[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
knight c3 b5 and look at magnus's face
[Music]
yeah he is not happy at all
panko is looking to beat
world champion magnus carlson
this is a historical moment for him it
is just
groundbreaking if he wins this game
he will be one of the only players
to have a winning record against magnus
carlson
and as i mentioned earlier magnus
carlson did not lose a classical game
chess for
games the guy is hard to take down and
in his first opportunity andre isapenko
is about to do the unthinkable
that's amazing that's just amazing
[Music]
historic moment he stopped the clock 18
year old grandmaster andre yesipanko
just beat the world champion in a
classical game
[Music]
and look at him that he is exhausted
from the fight that he just brought to
the world champion
[Music]
one of the best day in my life
yes i i feel very great and
i have nothing to say
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fantastic
[Applause]
hello everyone and welcome to the 84th
edition of this tata steel chess
tournament my name is fiona style
anthony and i'm delighted to be joined
by grandmaster robert has robert welcome
unfortunately remotely but how are you
today
you know i was going to say it's a shame
that it's so early in new york but the
real shame is that i couldn't be on site
with you commenting this wonderful event
but fiona i'm really looking forward to
it it's our first huge classical event
of the year
absolutely and we've got some big games
to look forward to already we'll get
back to that
in just a second but it's such a
pleasure to be here so i'm on site in
vaikansei you can recognize the blue
background
and the players will be arriving shortly
but robert let's first have a quick look
at a little bit of the history of this
event
yeah as you said it is the 84th edition
the first term was in 1938 it moved to
vikings a in 1968 and it's sponsored by
tata steel since 2011 so it's commonly
referred to as this tata steel masters
tournament but it has a tremendously
rich history sort of called the
wimbledon of chess
yeah absolutely i mean it's i think the
only tournament that has run uh pretty
much uninterrupted for the whole time i
think that it was only in
45 that the war stopped the tournament
for one edition but
one of the most traditional and always
such an exciting event with a a very
mixed field we'll get back to talk about
that in a second
as well so yeah absolutely a
big traditional tournament and a very
exciting one let's have a quick look at
what's at stake here this year
yeah magnus carlson he made it very
clear that he wants to get to 2 900 feet
day that is no small task but his
journey starts here we'll see if jordan
von forrest can retain his title he was
the surprising victor last year and he
is such a phenomenal force and a second
of magnus carlsen of course it's one of
the biggest the best events of the year
so we'll see who wins tata steel and
fiona speaking of huge events i mean the
candidates tournament is taking place
later this year we see duda we see
caruana we see karjakin and these types
of players and of course some of them
are taking part in tata steel yeah it
will be very exciting to see uh to have
a look at these three players see
how did they behave in the opening are
they gonna go all out will they be
playing some sidelines it's always
tricky to play a big tournament
like tata steel in a run-up to what will
surely for them be
the main event of the year
as we look to find the new challenger
for magnus carlsen and then we have to
see will magnus play so much chess
intrigue this year robert
remains to be seen but we do know the
chess.com coverage of the 2022
candidates tournament is coming this
june so watch the players you see on the
screen in front of you including alireza
farouza fabiano carwana yonda palmashi
and more as they battle out for their
chance to face magnus and tune into
chess.com tv to enjoy exclusive footage
of the playing hall and expert
commentary on every move
for now everyone should be paying
attention to tata steel go to
go.chess.com22
to find out all the information about
this event fiona and i we're gonna be
back shortly but go on chess.com events
to follow this one we'll be back soon
for the start of the tasso masters 2022
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
welcome back everyone so we're getting
closer and closer to the start of the
tournament less than 10 minutes to go
until we kick off here and robert we've
already seen a few players at least one
player i saw has arrived in the playing
hall the others tend to be often a bit
uh not late but they don't want to
arrive too early let's say
yeah if they're not exactly on time for
the start of the round then you're early
that's how chess works we see players
run up to their board the last possible
second but some players they like to sit
and relax in the playing hall right
absolutely yeah i think different
approaches for different players i think
it's a very personal uh take some like
to arrive early settle in while others
prefer to avoid their cameras
unfortunately there's not too many
people here once again the tournament is
closed two spectators only a few
accredited press people are allowed to
be in the playing hall let's hope we're
back to normal next year but for now
robert let's maybe have a look at who's
playing in this year's tata steel
tournament
yeah the tata steel event is never quite
the typical
participant list but i love this event
fiona we see the 14 players taking part
on screen here pragdanda in his maiden
tata steel masters event we'll see if he
can handle all these top players
but fiona you were there in person last
year as well you saw these players
firsthand i mean yes panko and jordan
van forest those were kind of the two
stars absolutely and i'm sure we'll be
talking about them plenty today i think
essepenko last year for me was really
the standout moment uh when he beat
magnus for those of you in the chat who
were here early you will have seen at
the little video which always makes you
a little bit even emotional i mean i was
here last year i interviewed i see panko
after the win and it was really a very
special moment as you mentioned jordan
of course he is defending a title which
was uh just as simply incredible result
and there we see uh yes penguin she has
arrived already at the board for a
second i wasn't sure is that the footage
from last year
or is it this year but no it is a live
footage from the playing hall
and what's your prediction actually uh
robert for this big matchup between
yasipanko and magnus carlson
oh gosh so i'm gonna buy myself some
time nobody has to know and i'm just
gonna talk about the format and the
schedule and then i'll think about what
my prediction is because there are these
14 players taking part the time patrol
is a long one so the players have plenty
of time to think about their moves
scoring is traditional you know i really
am just buying time i hope you know that
i'm just i didn't notice it's a good way
to buy time i mean we'll have plenty of
time to discuss it as you mentioned i
think the time control is at the longest
um on the on the circuit so i think
every day you guys in the chat will have
to make do with us for at least six
hours uh sometimes more so i strap in
for a long and exciting
uh tournament and let's have a quick
look at the schedule
so the schedule the tournament uh once
again one of the longest on the tour
will be here for over two weeks
um
the first one well it kicks off in just
over five minutes and then we'll have
three rest days the first after four
rounds and once again after four rounds
and a last rest day on january 27th so i
write that all down
and yeah robert
now that you bought you bought your time
what is what is your prediction gonna be
well
speaking of predictions before i make
mine i want to remind everybody to vote
chess.com events you can vote on the
result today's games if you go to
chess.com events navigate to the
tournament select a game click vote and
select your winner you could win a piece
of the 1 000 prize pool for best voters
or free diamond memberships voting ends
after the 10th move of each game so
don't miss out and remember to vote on
all the games
all right fiona i bought all the time i
possibly could i know we're looking at
the pairings for the round some great
match-ups and the one that i'm sure
everybody is most looking forward to is
the one you've asked me about
andre yesapanko and magnus carlson so
as we see all these great pairings i'm
gonna buy myself my last few seconds
i love those videos i love that these
are back
um it's always so great to see the the
players on the day they are well
before the tournament starts they do
these video shoots and photo shoots uh
little interviews you will see
throughout the tournament and there will
be those uh portrait videos where we
hear a bit more about the players and
yeah just uh very it even adds a little
bit of drama a little bit of gymnastic
wifi to the to the build-up
it certainly does and we see the great
pairings on screen for everybody all
right i'm just gonna go through this
andre yessipanko magus carlson i think
that game will be a draw i know that
andre won last year everyone was rooting
for the kid he was so happy you
interviewed him from this live on site
he was just jubilant but i think magus
carlson holds with the black pieces i
don't think he goes too crazy he doesn't
need to win just because he lost
previously so i'm gonna go
with the very exciting pick of a draw
fiona what do you think
yeah well if magnus concedes a draw we
talked earlier about what's at stake
during this tournament magnus has come
out and said his next big goal is
hitting 2900
he actually do you know what score he
needs in this tournament robert to to
hit it during this tata steel chest
tournament i actually do know the answer
uh i don't know if that's sad or
impressive but either way
he needs 12 and a half out of 13. so
let's be honest he's not getting
anywhere close to that he's not reaching
2900 in this event but maybe he can gain
a few points here and there as he works
his way towards that record
yeah i have to say i i agree with your
prediction of a draw but i also would
not it's really it's a it's a tough one
and where it's hard to call what will
happen we'll see also last year sipanko
had some very impressive uh preparation
what's it gonna be this year the players
of course haven't played that much
although ese panko also had a very uh
impressive world cup lost actually at
the hands of magnus carlsen but only in
the fast time controls and what's so
what's interesting about this matchup uh
as well is that andreya sepang was
actually the whole player the only
player in the whole field to have a plus
score in classical games against magnus
at the moment
that's a really good point then it's one
of those records that magnus carlsen
tends to hate i know when he had a
losing record against aneesh geary he
was always
the trolling couldn't happen because
anish had a winning record against him
but now that magnus is on top he can
continue his trolling but there's
other great pairings here in round one
i'm looking at fabinho carwana who has
taken a hiatus from his illustrious
commentating career to go sit at the
chessboard and play he gets the white
piece against karjakin i'm going to go
with a car want to win in that game
fiona um i think that fabiano will come
out sharp well prepared and for sergey
karjakin he's a formidable opponent we
know he took magus carlson to the wire
in the 2016 world championship but i
think fabi he's energized and his recent
rapid and blitz performances were also
quite impressive
yeah i feel like i can't agree with you
everywhere so i'm gonna go with a draw
there i'm gonna pick a couple of winners
only for today i'm gonna pick duda to
win
and i'm gonna
pick
anish and that's it
very great right now i like those picked
and i'm also going with jordan von
forrest with the win with the white
pieces against neil's grandiose he saves
his absolute best for white gonzai and
last year was that was no mistake he's
here to play he's here to try to win the
title once more and we have a niche
geary sitting here he's
i mean obviously he's a fascinating
human being he's very fun to follow on
twitter uh we both know anish pretty
well and he is so serious about winning
this event he's come
close he's tied in several events is it
his year at long last
yeah well we we will see i think last
year was a devastating
blow and well just as we say that the
clocks have started we see no handshakes
today so it's
we see no handshakes in this tournament
it's nothing personal but the players
have been asked to not shake hands
um before the round and we see that uh
yes panko against magnus is off and one
d4 is on the board
okay and that was a sicilian a year ago
so seeing d4 on move one perhaps andre
he's choosing a whole new repertoire or
he's avoiding specific preparation for
this game it remains to be seen but we
are in of course the very early stages
magnus not surprised about d4 on move
one
he shouldn't be surprised we'll see he
often actually takes a little bit of of
time and then adjusts all the pieces
which we see him do on camera now
and then we'll see how fast is the reply
going to come and what do you predict uh
robert do you think magnus is going to
take a solid approach or a more
ambitious one
i think the more interesting question is
did he say adjust right that's the
question that everybody wants to answer
to we're all going to freak out did he
say it on move one but i'd answer your
question seriously i think a solid
approach he starts with d5 i really
don't think he'll take risks today
because a year ago he did take risks in
the very nature of his opening with the
black pieces he really doesn't want to
lose again and there's like that
psychological pressure i'm the world
champion i've stated my goal to reach
2900 i need to start winning with the
black pieces against andre yessipanko
who's a a rising star in chess i think
he's going to play this one safe
i agree i think nobody wants to start a
tournament uh with a loss especially
like this kind of in this situation
where magnus has a minor score and he
doesn't want to to give vesti panko any
more grounds and just run so i saw in
the chat earlier when we were talking
about magnus uh wants to reach 2900 so
just to be clear he didn't say he wants
to reach it here and he just wants to
reach 2900 full stop
doing it here
will be a little a little challenging
yeah he is a very confident individual
but he's also realistic and he's not
going to reach 2900 here but that is his
quest and we see him on camera magnus uh
you know he's ready to play no matter
what tournament no matter when it is and
andre esopenco is not scared of magnus
and you know so far it is a very natural
start for the players we can go back
just you know we only have three moves
but the move e6 it shuts in the bishop
on c8 so your bishop has to remain
passive for now and that's a large
reason why white doesn't rush this
capture because white does then fiona
right e takes d5 is the response and
that bishop has new life
yeah
so we see instead is a panko developing
a knight it's always a matter of
preference which of the knights do you
develop first by developing the knight
to f3 you avoid certain lines of course
that's right
and um
right now we see
the night on f3
magnus still sitting and thinking here
but
um
it's early stages the player is really
just getting a feel for the tournament
and for the game itself so we can uh hop
to whichever game
catches your eye if you know and we can
just show everybody everything fabiano
who's the second seed here
um
he will be looking as well i mean i
think a lot of the players will be
looking to win this tournament it's such
an very often it's a an open quite an
open field but there were a few runaway
performances and one of them of course
was fabiano two years ago when he scored
an incredible 10 out of 13 i think one
of the the highest scorers to have been
to have been achieved here
and you mentioned it and after the
commentary stint he's back at the board
and i think he'll be very eager to get
off to a good start here with the white
pieces
yeah he would love to get a victory over
sergey karjakin who he'll face at least
two more times this year in the
candidates it started with d4
karjakin win knight f6 and then we had
an early d5 so if this position looks
familiar it's because this is what we
just left in yes panko and carlson here
we see the capture on d5 e tick so i was
just saying how you don't want to
capture too early 500 says you don't
know what you're talking about let me do
just that but the bishop is open on the
diagonal now the white is not unhappy to
play in this manner quick development
natural moves and that way there was no
capture on c4 available for black
sometimes you go for these more
dangerous and tactical lines
absolutely so also here a solid start uh
to the game
do you want to jump around a little bit
more or stick here for a minute
let's go to our bird's eye view because
we can show everybody
what's going on in every single game we
have all seven games available to watch
it's honestly difficult for me to look
at the scene because i don't know where
to focus my attention i'm like wait
there's that opening and yes of panko
against carlson but if i go in the
bottom right look at von forest against
grendel is a quiet line out of the
spanish and then i see invaded against
shanklin wait is that just the same
position as we saw in caruana against
karjatkin or are they going to find
their own territory here so it's really
fun to be in this scene but it also it's
a lot to take in
i mean look at dooba against mama jarv
in the top right
maybe we can go there for a second
that's a i think another matchup which a
lot of jazz fans who are very excited
about
um
two really creative players shakira
media if he was as high as the world
number two the last few years haven't
exactly gone his way but
such an experience absolutely top elite
player and
well duboff a lot has been said about
him recently famously he was on team
carlson for the the world championship
match
against uh nepo and not surprised that
carlson would want someone like him on
his team who always comes out comes up
with such uh creative and interesting
opening ideas
he really does i mean look at this game
i we haven't even started from move one
but as i sit here and look at this
position the last move play was pawn to
b4 which clearly attacks the knight and
often what black wants to achieve is to
create a pawn chain that's safe and
sound so if this knight moves out of the
way which it can right now let's say it
goes to a4 just to get out the way and
show a move then black can play this
move c3 and oftentimes you want to
create this pawn chain here which can be
very difficult for white to
get rid of that said the bishop on g2
clearly better than the bishop on b7 it
looks like white has a lot of pluses
despite those pawns fiona
yeah it's uh
maybe we can see how we got here because
we can see both players have played very
fast looks like both still familiar with
what's uh going on here let's see how we
how we got here
and we go back to the beginning so d4 d5
we started off with a little bit of a
slob um both sides not dealing with the
tension in the center not taking on c4
for black or taking on d5 with the trade
just yet and here we see
after g3 finally mama jarv takes in c4
so fiona these lines at least
historically they're known to be as
sharp as they come
are you the least bit surprised that
it's dubois and mama yara with this
opening no i'm glad actually because we
were a little bit uh worried that these
match-ups that look so promising on
paper sometimes they disappoint us but
not not this time
yeah well here
the capture on c4 says i'm ready to
fight let's do it bishop g2 b5 so black
is playing with all pawns and we know
from the queen's gambit the kara khan is
all pawns no hope here it's all pawns
and an extra one so let's just try to be
ambitious says mama jarv the move b5 of
course defends this pawn on c4 although
it opens up this diagonal so the bishop
on g2 is happily sitting here and trying
to expose that diagonal
so knight e5
a6 and fiona this is a really
interesting moment because this pawn on
c6
can be captured and uh if the knight
takes on c6 here it's like wait am i
winning in exchange because if knight
takes c6 bishop takes c6 is check and
it's also checked to the rook in the
corner but it's a good lesson
that when someone captures your piece
and you can capture back you don't
necessarily have to you're not forced to
and so after knight c6 the move in fact
is queen to b6 and that way if the white
knight captures the black one the rook
gets off the diagonal
and this is the kind of stuff i think
that the players have to be familiar
with it would be very difficult to
figure all of this out um
at the board but they are
following their preparation here still
so duboff decided not to take on c6
which i think a lot of people myself
included would probably do on a whim but
um
instead
yeah instead in the game of take on c6
he went oop sorry jumped ahead he went
castles and after bishop b7 defending
the pawn we saw b3 and that's where we
left off uh or where we started really
with the game is b4 by black because
black can take on b3
but in exchange for the pawn sacrifice
fiona white gets all these open files
and open lines
what's
your preference like do you prefer
material or the activity generally
speaking
i probably prefer the the material
i'm very very greedy like that because i
find very i can't play i struggle to
play with the initiative like sometimes
i want to give up a pawn or two pawns
and it looks great but you know the
opponent defense and there i find myself
a few hours later in the end game down a
pawn or two and
not having any fun i think it's really
an art to learn and it's so important
to become a good chess player to
to learn how to play with the initiative
and
it's also something i think a lot of the
players mentioned here during the
interviews the focus was a lot on
technology how the engines these days
are proving that you can really give up
a lot of material
for compensation that you can take more
freedom
with that compared to what chess used to
be a few years ago
that's entirely true and there's a
reason why magnus carlsen continues to
hire daniel dubov as his second because
dubois helps him prepare for the world
championship and dubois is known for his
creative ideas you say material not as
important as the initiative in some
positions dupont's the king of that the
amount of games we've seen
of his where he's down one pawn two
pawns but all of his pieces are active
and aggressive he loves these types of
positions and so does chakri or mama
jarov he
is not as young as dubois right he's
more of a veteran player and he has a
wealth of experience but it seems like
dubov is that new generation of wild
chess that the computer at first glance
like i don't know about that and then
you leave it and to sit and think more
deeply about the position and it
justifies those sacrifices so duboiv is
such a creative player and right now
he's down upon fiona and
the way i look at it i sort of agree
with you i look at these pawns on b4 and
c3 and i put them in yellow i don't even
like that color i'm putting in blue now
because i like that better that
they look like they're here to stay so
what is white going to do to deal with
these pawns which look like a thorn in
his side i'm also i have to say i'm
somewhat surprised to see daniel sink
into
his first thought
of the game here really
i would be shocked if the last couple of
moves came as a surprise because what
black played this b4 and c3 pushes
looked like at least one of the natural
responses
so
i'm curious what's going on is he just
trying to remember and he just as i say
that he was about to make a move and
he's played knight to c4
wow so he's looking at some of the
looser squares in black's position these
dark squares so b6 maybe a5 in the
future this bishop likely coming to f4
and there's no bishop d6 to fight for
the diagonal so i i completely
understand what he's going for
it's just this essential question of i
can visualize it you know i can see it
here but how to assess it and that's
always the difficulty when you reach new
positions is these top players they can
see
eight moves from this position without
really breaking a sweat but it's about
assessing those positions correctly and
right now this is such a great position
i mean honestly for our viewers who are
watching i would recommend putting a
position like this on your boards and
instead of just having the engine
assisting you just try to think what
would you do here and even with the
engine right i look to the side of my
screen here it says what minus 0.1 and
black is up a pawn we mentioned how
these pawns on b4 and c3 look very
menacing and yet the position is about
level it just went back to equal here so
how to assess this position let's start
talking about it right black has these
great pawns one of which is a pass pawn
on cedar all the way in white's camp but
in exchange for that pawn look at the
bishop on g2 better than the bishop on
b7 which is defensive piece uh the
knights on c4 and a4 are hopping around
into some of these squares the b6 square
the c5 square can always go back to e5
maybe d6 is whites for the taking but
fiona all that being said i can see
those pluses and i can point them out
but we need a concrete plan right we
can't just hope that we'll have
compensation we need to find the
compensation yeah so i guess one of the
ideas for danielle could try and fight
in the center as well as on the the dark
squares maybe try and get in e4
and then think about where what where is
he going to put the bishop
from c1
i guess that might be happy on f4 maybe
on g5
but indeed i think these i think one of
the reasons i these positions are so
hard to to understand um
like for myself i'm sure even
players may be a bit higher rated than
myself lower weighted i think it's so
hard to understand because there's no
concrete threats it's not like oh i'm
threatening this and this is how i'm
gonna prove my my compensation as you
said it's all about that peace activity
um and and the initiative and we see now
the players have sped up a little bit
more medeirov had played a5 very quickly
and that was met by a3 so daniel uh he
wants to challenge this uh queenside
pawns
yes and atex b4 can open up the a file
who knows if that will pay off for white
you know the rook on a1 the rook and
eight might have a bit of a stare down
and mama jarv we're speaking about his
experience he's no stranger to these
kind of crazy positions he's been doing
this for as long as he's played chess
and he plays this move bishop ac see
this is the type of game fiona where if
you show this to a student you're like
don't ever do this yourself please look
at this game i'll i'll walk you through
it but do not play like this yourself
because what black has done is moved one
piece that's not a pawn
and it's gone to a6 and moved two times
already white on the other hand is
castled has both knights out into the
action the bishop on g2 is developed
right like how do you even explain this
to
uh a newer player and i'm putting you on
the spot a little bit fiona it's all you
i think you just don't explain it you
just show it to them and say don't don't
do this whatever you do
i think you know i think it's really
very challenging and maybe you can
explain it to us but um i think very
often these days especially now that uh
i think chess has changed really a
little bit with all these you know alpha
zero ideas ai and all these neural
networks which i know absolutely nothing
about so i'm not going to go into it but
it's become even harder to to understand
games because i think
when we look at some of the classical
world champions
and we looked at their games i think the
ideas were a bit easier to understand
because they were following more
classical principles
and these days it's just sometimes very
very hard
i think for a lot of people to look at
these games and understand what is going
on so maybe robert you can try and
explain to us what is doing uh by moving
this bishop once again
and that's what is his idea
and i do agree with you by the way that
uh sort of traditional games from let's
say the early 20th century they had a
very like clear plan there was a
romantic era where they're sacrificing
all their pieces
plenty of times it wasn't a correct
sacrifice but also plenty of them were
correct uh but you know nowadays there's
all these crazy computer lines that are
influencing the way we play as you
mentioned neural nets as well so bishop
a6 what's the point of that move well it
does close the a file for the moment
which can be important it shuts the rook
on aid away from the rook on a1 if there
are some exchanges on b4 so that's one
point to notice and also this bishop can
come to the b5 square where it protects
the c6 pawn and allows the knight on b8
to develop so you may say let's go back
and move why not just play knight d7
right away that's a nice developing move
um the bishop on b7 still protects c6
and then you look at this position here
and you're like what is black's plan as
a follow-up what the 97 doesn't do is
help black cover the d6 square so bishop
f4 comes in very naturally and now i'm
looking to play knight d6 check and if
you have to take on d6 with your bishop
i control all the dark squares with a
bishop firmly planted on d6 now b4 is
loose c5 is available for white you
can't castle because the bishop of d6
will prevent the king from casting
because it can't go through check so
knight d7 looks like a useful developing
move but doesn't do the trick so let's
go back a turn and play bishop e7 right
let's just develop and so we can castle
next and what does that give up well
maybe there's the b6 square to take
advantage of for white that's something
that you have to keep an eye on or maybe
knight c5 where i'm just planting my
night here again saying please take me
because your bishop on b7 is under
attack now and if you take well i have
the d6 square available for my knight i
have the b6 square available for my
knight i am down a pawn and i'm happily
down upon because black has way too many
weaknesses to really be thrilled about
the resulting position
so that brings us back to
well other things that black wanted to
avoid and also bishop a6 let me ask you
if white were to pass here would we want
to simply take the knight on c4
it's a great question it's not my first
instinct because it does give white
another pawn towards the center a more
advanced pawn and but there are times
where you do just take that knight
because the knight can be a threatening
piece uh then black has two past pawns
that are unopposed there that can walk
up the board if white is not paying
enough attention to it so bishop takes
we'll store that in our back pocket i'd
say but i would not rush that decision
by any means
there is probably no need
to rush
as i don't think white can do anything
concrete in this position we see duboff
is still thinking while shaq is looking
looking very relaxed when we saw this
side camera he's just you know sipping
his tee looking away
uh from the board and from his time
management it looks like he is
certainly still familiar with this
position i would say
yeah i agree he does look pretty
confident i personally would not be it's
such a shaky position but mom and dad he
has lived for these types of games
throughout his career so why don't we
hop back to the bird's eye view we can
just sort of talk about every single
position that we have between these
players i'll start with vidit and
shanklin it's still early stages there i
mean that's known theoretical territory
so neither player should be out of their
element just yet fiona when you look
across here i mean what stands out to
you because for the most part we're
still in the opening stages yeah i mean
it's it's really hard to look past this
duba media
board because i think our eye is always
caught by by boards where there's
messiness going on it also somehow it
feels like these guys have twice as many
pieces
as the others as the other players vice
america
um
i think the game between anish and
pragnanda also looks interesting
whenever the queen is out sort of
early you kind of wonder what's going on
there
um and i think it's a big it's a big
game with prague you know making his
debut um on the highest stage
and so that looks interesting to me but
uh i think
all in all a pretty quiet story to the
tournament not too many extravaganzas
apart from dupofma
i am with you there so
most of the games still in theoretical
territory so we can continue to uh
analyze the positions as they leave the
book but this game between anish and
pragnanda as you mentioned that one
is fasting because there's a black queen
in the center of the board a white has
moved some pieces backwards the knight
to e1 and there's a pawn e4 for black
it's one of those big questions in chess
like upon e4 in this position is that a
pawn that's gone too far is that a pawn
that's you know happy to be there
because it did just kick that white
knight back and it takes away the d3
square as well as f3 so it's a nice
looking pawn that's one that and there
we see it the move f3 was just played
let me challenge that pawn open up files
and there's a queen in the center and we
often don't like developing her queen so
early because it can be kicked around
quite a bit but pragmata has been moving
pretty quickly so fiona do we think that
pragnanda had something like this
planned for
this opening or how are you feeling
about the time management and what that
says about the players
it's hard to say because i also i have
to admit that pregnant i'm not too
familiar with the openings that he
usually plays so
i don't know um
was this all
uh
was he following his usual repertoire
was there a surprise at some point maybe
we can quickly actually go through the
opening moves and and see
um how we got there but i think the time
um
the time usage of prague doesn't
necessarily mean
that he was surprised because because i
think it makes a lot of sense um for
prague who's making his debut here in
the masters he's the youngest
participant
uh in the
in the top group
it makes sense to to take your time on
the first day especially i think to sort
of ease into
the tournament and and not rush
i agree with that i think that it's
important for him to find his footing
here in the early stages of this event
game one out of a 13-game event a
grueling tournament and there are no
easy opponents so anish did play knight
f3 which invited the move e4 in this
game we saw
similar ideas
uh throughout
many top level events uh wesley so five
minute carwana and the like have played
this opening a number of times and so
knight c2 is the choice now e3 may look
like a great move for black because you
open up the diagonal and the rook on h1
is under threat but after e3 white can
just push f3 and now you have to take on
d2 and you're actually helping white's
development there's a queen in the
center that will soon be kicked out with
knight to c3 if you take on d2 the
bishop simply captures and you see the
evaluation bar going up because it's not
looking good for black so e3 hoping that
your opponent doesn't see the rook is
hanging not going to work out so instead
we said knight f6 and fiona here with
this queen on e5
and he just worked around it so he
bishop g2 knight a6 to try to get this
knight potentially to c5 or as in the
game went to b4 but look at this move i
think this is the fascinating moment and
is in fact a novelty by anish knight to
e1 so
what a decision here by anish you don't
just like retreat your knight
and
play like this unless you've prepared it
i would say and he quickly plays knight
to e1 so
that must register shock for pragmata
absolutely and it's actually the move i
was going to ask you about because i saw
in the chat i think espionage was asking
a very good question
a very good question what is the idea
behind
knight e1 which looks at first like a
weird move you're retreating the knight
to a square
where it has at the moment no future
because both d3 and f3 uh are covered by
the pawn
on e4 but i think with the move that
we've seen meanwhile f3 that is probably
giving us at least part of the answer to
to what the idea was behind 91
right to challenge that e4 pawn that's
been sticking out and the take back with
the knight which attacks the queen and
then we get this pawn structure that is
certainly not symmetrical where white
would have
these two pawns in the center and then
black has these two bishops pawns the c6
and the f7 pawn so white has
a nice looking position for
the start of the game when there are
more pieces on the board you tend to
want pawns in the center because they
restrict enemy pieces and so if program
does take on f3 which i don't know if
he'll do that right now but then knight
captures an f3 the queen has to move d4
e4 we see white advancing here and
black's pieces are not harmonious in
particular this knight on b4 doesn't
look ideally placed so i would
like this position for anisha and i
think that's why he went knight to e1
and
so he could take back on f3 with the
knight
yeah so let's go back and let's see what
are the alternatives for prague if he if
he doesn't take on on f3
what options does he have
he can throw in queen c5 check first and
that way when the knight captures an f3
there's no attack on the queen so like
king h1 would likely be played after a
queen c5 check and now when you take on
f3 and white recapture say with the
knight we get to a position where black
doesn't have to spend another turn
moving the queen and in fact can castle
here so i would think that queen c5
check is in a poor move to throw in and
eventually this queen will dart all the
way to the king side and maybe even be
able to attack
the white position
yeah you are making a good point here
because the white king
we see the black bishop from c8 which is
looking down that that white diagonal we
could picture it coming all the way to
to h3 potentially after the black queen
has found its way
to uh
to h5 also the knight could join some
attack via g4
uh so
i would like to see this kind of um this
kind of action unfold
but we will see
of course prague also has to worry about
his king safety the king is still in the
middle of the board do you think that
there is any alternative to canceling
kingside here or will we just see
it's a great question i think that
actually yeah you can delay your castle
because the kingdom is actually very
safe in the center we suggest castling
and especially newer players they learn
that you play in the center develop your
pieces and you castle but you don't have
to castle without thinking about it here
the king is safe so actually you're
right maybe you can develop this light
square bishop so start with queen h5
perhaps and then go for ideas with
bishop to h3 and castle queenside and
that way you can really attack the white
king that said black's king will also
come under fire on the queen side so
it's kind of a battle in this position
rather than having kings on the same
side of the board
yeah exciting stuff here and prague we
see him at the board he is still
thinking
um if we go back one more time to the
live position after after f3
so we looked at taking on f3 which we
didn't like we looked at queen
c5 what about a developing move like
bishop f5 developing one more piece and
trying to to defend upon
yeah i'm a little worried about exchange
sacrifice that was like my first thought
was like is this rook going to be able
to sacrifice itself for one of these
miners
on the file and i think the answer is
yes because
it we see pawn takes e4 and you don't
want to take with the bishop on e4 even
if you don't lose material because then
you hand white the bishop parrot if you
take with the knight on e4 then it looks
like a situation where
maybe rook takes f5 is a move d4 also
comes to mind just simply hitting the
queen here in the center and well after
rook takes f5 knight c3 pawn takes c3
this position has to be amazing for uh
white maybe i just take on e5 actually
and your knight gets trapped down in
enemy territory so
pretty much no matter what white capture
is it's going to be a problem for black
because this knight now here is stuck so
b3 and
i'm going to develop my bishop and get
your night here it actually looks like
it's just completely lost
yeah so it looks like that's not an
option
uh so maybe
there aren't that many options in the
current
position for
for prague if he um
can you think of any other move i'm
trying to think is there anything else
which is even a candidate move
i mean most moves lose a pawn so we
that's why we keep highlighting he takes
f3 ideas or bishop f5 so i think you
have to take on f3 at some point and if
that's the case i do like the queen c5
check thrown in first just to show one
more time ef3 knight f3 and let's say
you play queen c5 check then white just
plays d4 and d4 was not available if you
started with queen c5 check i think
that's really important to show fiona
because there's a certain rule in chess
it has
it's a french sounding name i don't i
can't remember what it's called
but there's this this move and
people will say you're cheating
and d4 does the same thing right
i'm looking at the chats because i know
they love the rule
who's going to be the first
one that's exactly it groovy money got
it in one
exactly right because when a pawn moves
two squares on its first turn you can
capture it as if it moved one and then e
takes d3 on poisson here gives me the
pawn
opens up the check once more black
steals material and of course is with a
huge advantage so uh that's why queen c5
check first is better than taking on f3
yeah so we'll see and oh prague has just
played and did he he took on f3 or am i
i think he did in fact take on f3
interesting i'm curious you had
convinced me robert video queen c5 i was
completely on board
but we'll see what prague is planning
here after i guess knight if f3 is the
move that makes sense hitting the queen
maintaining those central pawns
yeah and there he goes
and one more thing is
this king on h1 like
it may not seem like a big difference
because if he plays queen h5 here we can
get back to the position we were talking
about but the king is on g1 rather than
on h1 and those things do end up making
a difference but we can leave the
players to figure out you know what's in
store for them because uh i believe we
need to go to our first break the day
fiona
let's do it robert but some exciting
stuff here already
um
some big clashes we saw some really
really good action uh in the the duval
of mamadiarov game so stay tuned i'm
here from the first day from vikenze
tata steel chess and we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i just want to say i know it's early
yeah it's early for all of us but fabi
you're looking fresh no thanks danny
chad likes it man looking good
what what about me
all right guys let's go run a show back
here we go
and fabi this video series was great by
the way people love it
i really do
by the way again dude you're
you're just looking fresh man i love
your new haircut makes me good
hey how's it going
[Music]
[Music]
i don't even recognize myself and i was
like
the whole new me
[Music]
hey fabi danny how's it going hey robert
hey man
you know i'm just trying out a few new
things here and there the day's
beautiful sun is out
cool
hey danny yeah forgot to mention that
haircut's looking real fresh on you yeah
thanks man
cool
appreciate it
serious
what does a guy gotta do around here to
get noticed
what are you talking about
i
this seems a little out of line a little
uncalled for
you know you already can't spell chess
without what borders you want
[Music]
welcome back to the 2022 tata steel
chess tournament my name is fiona style
anthony
and still with me
is the fresh the smooth grandmaster
robert house
well i'm glad you say it because nobody
else was you know they were
complimenting each other the whole time
and so i just had to find a way to get
them to notice me it didn't work but i
appreciate you feeling i'm glad to be
commentating alongside you and i mean
i'm just so happy that there's more
chess to be played
absolutely well we have uh just liftoff
here in waikanse uh
43 minutes ago exactly and i think we're
just gonna go back to the bird's eye
view to get an overview of what is
happening on all the boards right now
and then
try and uh go through all the games and
the chat robert wants you to know that
they do notice you
and uh
i don't think i've ever ever seen anyone
have as many fans as you so i i don't
know if i buy the the act but anyway
let's go back to the games
uh well we have all seven on screen for
the viewers here and i mean i'm looking
at them some games farther along than
others i
don't even know what to focus on i'm
serious whenever we get in the bird's
eye view i both love and hate it because
i love it there's so much chest to look
at so many interesting positions i hate
it because i'm distracted and i feel
like my neck is on a swivel
yeah it's a tough one of course dubof my
media
is the one that still catches the eye
with
the pieces they almost look like they've
been thrown on the board at random so
we'll definitely have another another
look at that but things are
starting to happen of course it's still
early doors robert where would you like
to to start maybe a game we haven't seen
yet
sure let's go to the game between vidit
and sam shanklin both players have many
many fans both players are i think
they're sort of under
looks overlooked not under i wasn't
under-appreciated but that wasn't the
right word overlooked in a field like
this because people focus on magnus and
fabiano and then yes panko beat magnus
last year and jordan won last year and
nietzsche seeking his first title and
then you have these two players gujarati
and sam shankland who are both super
grandmasters incredibly strong talented
players who work so hard at their craft
and then it's like wait
no one picked them to win but also we
shouldn't
um we should not discard them absolutely
yeah like not at all because they can
beat any player in the field and we know
how talented they are and we are 10
moves into this game so let's go from
the top here
actually let me just say funny it's
funny that we would have watched your
your barber skit because uh sam has also
pulled a
skit on us yesterday when he came for
his interview he had this big beard but
today a nice and fresh trim the beard is
gone
oh wow i see you were at the
live opening ceremony i didn't get to
see it so i didn't even know that but he
is looking sharp he really tries to um
play his best chess and he's shown great
results in tata steel right he beat
vladimir krumnick
last game
[Music]
he ended kramnik's career
single-handedly
oh
well that is both an honor and for
chronic fans something that you don't
want to hear but uh either way sam
shanklin he is ready to play whenever he
is called upon and for vita gujrati uh
he was unable to play in the grand swiss
we know he's taking part in the grand
prix and it's great to see him back at
the board he has so many fans deservedly
so so we got off to a start with early
d5
c takes e-take so we talked about
keeping the tension here unlike the duba
of mama jarv game where duboff left the
tension for so long that mama jarv was
able to take on c4 we get a position
where there's a simple trade and white
quickly plays his bishop g5 move so
the start of this game is very standard
black reinforces the pawn on d5 that way
if your bishop takes f6
queen takes f6 the queen isn't needed to
defend this d5 pawn so everything here
is normal
e3
bishop e7 and fiona i mean the start of
this game here
also featured a night retreat so anish
played 91 sam plays 98
i think we can understand why sam did
this though
yeah
we can so sam is looking um to exchange
the dark squared uh bishops
to be honest one of the things that
surprises me a little bit about this
game is that the time comes on
consumption because all the moves that
we see
that we've seen so far i don't know
have we already seen a novelty it all
feels quite standard
but
well it is what it is and after 98 vidit
said no thank you i don't want to to
swap my
dark squared bishop so i'm going to go
back to f4 and sam said yes we will
exchange those bishops
bishop e6 and now there is no escaping
the trade
it any longer so he said at least let's
trade the bishops on my terms i'm not
gonna take you
instead goes queen f3
and
they're playing this little game of like
who's gonna be forced to take the bishop
first
um and i don't know does vidit
have to take now i guess we don't want
to allow black to capture our bishop in
this position uh to avoid being left
with an isolated pawn on d4 or how do
you feel
yeah no i'm with you i think taking or
knight to e2 both moves makes sense but
i do like the game as you describe as
cat and mouse because
vid is like i'm not going to trade
pieces and sam's like oh yes you are but
the reason why sam is so focused on this
is because when you have less space when
you're a bit more restricted you often
want to trade pieces because if you have
too many pieces they step on each
other's toes so for example in this
position the knight on e8 wants to go to
d6 or f6 so a trade would help black get
developed in a better way and the reason
why white has more space is because look
at what white did play the bishop on d3
which means that the f5 square was
covered and then played the move pawn to
h3 as well which means that the g4
square was covered so the bishop on c8
just doesn't have the same promising
diagonal that the bishop on d3 does so
that bishop is very strong on d3 the
bishop 168 is worse than his counterpart
so that's why sam is looking for some
trades
yeah and i'm sure he would love to trade
i'm looking at bringing the blackbish
about to f5 i don't think we can work it
we can make it work now or
no unfortunately not because uh you will
take on d6 and
i think i actually stopped
my favorite tactic in chess stopping one
square short of expectations because
bishop takes d6 knight takes d6 and then
the knight protects the bishop but here
i go
bishop e5
your queen's under attack so you have to
deal with it and after the trade your
queen is still under attack and then
this bishop is lost on f5 thanks to the
bishop and queen teaming up on it so
it's my favorite tactic in chess i also
think it's the easiest tactic or one of
the easiest to overlook and especially
when rooks are on the same line like
you're like oh rook is coming down to
trade rooks and they stop one square
short of your rook on the seventh rank
oh wait now my position is falling apart
so i love tactics like this and
unfortunately for sam that means he
cannot play bishop f5
yeah so the move that you would like to
make you cannot uh you cannot make so
will we see sam now take on f4 i don't
think he wants to because he would keep
uh improving white's pieces what would
you what do you think
vidit would probably take with the
knight and keep the queens on the board
or would he be looking for a queen trade
it's such a good question because my
first instinct just take with the knight
and continue my initiative but even
queen takes f4 does look better for
white because if we trade queens let's
say black takes white takes back
why has three minor pieces developed and
black has none right black hasn't moved
any of the pieces besides pawns off of
the last rank here and so white should
be better can play g4 it's a type of
move that i think we underestimate
because we think g4 there's no attack
but it's not just about the attacks
we're restricting squares from the
opponent so if black were to play knight
d6 just to go uh one
uh move deeper g-force is no bishop f5
for you it's a white game space and
we're just talking about how when a side
has less space they want to trade pieces
no bishop f5 trade for you no knight f5
nothing like that and so white is in the
driver's seat
yeah it looks like uh
it's nothing nothing dramatic is
happening yet but certainly a position
that's a lot more pleasant to play for
with it with with the space advantage
and sam will have to figure out how to
get
his pieces out
uh i suggest we come back to this game
in a little bit maybe we jump back again
to the the birds eye view or we just
jump to to another game
well here we are
in the bird's eye let's see what else
haven't we we haven't seen duda against
report
at all should we go there for a second
i mean it's the world cup champion i
think that it's always
worthy to go to dudes games and he also
he lost the tiebreaker to magnum maggots
using maxime vashi lagrav in the world
blitz but he tied for first place in the
world blitz won the world cup what a
2021 yanchez of duda had so let's go to
his game and
we're playing rapport who's i think one
of everyone's favorite players because
he's an electric style and i just saw
the move rook to b8 played and so my
first insight is ooh i don't really like
black's position because it's a rook on
b8 a very valuable piece simply
defending a pawn but then i look at how
solid the position is for black all the
minor pieces are coordinated quite
nicely it's a harmonious looking
position but fiona what's your initial
gut reaction to this position
i think my gut feeling is i like white
whenever i see a bishop and a queen a
line like that i already get some some
dreams of of sacrificing some days it's
making something happen on the light
squares i don't think it's gonna happen
as you said the black position is uh
rock solid uh black is probably just
gonna castle uh king side maybe even on
the on the next move
so then i think okay instead of getting
excited about non-existent ideas
probably what i should do as white is
get my king into safety so
i guess castling must be one of the the
candidate moves and then
another candidate surely would be
developing tonight from b1
um i would say that c3 uh is the the
natural developing square unless you
think there's something to be said for
knight d2
the only thing i guess that can be said
is it leaves a c file open but i'm
not really
that uh
tied to the idea of 92. i like knight c3
uh but if you know i guess as i'm
racking my brain and you were just
talking i was listening to what you're
saying like is it one of these positions
that optically looks really good for
white but then you sit and think and
like but why like is that just my gut
reaction that's maybe not accurate here
i think that's what i'm coming to a
realization about that i like white but
then i have to think about why do i like
white's position and it's maybe because
rookie looks strange but then again
black blackenstart trading pieces and is
so solid here that i'm not really sure
what white's plan is i like the look of
the position but what is actually going
to happen here that should leave white
with anything real
yeah i i agree with you and we see duda
has just started with knight c3
one of the questions i have is can he
get the e4 push central pawn push in
if we can make that happen
is that going to give us anything at
least it will get give us more control
over the central squares but it's not so
easy at the moment black is covering
that square
twice
so i was thinking maybe we casted rookie
one but all of that takes some time to
prepare the e4 push and then i wonder
can black
strike
uh maybe uh try and attack our centum
with
c5 is not possible unfortunately because
the bishop on d6 would be um
would be hanging so i wonder what are
the ideas like how is
black does black even want to stop us
from playing e4
um does black simply want to trade on on
on
which also looks like a very reasonable
option
i think that looks pretty decent right
where you trade and you can play for c5
you could also throw in this b5 move
because white can never take on b5 since
you walk into a pin so i was hating on
the move rook v8 like i didn't like the
look of it but now that we got here i'm
like wait a second that rook is really
useful where it sits because now i can
play b5 you can't capture uh just to
show that uh so everyone can see that no
matter if you took the bishop or the
knight you'd lose the piece that is a
pin so whatever captures an e5 can't
move without losing a heavy material and
if you have to retreat back to e2 then
your move c5 makes perfect sense to me
and all of a sudden black is pushing
forward here in a way that
doesn't look very pleasant for white
yeah and i think you're absolutely
correct with what you were saying i
think when we first tuned into this
position it's very easy to get a feeling
of like oh this looks nice for white but
so often when you sit down and you
you start actually thinking about
um what is going on in this position
what are the ideas for both sides and uh
you've convinced me i think that richard
report probably has a
quite a comfortable uh position here
i would say even very close to to
equality
yeah it's one of these things where it
can get dicey if you're not
showing pinpoint accuracy and maybe
white can make black's life a little bit
more difficult because i just castle
thinking of course i'm going to castle
again my king on the center but one
question that really needs to be asked
because we keep talking about c5 breaks
for black that was your idea fiona is a
great one that maybe white at some point
can consider taking on d6 i don't really
like it in terms of playing for an
advantage because if we uh make a
symmetrical pawn structure black is
about to play d5
yeah
you're not quick enough for white queen
a3 oh double attack on your two pawns
it's not real like you probably can't
take on c
a7 in most positions anyway but even
still white can just assuming black can
just play the move d5 and protect one
pawn move the next one to a6 and what
are you doing is way right you're not
really playing for an advantage yeah but
it's a good point you're making i had
seen earlier comment in the in the chat
pointing out that the a7 point is weak
and i
kind of dismissed it at first but then
uh when you pointed out this tactic it's
something that black at least always has
to be on the
on the lookout for because
certainly you can take the pawn in every
situation but there might be some
situations where you can and you don't
want to be caught out
no that's
very true and well we did see the move
b5 so uh rapport lashes out says you
can't take me on b5
dude very quickly retreats to e2 and
it's one of these moments fiona where we
were talking about b5 but then i also
wonder was it too soon like because he
played b5 now he has to deal with that
pawn on b5 like if the queen moves away
from b3 then you have to
either protect the b5 pawn or push it so
you sort of made your
intentions clear which can be good in
some positions and other times like wait
now white can change his entire plan and
now they're squares that black may have
lost if you can't play the move c5 like
then white will stop c5 and then you
have these square c6 and c5 and the
backwards c7 pawn
yeah a very interesting positional
battle at this one i suggest that we
leave richard to it and we will come
back here maybe it's time to go back to
our world champion
magnus carlson and see how his game
against andreas panko has progressed
okay always a good idea to look at
magnus carlson chess games and andre
yestepanko he's has a position here
which is very solid but
these positions hurt my head fiona i'm
going to be honest with you like i look
at them not a single p oh
as soon as i say now single piece has
been traded he takes on d5 but to that
point
not a single piece had been traded and
now the question is
okay i can't even ask my questions
because they're answering them before
it's like well do you take with the pawn
on d5 you have to because the h7 pawn
was hanging if the knight took on d5 but
there are some positions where you do
take with a knight rather than pawn and
so fiona we're here
hanging pawn type of structure
do you think magnus is feeling good
about his position because based on time
management both players have been
thinking approximately the same amount
yeah it's the kind of position where i
mean i really struggle to
to fully uh appreciate all the nuances
of these
phone structures and the slight
differences in where you develop your
pieces but i always think that's the
kind of position where shirley magnus i
think he is really at home um he
has the best chess understanding
in the world he's so well versed i think
in
in all all the classical
chess
structures pawn structures
so i think he should definitely
i think he'll be happy not to have
gotten like a sharp opening battle
like last year where i think andre is
somewhat surprised him so i think magnus
really will be happy
yeah i think he sort of learned his
lesson of what to do what not to do
against andreas panko and sometimes that
just comes with
getting those games under your belt and
magnus is the best in the world he has
been for so long but that doesn't mean
in every single game he will win or be
the best player in that individual game
and so right now we see this position
where white can take on c5 leaving black
with this choice do i play b take c5
known as the hanging pawn structure and
in the hanging pawn structure your pawns
don't defend one another but if your
pawn moves forward let's say c4 then you
hand white the d4 square and if you push
forward with d4 then you hand white c4
and e4 square so those pawns they can be
at risk for white's rooks attacking uh
in the center but there are tactical
motifs here where
black pushes d4 and then bishop on b7 is
unleashed and takes that knight on f3
and all of a sudden with first the light
square bishop then the dark square
bishop
the white king could be in trouble so
i've always been a fan of hanging pawn
positions not because i understand them
but because every time i watch the games
it's like a tactical melee and it's
fascinating stuff
yeah and i'm curious what is andre going
to do if we go back
to the the current position
so as you said he could take
i think he isn't going to do it for the
exact
reasons that you just
talked about i don't think you want to
give magnus that kind of
dynamic uh possibilities
i i'm wondering what would i do instead
can i simply maybe continue my
development bring the rooks you
highlighted those two squares c1 d1 i
think are natural squares for the work
so do we simply start with that
um
what are do we have any other
options what do you think
i think rooks to d1c1 make perfect sense
i'm not sure
which to play first it's one of these
situations where i probably play rook f
to d1 just because there's potentially a
hanging pawn on d5 if black's not
careful but i think the plan is clear
rook d1 rook c1 and one important note
here is that at some point we can take
on c5 but we don't need to rush that
decision because black isn't going to
take on d4 let's play rook d1 and if
black plays pawn takes d4 then white
very happily can play knight takes d4
black still has an isolated pawn this
knight is hopping in the center maybe f5
maybe to b5 and now it's white's bishops
who that are very happy and there's
bishop on b7 is stuck behind a pawn on
d5 so
since ctx d4 isn't really an idea that
black wants to go forward with i would
start with rook d1 maintain the tension
but also potentially putting a rook on
an opening file
yeah and i think you know i was saying i
think magnus
will be happy but i think andre will be
similarly happy i think white
has no problems here
i think white has probably the slightly
more pleasant position to play i saw i
know robert that you love the the engine
bar and evaluation
oh gosh you know me so well fiona
so i thought the chat was going a little
bit crazy when it said plus 0.7 now it's
gone down to plus 0.5 but um what do you
think it doesn't mean necessarily that
this panko is much better but and i
guess we would both prefer to play this
on the white side
yeah and i think that we're in a pretty
standard position so when the players
are looking at this they know from
experience from preparation from all of
their practice games against their
trainers and seconds so they're in
relatively familiar territory despite
the time consumption so i don't think
that they're thinking of this position
as
in engine terms because they know that
most positions 11 moves out into the
opening will be slightly better for
white but it's really about how you
handle the next
let's say eight moves because with the
potential of a hanging pawn structure
that could end up in a very precarious
situation for black with the pawns being
targets or it can be an attack unleashed
as soon as this d4 pawn is gone from
white black will be considering d4 like
every single move right like after dc5
bc5 black will consider the move d4
pretty much at every turn to open up
this bishop on b7 a fiance bishop is on
the longest diagonal it wants an open
line in front of it so the move d4 has
to be considered move after move so i
just think that it gives black some
additional options and if i were andreas
panko i don't want to hand magnus any
play whatsoever you are going to
passively sit and wait until the coast
is clear and one more
thing to note fiona before maybe we
either look at different game or just at
different lines this pawn on d4 is so
strong because there's a knight three
squares away a pawn
just controls that night's forward
progress when it's three squares away
from the knight so there is no knight e5
there is no knight takes c5 which is
also a possibility after dc5 if white
were to choose that move black doesn't
have to accept hanging pawns you can
accept an isolated pawn and tape with a
knight on c5 this is a stylistic
preference but the knight is active the
c file is open and so instead of having
hanging pawns you could accept the iso
isilani in the center and play for uh
the open lines around it
yeah i think you're absolutely right
although the position looks um very
standard and relatively simple there are
no complications yet in the position i
think there's a lot to consider here for
both players and i think you're
absolutely right that i think in the
next few moves we will see
which turn this this game will take
for now um how about we check in with
the the the defending champion jordan
van perraised who is playing white
against neil swandelus we haven't seen
too much of that game yet so let's uh
let's go there maybe
okay well here we are and
we haven't seen too much of it because
i'm doing a quick count uh precisely
zero pieces have been traded and just
because there have been no trades
doesn't mean that it's not an
interesting position but this one in
particular
nothing there's no tension there's there
are no pieces attacking one another i
expect that at some point white would
like to play the move d3 to d4 and
create some of the tension but if you
know when i look at a position like this
i'm like oh it's totally fine and then
when you play rather than look at this
position you calculate every single turn
is the move b4 for black really an idea
you want to play or does that allow
bishop to a4 now that the pawn is pushed
the diagonal is open does white want to
play d4 or maybe black can take on d4
opening the e file or does black want to
maintain the tension and keep upon e5 i
know i'm sort of spit balling lines here
but the point is that's how these
players are going through a position
like this and there's a reason why niels
grandelius is down to an hour and jordan
has an hour 25 he typically is very fast
in the opening but the point stands that
you have to be careful the engine off to
the side here says zeros but the
position is actually very complicated
it's rich
full of ideas so fiona if you you know
look at neil that's a good friend of
yours is he looking comfortable here
it's a funny moment to ask me that
he's looking very thirsty
um
no i i
i think the time alone is always an
indicator if you spend
um so he spent what he spent 40 40
minutes already
well more with the increment
uh
i wouldn't say he's necessarily not
comfortable but also i think there's
also the psychological
element that this game is actually
as jordan put it last night in the
opening ceremony they are continuing
where they left off last year because
this was actually
the last round
pairing with the same colors
where jordan beat nils last year to
reach the the playoff
against anish
giri so i think that always gives you a
little bit
of a
of a psychological
edge
and then as you say
i think from the position there's all
these different breaks that white has
there's so many things you need to check
at every turn so
um i think jordan will certainly be
quite happy talking about last year as
well um last year jordan had attributed
a lot of his success to his second mark
swarmadam
from the netherlands but this year the
the second teams have been mixed out and
mixed up quite a bit because max is
playing in the challengers group himself
so jordan
is helped by grandmaster m zipker
who i believe was one of his early day
coaches and niels is helped by grand
master cosmos svana
wow and you can see actually not just
the players that we've been focusing on
but all the players and the masters and
the challengers tournament so max he's a
little bit busy he may not be seconding
any of the players helping them with
their preparation because he needs to
help himself he's playing the challenger
section he would love nothing more than
to represent uh his
country in vikings a and play in the
master section next year if he can win
the challengers group interestingly
enough max uh has his own uh legend here
he's played in vikanze so many times
before and mark's second is none other
than luke van veli
oh wow i didn't know that that's uh it's
funny how this it feels like there's a
cycle of seconds here right like we know
that uh anish has worked with aaron for
so long but
chris master love me is playing in the
challenger so who's anish here with
right he's also very interesting second
anisha is working with uh ari antari
oh okay and our antare a compatriot of
magnus carlsen which is funny because
aryan used to work with magnus and
jordan used to work with anish
and then it seems like there's been a
swap
well it's just a game of musical seconds
yeah and there we see for those of you
who are not sure who we were talking
about on the screen that is max warmer
dumb who was here last year as a second
uh two-year-old inventor race but this
year he will be looking to make
some waves on the chessboard himself
yeah and he is a great player in his own
right as many of the seconds are you
mentioned so many illustrious
grandmasters working with these players
trying to help them stay in shape for
this tournament so
if we dive a little bit into this
position so we can actually rewind and
go through the moves because we're not
in a particularly unique situation we
saw spanish
a6 bishop a4 dropping back knight f6 d3
so
jordan commits to defending this pawn on
e4 but what that indicates as we see the
game continue is a quieter position
you want to strike with d4 at some point
but that pawn e4 needs a defender and
that's why the players can play in this
manner g6 say i'm going to fianchetto
the bishop i don't have to play bishop
e7 i'd rather fianchetto and get ready
for the eventual d4 push so fiona i mean
this has all been seen many times i've
played both sides of this position a
bunch and it's all about that first
break and we see the move coming up here
b5 the first real pawn push uh getting
active but it still doesn't indicate
what's to come
yeah actually sorry i was getting
sidetracked because i thought of yet
another subplot to disappearing between
jordan and niels i think jordan was
actually the one who replaced niels on
team team magnus
because niels worked a couple of times
two or three times as a
as a part of the the match team for
magnus
and this year i think the only change
was kneels out jordan inn
so we'll see if niels will be looking
for revenge but i think both players
here very well worst
in the spanish opening i think from from
both sides
so you're saying there was only one
change in the makeup of the team and
then suddenly magnus wins all of his
games so i'm not going to blame niels
for the draws in the previous world
championships you said it not me i'm
just reading between the lines
i didn't say it but we'll we'll let
everyone draw their own their own
conclusion
but sorry robert you were just saying uh
about uh about the game what were you
saying about b5
oh i was just saying that you know black
was sort of the first to strike forward
even though it's not attacking anything
the move b5 indicates that black's not
just going to sit and be passive and
there's a move on the other side of the
board how about g5
it's something that you have to consider
from both points of view because when
you play the move g5 you're of course
attacking the bishop but it's not just
about that it's about freeing up your
pieces so the bishop will retreat to g3
the peace sacrifice will not be good
here so we retreat but now this knight
can come to e3 and this f5 square
becomes vulnerable and white can try to
take advantage before black is able to
make this move pawn to f5 because if
black could jump forward and push pawn
f7 f5 that's sort of a way to justify
these pawn pushes but when you have
pawns two squares apart like this the
square in between is your opponents and
now knight e3 which is what was the plan
anyway with d4 on the horizon it could
be a long-term issue for black to deal
with even though at first it looks like
black is gaining some momentum in the
position and i think that's another
reason actually why niels is spending so
much time because
if he is considering
moves like g5 those are very committed
moves once you've made that pawn push
you cannot take it back pawns don't go
backwards so i think it's normal for
players to invest
an extra amount of time
if they are considering committed moves
such as um such as uh g5
that's correct and
well we'll see what neil's place he's
spending a lot of time at this point why
don't we go to the fabiano game against
karjakin because it's the one game we
haven't pulled up uh on the full screen
here and it's
a game between i don't even know what
fatherhood's current ranking is i was
gonna call them the world number two but
i know that alireza foruger fans would
have just jumped on me for that and it
was just i'm used to saying five minute
carwana world number two he was number
two for so long he's what number four
now is that correct number four i think
that's correct yes
okay so
i corrected before i could even make the
mistake out i just wanted everybody to
know that i was wrong so here we see a
position uh well okay at first glance i
really like white's position i thought
you are going to be really happy because
there is less pieces on the board so
less work for us here
there is a bit less work that's true but
i'm just looking at the position white
is active and aggressive black is
passive and if there's any player on
this planet who can successfully fend
off this position and make it look like
black was never worse it's sergey
karjakin the amount of games where he
has what looks like a dubious position
and then he makes like an easy draw or
even wins those games it's just
unbelievable so he is perfectly content
to sit in a position like this will he
play c5 that's a really important
question on one hand it gets rid of this
target on c6 but on the other hand it
makes d5 potentially vulnerable and you
know one other thing i notice here is
just like the placement of the knights
white's knight on c3 i mean of course
it's better than a knight on the rim and
the knight on f3 can jump into e5 and
then f6 doesn't have the same
opportunity on e4 so i really like the
look of this position for caruana but
i'm going to say that and then sergey is
going to do something and just make a a
miraculously easy hold also i mean you
pointed out that the knight on f6
doesn't have the same same opportunity
to jump to e4 but also the knight on f6
is not defended by a pawn so there are
also potentially some weaknesses
along along the dark squares around the
blocking so i i certainly agree
with you i am like fabiano's position
a lot
but as always the the big question is
how do we uh how do we make progress
here as as white
i would make a quiet move i would make
the move h3 because i don't think that
black wants to play c5 it's one of these
moves where
you do want to play it but then you
immediately immediately after you play
it you're like wait a second my d5 pawn
because we just talked about this in the
magnus game with yesopenko like it's not
like playing c5 just makes all of your
problems go away and here there's no
bishop on b7 so that pawn on d5 could
become a true weakness a vulnerability i
maybe block can get away with it but
you're going to have some long-term
issues to deal with and so i still
prefer white's position even with a
quiet move like h3 that was just an
off-the-cuff move but the point still
stands that i think that white can waste
a little bit of time as black
even after striking with c5 is going to
be worse
yeah and i i think it's also you know
you're saying of course sergey is so
well known for defending these difficult
positions but i also think and you know
it better than most people i think
fabiano is also excellent
um at converting
these small advantages so i think we're
going to see a very
uh interesting battle here
with fabiano clearly the one pressing
he certainly is and well we know that
fabi
he's looking fresh his chest is looking
fresh
we're going to try to freshen up because
we're going to head to a break just to
you know get some water see what the
players have in store for us when we
return but there is much more to come
from this 2022 tata steel chess event
you will not want to miss the action see
you very soon
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i have no insights as to whether or not
madness will take his revenge
but you can get insights in chess.com a
new way to understand your games on
chess.com has arrived check out
chess.com insights to see detailed stats
and analysis across any time frame or
time control what time of day do you
play best how often do you botez gambit
these questions and many many more are
answered at chess.com
insights and back to tata steel we go
invite gonzay magnus carlson he just got
off from his chair and he's playing
andre yes panko the player who defeated
him and fiona actually we didn't talk
about this but is that the last game
that magnus carlsen lost in classical
chess
yeah he he lost dude in the in uh the
rapid tie break right in the world cup
and someone in the chat that knows
everything that is all knowing i'm sure
someone would
oh
excuse me
my mic is lying on the floor
i was wondering why it was much more
difficult to hear you and i i wasn't
going to say anything in front of all of
our viewers you know
it wasn't going to be me who
made that known but
yeah i guess you might no i just uh i
literally just went to to bin my my
empty water bottles and i i left to like
my to mike lying on the floor but it
shouldn't be all good now apologies
about
about that i think they should be able
to hear me
now yeah yeah okay
there's a literal mic drop
literally
exactly and so we're waiting for someone
from
someone from the chat to enlighten us
about
was that the last classical game magnus
lost i can't think of any uh from the
top of my
my head but um i'm sure we will
we will be
informed and
the game here
not too much has changed andrei did
decide to go for rook d1 at the moment
where we we left it off which was i
think one of the moves that we were i
think you had
uh pointed out this putting this rook on
the d file the pressure on the the d5
point
magnus responded with rookie eight
and the other came to c1 we called this
one pretty good and magnus plays another
quiet move a6
um taking away the square on b5 but
do you think he might also be preparing
a b5 push what are the ideas behind a6
i think he's mainly taking away the b5
square say from a timely knight b5 or
even a bishop b5 and
you can play b5 i'm just worried about
these isolated pawn positions because
if white were to take on c5 right now
black will take with the the pawn on c5
and create the hanging pawn structure d4
coming we talked about all these
tactical threats where i think white's
actually worse at this point i would
take black position so
if you play b5 for black then white can
take on c5 and you have to take with a
piece which leaves you with this
isolated pawn and white has control of
the square in front of the isolated palm
which is very important so i don't think
he's going to play b5 at least not in
the near future but it is something to
keep in mind as the game continues
yeah so
now that we have put our rooks to the
natural squares
c1 and d1
i was just going to ask you how do we
continue buddy panko has just made a
move so he's going to answer that
uh for us and the move he played was
bish
bishop
oh sorry i didn't refresh your bishop
five here which makes sense you're
getting more aggressive you're
anticipating rook c8 not that the pin is
that meaningful but if the real
compensate the knight will in fact be
pinned and you're opening up your deep
file all at once so i totally get that
move i think that magnus probably still
can play rook c8 uh there's nothing
wrong with it tactically speaking uh but
there are times when after rooks see it
like there can be crazy moves like
knight e5 it's not a move that should be
played right now but the point is that
this knight on d7
if it moves you lose the rook on c8 but
if and if you take and say something
like this happens and rook takes e5
there's a bishop on b2 and there's a
rook on e5 which isn't happy to see that
bishop there so these kind of positions
can actually be very
tricky and so black does need to be
careful at the moment with that bishop
105. and sorry robert to interrupt you
but magnus was just pulling a funny face
like i think in general magnus is
is a player um when he's in a bad
position i think we all know those
facial expressions
uh he pulls
but he's making um
a different face
today i know that you and danny
over there have perfected the art of the
different faces what is it the how many
faces of hikaru
and so what do you read into
into this magnus look here
please don't
put me in the same sentence as danny
when it comes to reading faces um some
of us read books others pretend to read
faces
that's all i have to say on that
um but
i think
i think he's uh you know he's fine right
now he's up on the clock his position is
very solid and i'm starting to wonder at
what point will he try to play
for not a win you're not playing for a
result but saying let me be a bit
ambitious here take a risk perhaps
because magnus he really loves to fight
and we'll see if he can find some sort
of fighting line that allows him to play
not just for
a solid position to hold but in fact to
play for more
yeah i agree with you i don't think he
enjoys just sitting and waiting and
defending so for sure at some point
i think he will start looking for for
some active
uh ways but
we will let him uh we'll let him have a
look doesn't look like it's quite there
just yet and maybe we can go back uh to
daniel duboff and mom india if i saw in
the chat about around 10 minutes ago
some people were saying that daniel's
position
was already looking close to collapse so
let's maybe just catch up with with what
we've missed here
okay well knight a4 we saw this position
c3 and at first glance like how could
you allow those pawns to inch forward in
this way black's position looks great
knight c4
a5
and then a3 was played so we left off
here where black one bishop a6 so
to my eyes to move bishop f4 fiona that
looks
incredibly logical developing a piece
fighting for some of these dark squares
bishop b5 played by
shock makes perfect sense to me as well
you're protecting c6 so the knight can
develop from b8 you also can take either
knight at some point if
this position calls for it and wow that
was the move that the engine really
didn't like and it's moved pawn e2 to e4
which they say is best by test the best
first move but apparently on move 14 in
this position it wasn't that great of a
choice and i think
we can get behind the move in terms of
the ideas you're pushing upon for the
center you're taking control of the d5
square maybe white at some point could
try to break on d5 you can push that to
e5 to attack the knight but you're also
closing in your bishop fiona and as we
know from many catalan types of
positions that once you play e4 you
often times you want to take that move
back
yeah
i mean also the bishop on b5 we just
talked about it that bishop just came
there you said you know it's looking at
both knights
but also that bishop is now becoming uh
more powerful now the knight on c4 is
suddenly pinned to the rook uh on f1 so
maybe that rook would need to
go to e1 at some point but now the yeah
the
light squared black bishop
just gets a lot more
uh possibilities in this position as
well
yeah it's one of these positions where
like
we talked earlier about this tension and
in general keeping the tension or not
but i'm wondering if this kind of pawn
trade who that favors in such a position
because the open a file
as black king is in the center if i can
move my knight from a4 at some point and
just take over the a file maybe that's
the kind of compensation that white is
looking for and perhaps just queen c2
try to move this knight next and as i
said fight for the file but black is
ready to move this knight from b8 it
doesn't have to stay put it can go to d7
which means the queen defends the brook
on a8 and that means that white isn't
just winning the file for nothing so
i
i don't know it's a hard position to
assess here um having the eval
off the side doesn't really help me
honestly as i look through it but i i
the movie e4 in general in these
positions where the bishop on g2 is so
strong
it often is a move that you can regret
so e4 was played and look at this knight
to b6 the rook just slides up to a6 and
now black wants to take
two pieces for the rook and dubois
played a4
trapping the bishop on b5 and you know
what that means fiona's look at these
pawns here look at this chain i mean you
can't get rid of that pawn chain ever
yeah
i don't know those points look
very scary especially because of the the
fact as you say that now we just simply
cannot get rid of them
after a4 has been played
and now the question for
what are his options of course the the
most natural move to look at is bishop
takes
c4 but i guess the question is can we
take
on b6 so what's the what's the
alternative
such an interesting position because
rook takes b6 if white were to take on
b6
white can just
give up because after bishop takes f1
you take this bishop back and you lose a
knight and then black ends up a full
piece ahead you see the evaluation bar
says what is that minus 6.7 so clearly
winning for black because you win a
piece so after
rook takes b6 you have to take the
bishop on b5
and now after rook takes b5 black is up
two pawns but in fact fiona i don't
really love this position
compared to just bishop takes c4 i have
more material but when you have fewer
pawns you have more open files and the
rook on a1 is staring at this a5 pawn
black's position in general looks kind
of awkward white has the two bishops and
this bishop on g2 is unopposed at least
on some of the diagonals
unfortunately
go ahead yeah crazy and take back on b5
with the
pawn
oh
i think
it's interesting but a5 does fall so i
can even take on b6
and after queen b6 i can take on b8
you're just gonna take everything
but yeah i wanted to keep those
pawns but you still have the more
important ponzi even if you lose b5 i
strongly believe that black has great
compensation because of the pawn on e4
so even if this pawn is going to be lost
your b4 and c3 so black always will have
compensation but with open files and
with an extra rook for a minor piece
yeah black has to
be uh not as thrilled as some of the
other possibilities yeah no this looks a
lot less uh interesting now that you've
taken my a5 phone i thought i could cook
up a storm here with my four pawns but
the
four is better than three this one here
i'm not so interested in
yeah if you could keep a5 for sure that
would be ideal so i mean
here after a4
bishop c4 knight takes c4 so you keep
this pawn for white which
by material says oh that's good for
white but by the look of the position
well black is covered
all around there's no targets it's a i
think a stylistic preference if mama
jarv says i can get the second pawn and
my a pawn isn't too much of a problem
then of course he should go for it but
keeping the position a little bit more
closed especially because you have this
pawn chain very safe and sound here it
looks extremely promising for black the
one thing if you and i'll add on top of
what i've said already is where to from
here like it looks great for black you
have
a protected extra past pawn but then how
do you make progress because
if you ever play c5 you've got to watch
out for d5 and white has great control
with these pieces here and these pawns
in the center so it's one of these
positions where extra material
a solid
plus with the past pawn on c3 and then
what is really the question
yeah i wonder if long term can we
somehow try and put pressure on the
white center
and try and put pressure on the pawn on
on d4
so long term what i'm looking at is i
want to get castled at some point and
then just try and bring as many heavy
pieces as possible exactly like this
onto the d
you're saying that's not legal i can't
play rook h8 to d7 right now
it'll take a bit more time than that
yeah
yeah unfortunately the castle moved my
queen move my rook man
too time-consuming for me but you are of
course right that if black can apply
pressure on this d4 pawn then that could
uh be a big issue for white but that
said white's pieces are great white has
more space but the exception being this
pawn on c3 which is a great protective
pass pawn but white's pieces are looking
excellent here so i wonder what mama
jarv will choose because if you know
rook takes b6 pawn b5 rook takes b5 we
like sit and really try to take in this
position two extra pawns for black so we
mentioned the open a file and some
pressure against a5 is white just going
to play like rook a4
and
start attacking that pawn
yeah i'm very curious to see what shah
does but i think he has a
the two options are
i think it's not like he's choosing
between one option that's gonna leave
him in a in a significantly
uh worst spots so and he's about
about to make a move
reconsidering
uh and he goes for the capture i think
on c4 oh no no no no that looks like
rook takes b6
on v6
he took on b6 yes he did so he likes the
material he says i'm going to be able to
keep my past pawns and honestly
once we look at ab5 just optically
speaking i do like this choice at first
i was kind of like ah i would rather
keep the position closed i know i have
an extra pawn but from the mindset of
trying to win this position i think that
black has maybe some more losing chances
not that black is going to lose black is
still better we see the eval bar and i
think just it's clear that black should
be happy here but i think black has
increased some of the losing chances if
there are any and also increases the
winning chances so from that perspective
i really like the decision that mama
jarvis made certainly a great decision
for us as the spectators of this really
exciting
game we will come back to this in a
little while i thought there were some
requests in the chat
to have a look at anish geary's game
let's have a look here at the bird's eye
view first and see if we have any
dramatic
developments which call for immediate
attention
i just saw mom and jarv like staring
right at the camera you know you were
you were talking the bird's-eye view and
what the chat was asking for and i saw
mama dare like staring into our soul
he's very very focused i think he can
smell the blood here and
if you can if you can win your first
round game with the black pieces i mean
every
win is so valuable in these
round robin elite events and especially
so
with the black piece is also so nice to
get off you know
on a
get off on on the winning ways so i
think yeah very focused uh very intense
shakira media of staring us down here
well i i not sure i should admit this
publicly and danny you mentioned him
earlier he's going to be a little upset
with me but i don't watch the chess.com
lessons okay like i'm not trying to
improve my chess game but i did watch
mama jarv's lesson series which was
fantastic he goes through a bunch of his
best games and some really critical
moments in them uh even saying i'm gonna
pause you know to let you figure it out
so mama jarv did do a great lesson
series and uh i
i have to say i watch it and i enjoyed
it so shock you can't hear me but great
job but karen check it out definitely i
think such a
fan favorite i think for a lot of people
who uh you know maybe came to chess over
the last
couple of years that when we had this
huge chest boom i think to a lot of
people shakir mamedyarov might not be
such a big name as magnus or hikaru or
you know fabiano but um i think for you
and me robert is
players who sort of
grew up in similar
generations as shakia he was
um
really an incredible uh player he still
is of course but um
a big fan favorite
such an
fantastic attacking player and i'm
really really happy to see him here in
the field at tata still this year
for sure and i don't know if he's a fan
favorite if he's loved hated you know he
but he is a twitter troll and that's a
niche geary pragmata his opponent the
youngster from india you know in his
first
super grand master tournament like this
in vikon zay and you know he of course
has great experience playing in many of
the
india events that rapid and blitz in
particular but in classical chess this
is probably the biggest tournament that
he's been invited to and right now
fiona i'm looking at this position we
thought that the duba mama jarv game
could be unrivaled in terms of how
interesting it is look at this one there
is a king in the center there's an extra
pawn for black but there's also an open
file right down the center for white
here this looks extremely scary for
pragnanda i was just gonna say i mean at
first sight once again we talked earlier
about you know how do we explain this to
the viewers and i think here once again
i mean it's hard to explain like why is
the black king
not castled yet if that king had castled
a few moves earlier we wouldn't find
ourselves
in this spot which is uh incredibly
incredibly scary i agree with you
so let's maybe take a closer look
at the position so the last or maybe we
can just go from where we left off here
after knight takes f3
queen went to h5 so again no queen c5
check here because d4 would be a tempo
move against the queen queen h5 makes
sense d4
knight d5 and there's a huge difference
i'm now realizing fiona about where the
king's placement is if this king were on
h1 and i'm just actually going to go
back to
the moment white one f3 that here
queen c5 check
king h1
uh pawn takes f3 knight f3 and let's say
we go for queen h5
and just like the game we play d4
knight d5 and e4 so we're just trying to
transpose the position after knight
takes pawn takes knight takes e4 there
is no rookie one because knight f2 check
would
win the queen so the rook has to stay
put and knight takes g3 is also a threat
because the king's on h1 so these little
moves make such a huge impact on these
games so queen c5 check would have
forced king to h1 and that's probably
the reason why queen c5 check was better
than taking on f3 right away not that
this line is forced but the game
continuation looks very scary for black
and that would not have been possible
had the king been pushed to the corner
so
i didn't really know at the time why
the queen c5 check you know for sure is
better i i liked to include it just
because impressive like it was your
first instinct at the time was to go uh
queen c5
and i think time has given you um
time has given you what's the word i'm
looking
for not wrinkles
but
you've been in the right here i i really
think it makes a
a big difference as we can see
indeed uh where where the king is
i'm seeing by the way a simple game in
the chat saying huge blunder by duboff i
saw a lot of comments earlier i've
understood that the magnus blunder
comments are always jerks but this one
i believe could probably be true so
we'll go back there after this game but
first let's have a look
and now after rookie won the knight on
e4 is hit
yeah and i mean where's it going to go
because
you can protect it right with a move
like bishop f5 but that doesn't look
like stable defense there's already a
rook on e1 this knight on e4 still feels
loose and after bishop to f5
i'm trying to figure out what the right
move is but if there's something
tactically available here
i can't move my knight cause there's a
queen trade
hmm
maybe
maybe super fight is possible but i
really can't believe in it fiona i i
don't
can we get the queen out of the way like
queen b3
so queen b3 just to attack b7
looks like a good move
um
yeah why not now the knight can move
away the bishop will attack the knight
on e4 the knight e4 still pinned here
this looks really bad
for black and it's kind of funny where
in some of these positions i feel like
you can even play this move queen c2
which looks ridiculous walking into a
discovery but any discovery has a flaw
and it's a fatal flaw at that that once
this queen moves
this bishop's already an attack but then
the knight is threatened and so if i
make a move like queen to b3
i'm going to take b7 your rook's going
to be under attack this bishop's
threatened this pawn is under attack i
mean your whole position is collapsing
you have two pawns you're losing one in
return and then you're losing much more
than that
yeah
so yeah this uh you can never really i
mean queen c2 is a funny move it's a
move that i would probably never play in
a million years but i like your
illustration of how it is uh
probably another another option here
yeah i like queen b3 more just
you know pointing out the queen's two is
possible despite the discovery so oh my
gosh if you can't play bishop f5 i i
don't believe in f5 i'm you know the
golden pawn channel about f5 which was
suggested in the in the chat earlier
it does look
incredibly scary
it hurts my heart honestly to see the
move f5 but it does make sense because
f5 you're up a pawn so even though queen
b3
removes your right to castle you can't
castle through or into check uh when i
look at this position i think maybe
black can retreat the queen to f7 and
we get a situation where if we trade
queens yes white can play knight e5
check and then get this knight and
restore material equality probably with
a slight edge for white just based on
the fact that this king like this go the
back rank and once it goes somewhere i
don't know let's say e8 and we trade
here
this pressure along the e file the king
doesn't have true safety so i do like
the look of white's position it's just
much more difficult to black to play for
black play excuse me even if objectively
there is going to be this like
a line just one line that can keep black
in the balance it's not easy to find and
i think that it's a very risky setup for
black
yeah so prague definitely has some some
tough questions to to answer here after
rookie one
uh with anish really putting him here to
the to the test uh in this first round
so we'll come back here but shall we go
and have a look at what happened in the
duboff game
where we're hearing dupoff just gave up
another pawn apparently
okay so we
left off right here a takes b5
and duboff went rook a2 so he can go and
win the a5 pawn but after castles queen
a1 oh my gosh let's see that again so
queen
on d1 minus 1.2 apparently approximately
and then queen a1 minus three
um
so okay the pawn that's hanging is the
pawn on d4
i guess
yep
and
do i just take it
like don't get fully greedy i'm guessing
the answer is absolutely i just take
your pawn
yeah
and oh oh wait a second
wait a second oh
wait what what are you doing engine
that's why i don't ever have you on
because i
believe queen 64 is a good move and then
you scare me so i'm going to quickly
change my mind but this position looks
it definitely looks good for black you
have a protect there it goes okay go
back go back
yeah
because it's not gone all the way it's
hard to try to imagine there's a better
move than queen
queen d4 but
is there
i
i don't know this looks amazing for
black like
i don't care what the engine says
i'm just going to be honest every
tournament that i do now that forced me
to have the engine on i don't like it
i've never liked it i hope you all know
that i'm here to be incorrect i'm happy
to be wrong because i'm wrong the
players in this tournament they make
mistakes sometimes nobody's perfect
oh gosh i think i think we need to go on
break but tell us how you really feel
robert
no no no okay before i lose it we are
going to go on a break
we'll see you soon and i will stop
talking about my
absolute love and affinity for the
engine we'll all have a glass of water
calm down and we'll be back with the
continuation of round one here so don't
go anywhere we'll see you very soon
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fastest
[Applause]
hello and welcome back here to round one
of the tata steel chess tournament 2022
your host for the day still grandmaster
robert has and my selfie on style
anthony and we see robert that shahriar
has gone
into deep thought here
uh he hasn't captured the pawn on d4 yet
but do you think he will
i think he will um this is such an
important pawn for white's position and
if there are no grave consequences it's
a great pawn to capture the queen can
retreat back to a7 which is important
because after queen takes d4 let's say
rook to d1 we were
just looking at this position briefly
that the queen isn't trapped it doesn't
have any central squares to go to but it
can go to c5 and to a7 so moves like
that are possible allows the queen to
escape and this pawn on c3 i mean that's
what this game is all about fiona is
there is a protected past pawn on c3
which is just such a problem for white
to deal with
yeah and it's it's honestly hard to
understand what duboff was thinking when
he played his last move
queen a1
so does he just want to capture on a5 or
you know when i get the feeling and i
could be incorrect but he is pretty
disgusted with how the game is going so
he just like making moves that create
threats and causing mama jarv to think
the problem is that mommy darb has more
time than doobab does so
mama jarv is a calculator up with the
absolute best them in the world he is
going to be able to work through the
complications and he is fully justified
and then some his decision to play rook
takes b6 let's go back to that moment
again because you suggested a fiona it
was um you wondered what would happen
after rook takes b6 he says i agree with
you that this is the move that i want to
play because i win a second pawn and i
understand that white will get some play
against the a5 pawn but the problem is
that dubov went for it right away and he
is paying the price in terms of the
evaluation by this position queen takes
d4 scooping up a central pawn giving
black temporarily a third extra pawn and
i mean there's just no way around it
this pawn on c3 is so good
i was just having having a look at the
at how quickly uh daniel played uh
played that move queen a1 he played it
extremely quickly
uh less than a minute if only 26 seconds
and i don't know you have to wonder
is there already i don't want to say
tilt because it's too early it's day one
but uh daniel did look
not maybe disgusted is too strong but he
didn't look happy let's say
for the last while when we were looking
into this game
um but still very strange to see him
make a move like queen a1 giving up the
protection of one of his central pawns
so fast
and um
we see shaq i mean he has so much
experience he's not gonna make the
mistake of taking the pawn you know
instantly as you said he is gonna take
his time he has plenty of time on the
clock still
to to think things through but
definitely looking uh looking very good
for charge today
and i'm wondering if queen d3 was a
better alternative than queen to a1
because it keeps the d4 pawn protected
the rook on f1 can swing over to a1 to
put that pressure on the a5 pawn and try
to win it so i'm i guess that
yeah there he goes
yeah queen takes d4 he tried to cash in
and not cash him but he tried to win
back some material a little bit too
quickly and in the process he gave away
this d4 pawn mama yar just took it as we
saw and again the issue is after rook d1
there is even queen c5 because the queen
doesn't quite get trapped uh it looks at
first like bishop e3 might trap the
queen but the queen does have the h5
square i don't like the look of queen c5
regardless it just feels like it's out
in the open so even in the event of like
a knight d6 and if you have to take your
queen could just come under fire in many
positions so i like queen a7
as a retreating move and yes white can
take this a5 pawn and sure the queen on
a7 is in the line of fire somewhat but
it's just not enough here and the queen
does
a great job of uh defending a lot of
black's position you can just move the
queen out of the way i where to i'm not
entirely sure honestly but uh the queen
can move and
black remains well ahead
yeah and i think shakia are really an
overwhelming favorite
it's curious um it almost it's almost a
little bit reminiscent of the the
carlson nipple match where when things
were not going young's
a way we saw these self-destruction
moments almost so i'm a little bit
scared for daniel here
as to how he's going proceed maybe the
position is already objectively
lost
but i'm also worried that he will not
put
put on maximum resistance from here but
i hope he proves me wrong and we will of
course keep an eye on it
uh robert shall we have a look at the
bird's view see what else has been
happening while we were gone on a short
break
yeah and if i'm being honest with myself
and i'll be honest with everybody i'm
still trying to calculate this you know
position uh with the mama jarv game
because it does look quite complicated
we do benefit from having the eval bar
off to the side to know that black
definitely is better but the position
remains really sharp so if dubov came
back in this one i wouldn't actually be
that surprised but we have five in a car
one on screen let's look around at the
games here
um
it looks like pragnan did play f5 and
anish play queen b3 so we were more or
less expecting that
what other games are catching your eye
here
i see that fitted against shankland they
are into the end game the only game
actually here today so far where the
queens have come up so actually very
exciting two hours in
i'm always happy when queens are on the
void
uh allowing for a little bit more action
i see that things have been happening in
the van forest grandillus game as well
so with some queen side action there
um and finally what's happening maybe we
can go back to to magnus
what do you think robert
you just gave me so many options that i
don't know what to choose from
we could start with magnus because i
think
we've
highlighted many of the important
nuances but if we go to the current
position
things have in fact changed we see that
black has the hanging pawn structure and
white put the knight on a4 so black's
last move was rook to c7 and you see the
eval bar saying i don't love that
decision
of course it can be a little bit finicky
with more depth the engines get stronger
and stronger
and there are probably tons of
possibilities in this position maybe
black at some point will be able to
strike with d4 we mentioned that as a
possibility earlier from white's point
of view these pawns here are what you
want to go after and i'm looking down
the cnd files and i really want to win
one of those pawns it's just not
possible at least not yet so
fiona
i said earlier that i
liked
some of mag's chances if we got to a
hanging pawn structure
i still feel that way i really do and
the clock i was just gonna say that i
think andre has to start
watching out on the clock because we are
only on move 16 here in this game which
means that there's still 24 moves to go
to reach the first time control
and those 32 minutes they tick down very
quickly we see essie pink on the screen
though he is looking calm and collected
uh for now but i i agree with you i feel
that the tide is
starting to to turn ever so slightly
um
and yeah i think magnus uh definitely
happy and he will be looking for his
chances now to maybe even start off here
with a full point
yeah i would be pretty nervous if i were
yes a panko and it's not just because
he's playing magnus carlson um you know
he beat magnus last year but this is a
totally different game in any individual
game all the players in this field from
pragnanda's the lowest rated and
youngest player
all the way up to the second seed in
this event five minute corona can beat
magnus they all the players know that
magnus knows it so that
event last year
it's a world away in this current
position what i'm looking at is the
possibility for black to play this move
d4
because
once d4 happens there is the threat of
taking on f3 and even if you protect
that knight with queen c3 i still kind
of like the move d4 it's a pawn
sacrifice but after e takes d4
saying give me that pawn my queen
defends this knight so you're not going
to take it the move knight d5 comes to
mind hopping into f4 there's potential
sacrifices on g2 the knight is starting
to go to e2 would check this queen is
open on the diagonal well let's stop on
f6 we'll be able to get to g5 maybe even
all the way to h4 it just looks very
scary for white to deal with all of
these tactical threats and so that's the
reason why
as soon as i saw the hanging pawn
structure i said i like magnus's chances
because he's well ahead on the clock and
in an instant the position can change
from does black need to deal with these
pawns hanging pawns that can be attacked
and aren't protected by pawns or can
black use the
pawns to push one of them open up the
entire position and then white could be
in big trouble can we maybe just go back
for one second and see how did we end up
with the hanging pawns
sure uh so bishop f5 rook c was played
and then this is where
he decided to take
and i'm not sure i love that decision
like a move like queen b1 looks awkward
if you want to get off the c file but
you can make these sort of slower moves
in a position like this because black
really does not want to take on d4 and
leave this bishop behind the pawns so
um
i i'm not positive of how exactly to
proceed but i know that when i see a
position like this taking on c5 to me
and that's a preference because you see
the eval bar stayed about the same i
just wouldn't have gone for this
structure especially not against magnus
i would have kept the position more tame
yeah and we will see well how uh jesse
panko deals with this opening up
of the
of the position
i think this d4 move you're highlighting
definitely looming and the scary
prospect so um
yeah i will keep an eye
on this one uh for now i was thinking
maybe we can
i see you hovering i was thinking a
quick look maybe i'd run for waste and
then i'll let you i'll let you pick the
next one
no i don't see
i wasn't even trying to pick a specific
game i was trying to anticipate what you
were going to say sorry i was quickly
hovering over the other games seeing
what's fiona going to say and there's
you know really it's a great choice
always to check on jordan von forest
position especially when it looks like
this yeah it has changed quite a lot
since we left it off
yeah where did so h6 this was the moment
we left
a bishop h4 a4 played by
nils
knight e3 natural move considering the
knight went to d2 to f1 its plan was to
go up to e3
and now bishop b7
c4 so i
in principle or i like this move c4
because this pawn a4 it sticks out and
if the c
b pawn rather is removed
from the board then a4 is a target so c4
it causes some very concrete issues for
black which neil decided to deal with in
a tactical manner but you see the eval
bar off the side it likes white's
position after this move fiona because
it is a pawn sacrifice
it is a pawn sacrifice indeed and jordan
considered his options and decided to
take on b5
the things are sharpening up here
between d7 hitting the pawn
and now jordan decides to take on f6
he does he says i'm gonna
get rid of my bishop for this knight and
one important thing here is that we
often talk about the bishop pair as
being a two bishops advantage that's at
least how at the highest levels it's
often uh called and considered but this
bishop on f6 doesn't look like much of
an advantage to me when a position is
closed it's knights that typically reign
supremes the bishop on f6 is not a great
piece uh and so now bishop takes a4 was
played taking a second pawn and
defending the first extra pawn so
jordan's two pawns ahead temporarily
knight takes on d3
queen takes d3 and rook takes a4 so it's
a one pawn advantage there are two
bishops here for black the e4 pawn is
under attack right now
but it seems like white can just protect
that pawn remain upon ahead and this
looks like a very difficult position for
niels
you know i don't really like it for
black he has some activity but the extra
material i asked you that question
earlier fiona do you prefer material or
activity here i definitely prefer the
material
yeah i think jordan is going to
to solidify his position take care of
that pawn that's under attack on
e4 and i'm i think even those those uh
queen slide pawns look somewhat scary
you could easily see
at some point b3 a4 and the puns just
start running
yeah this pawn on b5 is doubled and not
that easy to defend but it's going to be
a good one and so let's say you play
knight d2 right we protect our pawn on
e4
uh there were two pieces attacking it
and
here after knight d2
what are you gonna do because b3 a4 your
idea makes perfect sense you can go
after this b5 pawn but that's not the
end of the story like playing rook to b4
let's say attacking two different pawns
here
it's not just about that the c7 pawn is
a target um
although actually rook before you know
at least at first glance it looks like
it could be a bit of a nuisance to deal
with you know just
attacking two different pawns at once
saying i'm going to win my material back
uh but i do believe that i would just
give up the b2 pawn and play a4 and say
i'm happy to have this for sure the rook
might get trapped down here actually
yeah it's a curious position with the
the rook sort of trapped in the enemy
enemy lines but the engine
seems to be firmly on yorden's side and
i i believe he must be a big uh favorite
to win his opening game here before we
move on speaking of jordan it's the
first of our portrait videos that is
ready so let's hear
what jordan had to say before the start
of the tournament
my first memory would be being here with
my grandfather and my little brother
playing here for the very first time i
was playing in the amateur sections and
really desperately trying to get a good
look at
the two players playing
so my best memory would have to be
definitely
while winning here last year without
question
a couple of years ago we started getting
neural network chess engines um into the
into the
jazz world and they really changed the
game uh the way we see the game uh very
differently and it has improved our
understanding of the game immensely so
it's a very interesting development and
the way they play chess is really
magnificent so it's it's very nice
i have a chess board at home so i like
to bring a chessboard to my tournaments
but
90 of the work i think does take place
on my laptop and using technology
i always think that like the engines we
currently have they're like the
strongest
there can ever be but they keep on
getting stronger so who knows
what's going to come in the future
i've basically played in all of the
groups and indeed that
just coming here as a kid and now
playing on the highest stage is of
course
very special to me
[Music]
very nice to hear from jordan and what a
long way he has come indeed from playing
here in the amateur groups as a kid with
his grandfather
to winning the tournament uh last year i
mean it's just simply incredible robert
yeah he uh has been playing in these
events for so long and now he
he was a kid playing in them now he's
not kidding around he won last year and
he could win again this year there's no
reason why he can't repeat his
performance i don't expect that to
happen by ratings i don't think
mathematically speaking most people do
but still he is such a great player his
preparation is elite and his play
matches his preparation level he's just
really a phenomenal force in the top of
chess and it's great to have him back in
vikings a but niels grandillous probably
isn't so happy to see that jordan is
back because right now
neil's back is against the wall he's
down a pawn it looks like there's going
to be potential to just rush those pawns
up the board even if black is able to
you know try and win a pawn back it's
not going to
be easy and so
niels is down on the clock down a pawn
i don't like his chances
yeah and just as we speak jordan has
played knight d1 so defending the pawn
on e4
and yeah i agree with you i think things
looking great for jordan apart from all
the things you highlighted he also last
year started working with magnus carlson
so we'll also see maybe
of course these things don't necessarily
always show in the first event you
played but for sure
um that's going to have been a
big step in jordan's career when you
work with the world champion
especially during world championship
years
so we'll see we'll see where jordan
stands at the end of this
well now robert i did say i was going to
let you pick the next game so where will
you take us
well first i have to i love this knight
d1 move
retreating the knight opening the rook
to defend knight c3 coming he's putting
his knight from e3 which looked like a
great square to another excellent square
c3 which defends all the pawns when the
knight gets to c3 it is going to defend
e4 it's going to defend b5 it's going to
defend a2 and also protect a4 from when
the pawn goes up there so i think it's a
wonderful decision from a fantastic
player
the knight on c3 can't be attacked by
the bishop
to show after knight d2 maybe bishop g5
was suddenly an option where we talked
about how bad that bishop was let's
trade it off for a night
in this one and maybe try to win a pawn
back so i really like to move knight to
d1 great choice by jordan and it goes to
show that while retreating moves may not
be top of mind you need to consider them
because one step back doesn't mean that
you are
really on the defensive it could be one
step back to take two or three steps
forward and so knight d1 was a really
great move by jordan recognizing how to
improve his pieces i also really uh
going back i really liked jordan's
decision which i think in the moment is
not always so easy to understand when he
took on f6
also on move 17
because very often we wonder why would
you give up your bishop pair especially
unprompted uh but i think that decision
with all the moves that jordan played uh
has completely paid off and
jordan would a
borderline borderline winning position
almost so we'll see
if he can convert but uh picking up
where he left off this
year well where he left off last year at
the moment
and there's actually a really good
illustration of why bishop takes f6 was
so important he recognized what was
going to happen you call him prophetic
he was just calculating and visualizing
the state of the board because if bishop
takes a4 was played right away and black
threw in g5 bishop g3
now if we go to knight takes d3 as we
saw in the game queen takes d3 rook
takes a4 there's a huge problem in that
now it's not just two pieces but three
black pieces are aiming at this e4 pawn
so black's gonna win that pawn the
bishop on g3 is not very good and so
that is why jordan took on f6 he saw
what was about to happen and he realized
that i need to include this trade to
make my position uh be strong because
this is actually worse for white if he
allowed g5
yeah absolutely so you're then showing
some great understanding there of the
position
and i will come back here but um a tough
tough task ahead for nils
and a game we can go to is the one
between duda and report i think that one
is quite interesting because of a moment
that
just happened here and i sort of see
based on what the position was to where
it is now as i pull it up here that
in this position here the move b4 was
played by a report and speaking of great
calculators great tactical players
rapport is up there with the best he's
so innovative and b4 looks like a huge
blunder because knight c6 is a monster
fork against the queen and the rook if
you move the queen then i just take your
rook and i am able to steal some
material the problem is that i'm going
to give you my queen and play b take c3
you'll take my queen with check as well
so i'm not even getting your queen back
but after bishop takes e7
white is unable to play queen takes c3
this is the problem with having your
king in the center if the king or castle
queen takes c3 would be great now queen
takes c3 runs right into bishop b4 and
black is up a minor piece and completely
winning so
you have to move your queen away to
something like a or c4 and then c takes
b2 happens and i don't care what the
evaluation bar says
nobody wants to see this happen i'm sure
it's just good for black it'll keep
going down but uh at first glance this
looks amazing for black with two minor
pieces and a pawn that's about to
promote for the queen no you're not
doing this from the white side yeah
what an incredible uh an incredible line
and no surprise that uh
that young kristoff had no interest in
going and knight c6 although i think
it's a move that especially in faster
time controls myself and hopefully i'm
not i'm not alone in this would probably
play on a rim but now that line uh with
the queen sack
not just beautiful but very very strong
so instead
do that here went knight to a4
and rapport decided to take on e5 can't
take with a knight you can't trade them
because after the pawn takes there would
be a fork of the minor pieces and that
would be bad so bishop takes e5 pawn
takes e5 and now
knight e4 played so the bishop on g3 is
under attack and can be captured
honestly fiona i think that there are
two different story lines happening in
this game one is that black is playing
very active chess this pawn will be down
to b4 uh but on the flip side of that or
maybe because of it there is some
backward pawn on c7 white already has
controlled the d file so it's like
it's a dynamically equal but i would say
that
in the near future there are some
problems for white to deal with this e5
pawn being loose probably the biggest
thing right knight takes g3 knight takes
e5 but there are some issues here for
black if this rook could swing from h1
to c1 all of a sudden there's a lot of
pressure which side would you rather
play here
oh i was hoping you wouldn't ask me that
question
i mean it's such a weird position
it is
i'm
i'm gonna go with black
i mean i wouldn't have expected myself
to say it because optically you know
aesthetically it looks like a position
i'd want from the white side but how do
you defend this e5 pawn
a great question
i mean once again there's this f4 move
we saw earlier f5 in prague's game but
again it doesn't look like the kind of
move we want to make
yeah f4
with our king in the center it does save
the pawn but
i'm not totally buying it and nor is the
engine says you can play f4 all you want
you can defend your pawn but in this
position i'm even looking at ideas of
knight to c5 training off knights rather
than winning your bishop that looks
pretty awesome to me
because well do i i don't even know what
i take with i i'm spoiled for choice
probably queen takes honestly just take
this this is weak
here there's a threat of bishop c2 at
the end i mean
not the position you really want
absolutely much perspective
and we see that duda he stopped one
square sooner he didn't go f4 but he
went
f3
aha
so he knows the types of moves that i
enjoy you expect f4 and they grab the
pawn and then just poop f3 so what's the
idea of knight g3
pawn g3 knight takes e5
one consider can consider that an extra
pawn
for black
unless i'm
missing some material no that's an extra
pawn however
perhaps you can push the g pawn or the e
pawn kick the bishop back and with an
open h file and an uncastle king there
is some outside potential of an attack i
guess yeah well i'm also a little bit
especially if i go e4 then my my own
king might also be a little bit exposed
i don't like how weak the the dark
squares i don't know how much of a
problem it will be
but for now although i'm always i love
uh you know attacking uh it doesn't
matter if it doesn't work but here i'm a
little bit
skeptical about how i'm gonna proceed
with this attack without um without
being too vulnerable my son
yeah this bishop on g6 both deserves red
highlight and green because it's bad
it's staring into a pawn but it's great
because it defends h7 and there's going
to be no attack white can play for like
a bind a queen e3 hitting a7 but also
stopping c5 from happening uh at least
for now
it will lose a pawn if you play c5 maybe
you can sacrifice that bond i don't see
why you'd want to
but these kind of positions are very
interesting the dynamic is such where
black is the material white has better
control who is actually better the
current evaluation says the black is
i would probably take black in this
position but i also see the merits and
whites set up here well we'll see
because richard has just taken on g3 h
takes g3 is on the board
and i'm i'm very curious to see uh i
think richard is going to take some time
here
and i'm curious to find out if he kept
decides to capture the pawn on e5
because it's it's a pawn that is hanging
for sure but it's not a forced decision
and now that you sort of say he'll think
it makes me want to think and now that
i'm thinking i'm looking at alternatives
and one alternative is this move knight
c5 because it still forces the night
trade the queen has nowhere to go
without dropping a piece and after this
trade here this e5 pawn is loose bishop
c2 is a threat in many positions
black's pawn structure is better because
white has double pawns so
a situation like this could arise where
report is not unhappy to see this
position so you don't have to take a
pawn just because you can you should
really deliberate and think hey maybe i
can win it another way or instead of
winning material i'll gain
some other advantages in the position
yeah and i think due to
a
difficult story today i think uh
rapport has been absolutely true to his
style
playing
uh an interesting fashion and i think
certainly being rewarded here
yeah we'll see if he's able to
uh score a win with the black pieces too
early really to speak about results but
i like the the play i think it's a great
uh start to this tournament for both
players uh but for duda you you need to
make
the most of your white pieces and let's
determine this caliber we'll see if he's
able to uh in this game so
we can go around
i'm just like hovering over boards
yeah should we look at the end game i
know you said end game you prefer to
have queens
no i love end games
okay
because it's you robert
we don't have to we can go to other
games as well but it's fine quickly
we'll have a quick look
i think there's at least one vidit fan
out there and at least one sam shanklin
fan out there so we're gonna make those
fans happy by looking at the position
and i get it there's not too much going
on fiona let me come on i don't know
there might be some you know h5
trying to open the h file and
and
you know mate on
on h8 king g7 rook h7 mate that's the
dream right
you know i know you're laughing but i
also know you mean it because h5 is a
real idea to open up the file black just
played the move g6 which was by no means
forced but likely didn't want to see
this knight hop forward and also wanted
to create left for the king so
the move g6 invites h5 as fiona's
talking about i totally get behind h5
now or in the future but really when i
think about this position as a whole
when i look across the board i don't
really see how black can get active play
so while there are no queens on the
board there are fewer options because
there are fewer pieces
when i look at this position i think
that these types of end games can be
super difficult for black to play that
oftentimes players would like a position
where the engine says oh it's over a
full pawn
better for my opponent but at least i
have activity and have calculation to
make the game complicated here it's very
clear white is better and there's
nothing black can do about it maybe sam
plays well and holds but he's not
playing for an advantage and unless did
it make some really huge mistake and i
don't see that happening it's uh playing
for two results either vidit will push
and get a win or sam will neutralize
play accurate defense and hold the game
but sam is not looking to win this game
and so a move like h5 your
first
um decision here i really like it fiona
why not play rook h1 next and without
queens doesn't automatically mean that
the king is safe no there's a
checkmating net
right at the start of this position yeah
exactly maybe there is even no need to
rush with h5 i guess that move isn't
going anywhere but
i think as long as our pawn on g5
is safe which we want to make sure of
then i don't see why not let's go for it
immediately
yeah and there's no way for black to get
to that pawn so i like that we paused
and you said wait we don't need to rush
that because maybe we want to play rook
h1 first to really
show what our threat's going to be but
you can't get to g5 so i'm told with
your fiona the h5 looks good and
really sam will have a defensive task
his position you know he could put his
knight in f8 you can continue to hold on
and make sure that everything's defended
but do you really want to take with the
f pawn on g6 like that's a huge question
here and you're almost certainly going
to have to take with that pawn because
opening up the h file looks disastrous
and let's say just to put a position on
the board where you take with that make
some like very quiet movie a6 takes and
you take with the f pawn like i look at
this position and now i really like it
for white there's a target that is
pretty permanent thanks to this pawn on
g5 you can't play h5 i'll take on
poissant don't forget about that fancy
french rule and then we'll maneuver this
knight right this knight can go to e2
into f4 this king don't forget about
king marches that king can walk all the
way up the queen side at some point i
know that looks ridiculous but it's
something to consider and you can play
for a pawn minority attack i wouldn't go
for that because it frees up squares
like c4 but you have all of these
different possibilities so we shouldn't
take positions like this for granted and
i really like vivid's position it's
actually one of my favorite positions of
the entire round
yeah absolutely i am being convinced
that no queens doesn't necessarily mean
no fun i was sorry i couldn't stop
laughing like i'm such a sucker for
these
like memes or whatever you want to call
it like with it in the not like this
pose
[Laughter]
he's just too funny
well he really is oh my god he is
he really is indeed but uh
he has no need to be not like this thing
because he's doing uh he's doing great
i agree with you again for two results
uh still plenty of time on the clock uh
to make the first time control i was
reading uh
in the chat a few people mentioned this
that apparently magnus uh was given an
opportunity by sapanko which
he failed to take so maybe we can go and
see
what the story is there
okay so i just brought up the uh board
and here's the current position but
let's go back to where we were so now we
know there was an opportunity we have a
hint the players don't have those hints
so they have to find it on the fly but
we have a hint so there was an
opportunity which means that d4 at some
point is the move i don't know i think
so i even saw that some people were
we're talking about d4 which was the
move you had highlighted last time when
we looked at this position yeah we were
talking about this even before the pawns
were traded i said if white ever takes
on c5
then what always needs to watch out for
d4 and black should be of course looking
for that and d4
bishop a5 i am sure is what magnus uh
was concerned about because that is a
pin here but bishop takes f3 coming you
can't take on e3 because the bishop on
d6 is loose
this is not that clear like this is
blunder is strong magnus of course
consider the move d4 but he you look at
this position and then what's black's
move right we can go i mean we have the
eval bar where we don't have the lines
that tell us what moves should be played
but when i look at this position
i'm like it's complicated i could see
black having some serious play against
the white king and so i would calculate
it but it's still not abundantly clear
what the correct continuation is so i
think that you know as we sit with the
in the comfort of our home sipping tea
looking at the engine we see that's a
blunder some some moves are obvious and
the players just miss them and then
that's a blunder here
magnus of course thought about d4 i'm
sure yes panko thought about d4 but they
both came to the same conclusion and it
might be a faulty conclusion that d4
wasn't sufficient because of bishop a5
but i look at this position i definitely
like
how tactical it is how sharp it is and
black should have something
yeah but i guess the sharpness is
probably not going anywhere which is the
nice thing i think it's not a position
where now this was missed the position
is going to go back to being dry and
boring let's see what happened
instead so magnus instead of going d4
which was certainly as we've seen um
well a possibility magnus went queen e7
instead
and the bishop came to a5 and rook c6
and now
he's like inviting d4 but there's a rook
in the way
like i was like wait why would you play
bishop c3
d4 is just so good and then i realized
you can't play bishop takes f3 because
that's not legal there is a rook
sitting in the path but
could magnus invite i don't think he's
interested but do you think he could
invite a move repetition here
he might be because
white might be threatening move like
bishop takes d7 and then this d5 pawn is
loose right so let's say
i don't even know what a rant like king
h8 some
move that
hey it's not even that bad apparently
wait
is it funny how that happens
oh wait
yeah let's just let's just do it but
bishop takes d7
if queen takes d7 then bishop takes f6
if knight takes d7 then rook takes d5 is
what i was looking at and you steal a
pawn in the center this rook is swinging
into the attack this is terrible for
black so i don't really understand how
king h8 isn't bad because something like
oh because there's no rook takes d5
maybe maybe that's the key there's no
rook takes d5 because of tactics
like
i mean it's a ridiculous move king h8
but yeah
i mean it's a crazy position
if you have to take with the queen on d7
i don't think black is happy to consider
this like at least in our heads when we
visualize like that looks terrible
double isolated pawns the king side an
exposed king uh the center still in
danger of falling apart but it
is uh the case where black can hold
things i need to go back to this
position yeah there is also a question
in the chat from uh rt blood feud and
what is the benefit of the work on c6
blocking the bishop so let's maybe just
go back to that moment after bishop a5
because there were only two
two options
and um
i guess both are not super tempting
right because rook c6 blocks the bishop
but rook c8 walks into a pin and i think
that both moves are are fine like both
uh make sense uh
magnus chose rook c6 to avoid the pin
but we actually
yeah we might see a repetition you asked
about sorry that
uh he won rook c7 so he's inviting
bishop a5 and then maybe he will play
rook to c8 but i guess
magnus is saying that maybe white has no
better than to put in the bishop back
here and he can still play rook seat if
he wants the game to continue i don't
think rook states a bad move i think
it's a perfectly uh good choice and if
that move were played maybe
uh oops sorry
sorry
has gone bishop a5 so it looks like he
probably is happy with the repetition
we'll see if it happens a third time but
now
uh the decision in magnus's hence rook
c6 likely to lead to a draw by
repetition or he can decide to play on
with rook c8
yeah not an easy choice because drawing
guess panko with black good result but
he's up so much time so i would really
think before i make this move because if
magus wants to make a draw he can spend
15 minutes and then play rook c6 it'll
likely end in a draw but if he says let
me buckle down and if rookie isn't a bad
move which it doesn't appear to be let's
go for that but you know what i wanted
to address here was this moment with d4
um
i mean bishop a5 bishop takes f3 just to
get into the heart of
the
quote-unquote blunder like even in this
position i mean i see the move knight e5
and maybe queen a8 and things like that
and i do get it like this is something
that
ordinarily speaking magnus would just go
for and he's able to
work through the tactical sequences but
like if you don't have sufficient
compensation which we know you do based
on the engine here your whole position
just collapses like you may uh if you
don't have a serious attack that you can
sustain or that really is a knockout
your position falls apart but it does
seem like with knight takes f3 is a
threat there's bishop on d6 staring
towards the king side if this knight
moves away from f6 the queen comes up to
g5 or to h4 i i'm with everybody that
this is something that looks
so so tempting i just tend to
um hold back a bit before being brutally
critical of players missing things just
because
there it's it's very complicated there's
so many different possibilities and the
engine will say something but doesn't
explain the why and so that's what we're
here for of course fiona just um you
know it's something that of course
magnus can and should see and did see
and i bet you in the post game interview
it's one of his first questions i was
just gonna say i'm curious and by the
way magnus has gotten rook c6 and from
his body language to me it looks like
he will be
if jesse panko repeats i think he will
take that repetition
and yeah i was just going to say i'm
curious as well uh i hope we get an
interview with the players will be
interesting to to hear their thoughts
and especially because for sure magnus
did consider d4 and what his his
thoughts
were of that moment you see panko here
this is all so typical i think even at
the highest levels there's always this
look at the score sheet you know
counting how many times exactly
um and
what is it if now rook c7 we see magnus
um
doesn't look too happy but uh
but i think he will we will see a
repetition here what do you think robert
i think he's considered king a trade
no i think we'll see a repetition that's
going to be funny
that would be unbelievable and it has
happened in my commentary before where i
suggest like a throwaway move and then
i'm like wait a second that's actually
really interesting and it happened in
the world cup when magnus was playing
against voitacic i was like oh and if
this move is played and then that exact
sequence happened and i was commenting
with ben and ben's like even when you
blunder it's a good move and i was like
i don't know what just happened that was
extraordinarily random but here
it's hard not to repeat for magnus
because d4 is the main idea that black
is going for but with the rook on c6 in
the way of the bishop you're not playing
d4 and you do have to be concerned that
your position just collapses and there
is the handshake rook c7 accompanied by
a drawfur which was instantly uh
accepted by andre yacipenko and there we
see
the postmortem
so a different image this year last year
there was the image of magnus leaving
and andre sitting at the board in
disbelief
but this result also a very solid start
to the tournament uh four years panko
robert what did you make of the game
it was solid i mean yes panko is a
growing player he's only 19 years old
and he's over 2700 and
a draw against magnus carlsen
that's
probably a good result i think one could
say that uh but don't don't get esopenca
wrong he didn't come into this game
thinking oh i just want to make a draw
he wants to play and he felt that magnus
had equalized and he didn't see a way
that he could play safely for an
advantage and thus repeated the move so
i
they just were talking about uh i guess
the move was actually played on the dgt
board so like oh what if i played knight
b6 in the final position but ultimately
magnesite is not worth the risk let's
just call it a day and tomorrow's new
one yeah and i think it was very nice
actually to see the interaction between
the two players there with magnus we
don't know of chris exactly what was
said but magnus with a smile on his face
giving a thumbs up and uh i think yeah a
very interesting game our first result
of this tata steel chest 2022
i'm sure we'll hear at least of one of
the players
so definitely stay tuned anyway you
don't want to go anywhere because we
still have six very exciting games uh
going on so let's see
the birds eye view
so you said six very interesting games
so i got my hopes up i'm looking at the
moment yard game and he just did bishop
c5 so that looks awesome i see dudes
king on f2 and rook on d7 that looks
like it's a good deal of fun and i see
shanklin playing the move c5 to meeting
h5 with c5 trying to strike back looking
pretty exciting uh jordan
has
niels is rooking a pickle but niels is
trying to open up those bishops that
looks pretty fun and then
giri with uh knight and bishop against
two bishops but a better king
that looks pretty interesting and then
finally
last but not least fabiano against
karjakin
okay that one's not as fun i'm gonna be
honest with you fiona i was saving it
for last because it's it's
it's just a worse position for black
than as we said earlier if anybody can
deal with it it's sergey karjakin but
everyone would prefer to have the white
side
yeah so let's revise uh my statement to
five very interesting games
and one game i think that's going to go
on for a long time karana karjak and
we're also
slowly but surely approaching the first
time control so that's going to be in an
hour 20. i always get excited when we
reach that that mark which means that
the time is ticking down for the players
and i see
you've opened the game so let's go there
duboff against mamedyarov and let's uh
catch up we haven't
missed
that much here
so let's just see the couple of moves um
since we left off
so queen takes d4 rook d1 the queen
retreat all the way to a7 and here after
knight takes a5
i was saying this isn't that easy of a
position and then look at the move that
mama jared plays it's bishop c5 like our
first instinct is wait a second there's
a rook here there's a queen here rooks
win showdowns with queens so knight
takes c6 is a pretty serious threat and
so he says no it's not bishop c5
and i think his plan is sorry to
interrupt you robert but i think we're
getting ready for an interview so we
will come back to this game uh in just a
second
to be honest
um i think we were both trying to to
play trying to
um to win uh but it became clear that
although
uh it looked like white had some
um interesting
possibilities and good activity
um i can sort of sidestep it and he runs
serious danger of being worse if he
if he's not careful um and he found this
idea with bishop a5 and bishop c3 back
and i couldn't find um
couldn't find a good way to to avoid the
repetition
so i think overall
that's just what what happens yeah
according to the engines at some point
you could have played d4 with
a sort of edge did you consider that
during the game
uh yeah i didn't really i didn't really
see that maybe maybe i could i don't
know
uh last year of course uh you lost
against asi penko was this special in a
way that you want to take revenge or is
it just another game for you
no it's um
i wouldn't say just another another game
but he's
a very strong player and
and not somebody whom i expect to
to beat every time with good luck
thank you
so we see magnus day giving a lot of
credit to his young opponent andre
jesse panko
saying he didn't see anything better
than the repetition in the end and
surprisingly uh
didn't really
say much about this d4 possibility
uh it definitely was an option and
it looked really interesting i thought
that he would go for it but i see i
guess we're gonna have yesapanko on for
an interview as well aren't we
i hope so but uh
i hope so we will see uh if we get andre
for now let's go back to this uh very
exciting moment here after bishop c5 so
you were saying it looks like we need to
do
something about knight takes c6 but my
media says no
yeah i mean bishop c5 is a wonderful
move because knight takes c6 if you take
on c6 it looks like a free piece but
then you remember that your queen's
under attack the what um as we say
magnus what mama jarv has up his sleeve
is bishop takes f2 check because if rook
takes f2
now we can trade queens i take the
knight black is up two healthy pawns
including this wonderful past pawn
so
um
in this position after bishop f2 let's
say you play king f1 i think you can
even sacrifice your queen in these
positions like if you take on c6
oh maybe not i would thought i had it
but i didn't i take it back but i don't
know what move then i this is clearly
what his intention is and so what is the
follow-up here is just
i don't know
i wish i did
yeah what a messy messy position i see
by the way that yes panko is getting
ready
uh for the interview so we'll hear from
him in a second as well
but what a mess this is and we yeah
we're yet to to figure out
yeah maybe just moving the queen but i
was gonna sacrifice the queen i love
sacrificing other people's pieces so
trying to take a rook and a knight and
then two extra pawns for the queen but
maybe just move the queen out the way
and say you can have this knight on b8
that's not really doing things for you
my knight's coming to g4 there's
checkmating attacks everywhere and the
white king is in big trouble
and i don't know exactly i mean this
position is way too complicated to
figure out but what i do know is i think
mamedyarov will be right at home
here he has played the move bishop c5 so
i'm sure he will have
given it some thought but also here the
time is ticking down half an hour for
duboff uh only 20 20 just under 24
minutes uh for my medieval and we're
only on move 21 so
we could get some
some fast action here at some point
the good news is the moves are pretty
forced for dubov because otherwise he
just is losing so he's going to have to
make these decisions and it seems like
he still is in trouble because if he
doesn't
take on c6 or do something like that he
in fact just did take on c6 then mama
jarv has an easy position so bishop
takes f2 check undoubtedly is the reply
here and mama jarv is about to go for a
huge attack and
i don't see dubois surviving this yeah
this is definitely going to be uh the
focus i think for the for the next royal
um
i think this game has the potential to
be the our first decided game but
i shouldn't get ahead of myself um do
you want to stick around here a little
bit longer or should we jump around a
little bit
yeah maybe we can just look a little bit
more into this variation because bishop
f2 check we're talking about rook takes
f2 after
the queen trade but you need to do this
wisely because if queen takes a1 right
away i'm now seeing that there's this
move knight e7 check
so i i was trying to trade queens and
win the night but no the knight comes
with an inter mezzo and then you win uh
the queen back and now white is up a
piece so this would be a huge blunder so
you do not take it
right yeah it looks like the white
knight from e7 doesn't have too many
squares but we'll be able to defend it i
guess yeah we'll be able to survive and
get out of there so you take on c6 and
by taking the knight you protect the
queen now black really is up to clean
healthy extra pawns and that's a
terrible situation for white to deal
with so um bishop f2 king f1 or king h1
but the king on f1 queen b6 knight takes
b8 like this position to me still looks
very interesting because if you play
knight g4 there's no checkmate threat
and this night can come to d7 the knight
survives it lives to tell the tale so
maybe just e5 the simple move cutting
off the bishop from the knight the rook
protects the pawn and then you win the
night back and
that's what uh the deal is but there's
still so many pieces hanging everywhere
my head is pounding with all the tactics
but black is uh clearly decided for
choice
to be honest i feel like that's the kind
of position where
i would need to sit down at the board
for like one hour with someone ideally
with someone like you robert to talk me
through all the lines
and maybe then i would have some chance
of understanding what's going on
um but the players don't have that
luxury
so let's see so bishop f2 is on the
board
it is and dubov is playing with a piece
it looks like and
going to figure out how to continue and
you just
sort of inspired me fiona because
a position i would recommend and now
people know the answer but
this is the type of position that i
would uh definitely show
students and i say
you know it's black's move here what do
you think about the position i don't
want to say anything leading so i had so
a generic question what do you think so
they don't know oh black has a tactic
because people when they're giving
positions they almost always think
where's my winning tactic but that's not
how you think about chess like you can't
be results oriented think i'm going to
win this game where is it let me find it
you just have to find the best move and
here would be a great example of that
because when we first saw the position i
was trying to figure out what to do and
i was like i don't know where to move
any of my pieces this looks scary
what goes on here and then mama jar of
[ __ ] plays with bishop c5 which is a
really wonderful choice and
it just goes to show that with strong
calculation uh there's a reason why mama
jarv has been the number two rated
player in the world and is still one of
the top and most uh
fearsome players in the circuit
yeah absolutely and
although we see the engine bar that's
pretty much all the way down
to the the
the white side meaning black is
winning according to the engine this
game is far from over because it's the
kind of position it's not uh like an
extra piece plus four advantage it's
still a mess
um
so if black goes wrong the evaluation
can
can turn around very quickly but i very
much fancy uh my video with chances here
and you say it's not over but duboff's
face kinda says it's over
he is not looking particularly pleased
to be at the board
mama jarv is playing a nice sharp game
with accuracy and dubov you know he
invited the tactics but he has not been
informed in this game
to be fair duboff hasn't looked uh
pleased at any moment in this game
really i think as soon as we
we tuned in if we go back a little bit
um
i don't know to which moment
like very on this decision to give up
the the pawn was certainly uh
interesting but it somehow seemed to
backfire surprisingly quickly with shach
especially playing so quickly in the
opening
so um
i'm curious and as to what happened
there
i think this moment where he played for
e4 and i don't blame him because it
looks like a natural move in a position
like this but he played e4 and then
quickly his position collapsed and
that's sometimes how chess works is
these top-level players uh they're
making moves that you'd say oh that's a
principle choice e4 gaining space
pushing your pawn for taking away
squares from your opponent and yet he
made this move and then his position
collapsed very quickly and mama jarv to
his credit figured out a way to develop
in dubai's night went but it
really didn't do anything besides
getting trouble sorry to interrupt you
robert but uh
is now uh ready with the interview so
we're gonna go back there and hear what
he has to say
no okay we're gonna i think listen to
the the interview uh later on
um
so for now should we go to
oh we have the interview apologies let's
go to the interview
um
yeah of course
but
i
i didn't like the way i played
and
yeah after the opening i thought that
it should be slightly better position
for me but then i realized that
it's not it's not that clear
and
it's maybe maybe i'm just worse
somewhere
so
it's a quite good result i think
were you the one who actually offered to
draw
uh
yeah i think and did you expect him to
accept it
because that's not very common for him
um i didn't expect
that he he will accept the draw
because i thought at this moment that
maybe i'm slightly worse but
i didn't see where exactly
so
when he accept i was
like relieved a little bit
last year you beat magnus
this does this game make you famous in
the chess we'll keep people reminding
you of that
um
maybe
i think i think yes
okay thank you
thank you
thank you
and andreas sipenko they are clearly
happy and relieved to get away
with the draw and i like his kind of
honesty about yes i am i am still famous
for
for that win against magnus
uh last year robert i think we're going
to take a quick break uh to recover from
all these
emotions from our first decisive result
and and our first result not decisive
we're still waiting for the first
decisive
and uh we'll be we'll be back after a
very short break so don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the world rapid championships
from warsaw poland we're about to get
going magnus now forcing the king closer
yeah this is very very tricky for the
georgian player no and he bothers his
rook oh my gosh oh my god
and magnus wins the game and that was a
lesson in just pressure pressure
pressure
duda he has three pawns more than his
opponent duda has won three in a row he
is getting off to a fantastic start
gunana and castenu two players with a
perfect score they're going to be facing
each other kustenyuk once again has
turned it around and for the first time
in the game gunana is down on the clock
gunina is going to have to resign what
initially looked like an amazing game
from her
magnus still has the threat on the pawn
there's the threat of rook f2 magnus was
actually very clever in how he just
avoided the trade and shiro has lost on
time so we have three players in first
place right now in the open section this
round it's oliver ferrugia and magnus
carlson i think magnus is going to wrap
this up really quickly the king moves
away from the check magnus maneuvering
his knight to a superior position
and olivereza resigns the game the
number one and number two players in the
world right now and magnus calls him
coming out there victorious needing a
win here if he is to have a soul lead
magnus just simply retreating the king
one step back there's no stopping him
from getting a queen on the next move
he's gonna win it
and he's gonna take the lead in this
tournament
carlson playing against the youngster
from uzbekistan abdu satoru has beaten
some really strong players in this
tournament and that makes me kind of
optimistic about his chances against
magnus here and magnus now is going to
give up another pawn
wow look at this for the second time
magnus is giving up pawns in order to
just get rid of them uh if there's a
check coming in here from oh my god
and magnus resigns abdu satoru takes the
lead after a win against the reigning
champion carlson will have the
opportunity to strike back with the
white pieces against the ponyachi magnus
is probably regretting this knight cd5
now he's definitely forced to be playing
football he's not going to be catching
yon na ponyachi that was surely a very
disappointing game with the white pieces
it's the big matchup of this round if
casteniuk makes a draw with the black
pieces she will be crowned world
champion i would have to give the edge
to white in this position because of the
permanent nature of black's king
problems i agree that this is an
advantage for
white what they're it's over kistanyuk
is the champion yes castaneux she had a
wonderful tournament a very convincing
first place with nine points alexandra
castaneuk the new women's rapid world
champion nakamura facing off against
carlson we've been waiting for this
pairing and it couldn't have happened at
a better time when everything is on the
line magnus moved his rook and no longer
is trapping that king on the edge of the
board
yeah i mean rook a5 is a pretty good
move but also king g2 as you said
um
and magnus gives it up it's a draw and
the rules of the event stipulate that
only the two players with the best
tiebreak score will be allowed to play
the playoff third place then the bronze
medal for carlson it is up to saturn
getting ready for the game he will be
facing jana pomnyachi of russia and
black's king doesn't manage to get back
to defend the pawn so yanaponyachi is
steering this game towards a draw and
that means norderbeck is going to have
the match ball with the white pieces in
the next one nepal nychi getting rid of
that last black pawn norther back
getting rid of the white pawns the guys
shake heads the white king is trying to
run away from the checks the brook just
keeps checking in on that white king can
the king get away both players are down
to just 10 seconds on the clock the king
is finding shelter on the side of the
board now he's returning to that
checkmating idea that irena identified
earlier on and now here comes the new
queen the new queen comes in and then
he's going in for the checkmate napoleon
she will have to and he resigns no
defect abductor up is the new rapid
world champion wow this is an amazing
turn of events i mean what a special
moment that we're witnessing the world
rapids champion nor dear back abdu
satoru that is going to be a name to
remember for the future only 17 years
old and already a world champion
the
chess.com rapid chess championship is a
brand new world-class online rapid event
series for the top 100 players top women
and top juniors in the world watch as
the very best compete for their share of
20 000 each week culminating with a 150
thousand dollar prize final it all
starts at 9am pacific on saturday
february 12th right here on chess.com
for more info head over to go.chess.com
rcc but right now we are in the tata
steel tournament fiona we still have six
games remaining in the first round here
i haven't enjoyed the bird's eye view
this much
honestly in a long time so
what what do we look at whose game
yeah i think as long as that tube of
mamadirov game is still going on i think
our eyes will always go there but i also
see that in the van forest grandillus
game somehow that
h-pawn has also dropped off the board
now things are happening there so maybe
we can check in with jordan and ills
for sure i just brought the game up here
and we see that uh the h pawn fell so
let's go back to where we were it was
right here knight d1 which is a move
that we both applauded thought that was
a really good retreating move to bring
the knight forward uh next
rook b4 played attacking
two pawns a4 was played but that move
wasn't loved so interesting that the
move a4 which defends the b5 pawn is not
loved by the engine which means that
sort of a process of elimination knight
c3 even though it gives up the b2 pawn
or not i thought
what wait what
nope now it's going up
knight c3 isn't this position
what we looked at after rook b2 and a4
yeah it's quite similar to a position
we're looking at earlier but you know
knight c3 and just bl even if black wins
this pawn and the rook doesn't get
trapped a white has a clear edge because
this a pawn is rushing up the board the
bishop on f6 still is not a very good
piece and so white has much more freedom
and flexibility so instead of an a4
niels decided to strike with d5 which is
a great choice to my eyes opening up the
center trying to get e4 to work all this
tactical stuff queen d2
double attack
and here we saw queen d6
pawn takes d5
e4
and queen takes h6 because fiona
loose pieces drop off the rook on e8 is
undefended and at least temporarily
jordan is up
three pawns here
three pounds and yet the bar has dropped
to somehow the the middle the middle
line
this is getting really really messy as
well now the bad news for nils is he's
going to have to navigate the
complications with only eight minutes on
the on the clock
but the queen's coming off must be good
news for nils i guess
from a time point of view definitely
from a material point of view maybe
having like the queen and the bishops
and all that was giving him a good
counter play you know for example queen
takes d5 here you could keep the
initiative up there's no checkmating
attack the knight on f3 can't get into
the game on the king's side so perhaps
queen takes d5 was another choice that
was available but queen f8 we saw a
trade and now knight d2
and it is three extra pawns that can
quickly become two extra pawns
it just feels like a position where
white has zero risk whatsoever and can
enjoy
a healthy attempt at playing for a win
absolutely but on the other hand for
nils the good news is his bishop pair
earlier wasn't doing much now at least
those bishops have come to life
so i my feeling is that his chances um
at least maybe somewhat better than the
last time we saw the position but of
course jordan's still
in the driver's seat just a quick
question from the chat i just wanted to
get back to quentin who was asked uh who
was asking if we were going to interview
magnus so both magnus and jesse panko
were interviewed this was live on the
show but if you missed it you can find
all those interviews uh on the tata
steel chess tournament youtube page
and we will probably at some point in
tournament have some in studio
interviews as well but we'll save those
for the really really exciting
uh games
so uh yeah back to this um
[Music]
niels has just captured on d5 jordan is
taking his time maybe we can jump around
a little bit uh while we let jordan
think
let's do it so let's just try to go
through all the games we'll go to first
inikiri against pragmata we have the
local star in a niche career from the
netherlands playing in vikings a here
and trying to win his first
vikings a tattoo steel masters term he's
tied for first on numerous occasions
including last year unfortunately he's
never been able to secure the title and
honestly fiona not off to a great start
his position looked interesting earlier
i liked the initiative that he was
getting but it looks like pragmata the
youngster has fended off everything in a
nice way and in fact i would take
black's position here in this end game
yeah i have to say i'm really really
impressed with how pragnanda handled
what we thought was a a difficult
position with a a king
uh in the center
of the board and when we left off he
actually just played that move which was
hurting your soul f5 but it seems to
have worked out not too badly for him so
let's maybe see what uh what we missed
here a lot happened of course
well they went for the queen trade line
95 check
came to g8 so i had just quickly said ke
is a possibility and after the trade of
bishop for night the
sides now have equal material but it
looks like a position where
white is a little bit better in terms of
coordination but look at this move
bishop f6 and then the knight moved away
because if this bishop takes on e5 at
some point opposite colored bishops
likely just secures a draw in most of
these positions so he moved the knight
to c4 also trying to go for d6 but then
after b6
bishop f4 h5 played and your knight gets
to d6 but so what the bishop retreats
where's this rook getting in not e7 not
e8 and e6 isn't exactly that tempting
knight goes back to e4 and then we see a
trade with king f7 there's definitely
nothing here
for
white and the reason why fiona i like
black's position is that in end games
having outer most pawns can often be an
advantage and if we look at the
situation here white has
this pawn on d4 in the center and black
has this pawn here on b6 so their
outside pass pawn potential for black of
course the game is equal right now we
see the eval bar saying as much but in
an end game like this i like the
outermost pawns better which is why
grunfeld end games are often pretty good
for black whereas in the middle game
with an extra pawn in the center that's
what white enjoys in the end game black
enjoys the outermost pawn
yeah and i i really like that
explanation and i think your explanation
is backed up by
an anish
who is looking deep in
deep in thought and not
too happy he can't be too happy
especially from the position he had uh
to to get here now
the question that is a niche to move the
last
the last black move was work to a to d1
what do we want to do can we try and go
in with the rooks should we try and
bring our king
how should anish proceed do you think
yeah he can bring his king towards the
center that makes perfect sense i think
the big issue i'm having is i don't see
a way to proceed for a niche like he can
make an assortment of moves bishop e5
king f2 but at best he's playing for a
draw so even though the game is for sure
equal and with the precise play which i
think we'll see it will be a draw which
is a great result for pragnando with the
black pieces i just don't see any
winning chances whatsoever for white
whereas i see some possibilities where
all of a sudden black gets a move like
rook d5 and then you have to think about
is c5 coming is rook a5 coming what do i
have to be concerned about and so i just
think as this game continues it's black
who has the winning chances even if
they're slight
he's the only one
absolutely um so i think let's move on
from here because
i think these guys will be here for a
while unless the drawers agreed we could
check in with fabiano or which
if something's happening there i'll let
you i'll let you choose robert
oh no i'm spoiled for choice so
let's go to the do buff game to see if
there have been any updates it looks
like the position has changed a bit but
the evaluation bar has not after king h1
queen b6 was in fact played and dubai
decided to play bishop takes b8 rather
than knight takes b8 as we mentioned
knight beat is was met by e5 bishop
takes b8 queen c6 you could take f2
black takes b8 and that's just a trade a
piece and blacks have two pawns so
nothing
really has happened here that
should lead us to believe
anything other than
mama jarva is going to win this game
because he's well ahead this is a minus
four and change position and it just
looks obviously minus you know a bunch
for black it's not that complicated
anymore
absolutely i don't think shach will
let anything happen here he will be
looking to safely drive home
at the full point and um do you want to
we could see fabiano is making progress
we liked his position
risk-free advantage let's see how that
has progressed
well
optically looks great for white you have
this pawn chain little pawn chain here
but that's aiming towards the black king
so the king on g7
it's not under attack but it's also
not that safe this knight on g4 it's
fine because it can retreat to h6 but
the pawns in the center are taking care
of many of the squares so i still really
like the look of white's position and
yet i sit i think it's sergey karjakin
if anybody is okay
in a position like this emotionally it's
karjakin but as you pointed out and
we're correct too fiona if people push
these positions fabiano is generally
speaking very good at pushing from a
position like this from the white side
yeah what do you think what would you
estimate
the chances that fabiano can win
this game
i think this next move is extremely
important if he makes the move a knight
g5 i think he has decent chances if he
doesn't i could see a situation where
black trades and gets this rook down
into the position can double rooks get
very active and that means that white
won't be in time to strike on the king
side so knight g5 uh looks good to me
because if we see a trade in comes this
queen to g5 oh actually maybe pawn takes
place that night getting trapped if i
take with the pawn
f3 next and bye bye night
yeah and that's sunny i hadn't even seen
the var shoot up there but i think
absolutely right tonight on uh
on g4 is uh
it's gone
yeah it's funny i was gonna play queen
takes g5 and say okay i'm play f3
not realizing that i could trap your
knight instead i was going for the
attack with queen f6 check and e6 and
all that stuff it's still a very nice
position but winning a piece is better
so after knight g5 you cannot take on g5
which probably means like queen e7
should be played but white sort of
can
after training nice and bring this queen
up f3 just when knight g5 is on the
board
yeah it's a very fabiano like move uh
mostly because it's good but also
because he's not one to sort of dilly
dally he really likes seizing the
initiative he's a great at calculation
so in comes knight g5 and now it's
karjakin down to 15 minutes for 15 tough
moves so both players are in relative
time trouble
yeah we're getting closer here let's
remind everyone
it is a very long time control the
players get hundred
minutes plus 30 seconds per move for the
first 40 moves then additional 50
minutes for the next 20 moves again
always there is always a 30 second
increment from move one and finally
after move 60 an extra 15 minutes but i
feel very often especially leading up to
the first time control we don't notice
that difference so much of the extra 10
minutes because i feel very often the
players just burn those extra
10 minutes sort of in the opening and
middle games and we find ourselves uh
with the same sort of uh time
trouble situation towards the end of the
first time control
yeah the players who play fast will play
fast pretty much regardless of the time
patrol the players who like to think
they're going to be deep in the think
tank at relatively early moments so i
agree with you fiona an interesting
choice though by carjacking
takes b4 allowing knight takes e6 check
to mix up the pawn structure and
knight take g5 isn't a plan because we
just saw h65 will trap the knight on g4
so fabian has a choice does he take on
e6 or does he just simply go quickly
take back on b4 your move sergey what
are you going to do and one of the
really big ideas is to play b5 for white
so queen e7 it does protect this knight
but it allows b5 and the queen is no
longer covering this d5 pawn so if the
c6 pawn is gone down goes d5 this
position really looks promising for
fabiano and i would keep the status quo
and take on b4 rather than taking on e6
even if taking on e6 and then taken
before is also
really nice
yeah i wonder if we
if we need to be a little bit concerned
first of all about that move you're just
highlighting queen e7 but also about the
opening of the
the f file
i feel i prefer the other line you
showed just because i've i feel my
feeling is we give the opponent a little
bit less counter play
i i'm with you there are fewer options
for black after a takes b4 so a takes b4
is what fabiano just in fact played and
if queen e7 now there's no pawn hanging
on h4 and g5 is already defended thanks
to the pawn and the queen so b5 is
possible trying to break down this
little pawn chain here and if d5 falls
and black is just in a world of hurt
this position is really unpleasant for
karjakin and i i know
i keep stating if anyone can do this
it's cardiac and but the more i look at
it the less i like black's position and
i think that no matter who the player is
they're going to be very uncomfortable
in the current setup
absolutely i i also really fancy
fabiano's
chances so we will
come back here there's one game i was
curious about
it's duda report i feel we haven't
seen it in a little while that was very
interesting
i just wanted to check if we can get an
update there
whoa
it's a very different position than when
we left off absolutely let's shall we go
back to where we left off maybe
let's do it so it was around
so he did in fact play knight c5 so he
didn't take on e5 he played knight c5
and after the trade it's more or less
what we're talking about where
black wins a pawn but
the queen side is favorable for white
even though black has the material and
rook d7
came
up there and then rook d1 and i mean you
look at this position fiona at least to
me material doesn't seem that important
no
what we see of course is the the white
king that's on f2 it looks
safe for now but
it's also not too hard to imagine black
managing to to break up uh this pawn
bunker
um
[Music]
and yeah that's actually what he set out
to do on the very next move with this
move h5
yeah he says you know i will go h4 which
looks like it's a free pawn but after
queen h2 there's no way to defend and uh
the bunker is no more black is
infiltrated but duda says yeah take that
pawn back
i'm just going to
organize my pieces in a healthy manner
and this is where
i'm curious because
white has all of the fun here in terms
of peace placement
can black make a crazy move like f5 it's
not my game so if it loses immediately
so be it i can just take it back explain
my thought process and then make a
different move but f5 is the type of
move when i see a king and i see a rook
i want to open up the file in between
them
yeah i like that
i like that i did a lot
i don't know what the response should be
but it also is scary
opening up a rook on the seventh rank
but hey i don't want to sit passively i
want to try to
uncork an attack so what if i try and
hit g7 if i go queen d4
uh so you're trying to say don't notice
checkmate in one move and i'll think
about it i'll say i want to play pawn
takes e4
i'll i guess i'll go queen h6 just to
defend against checkmate and can i play
a weird move like
king g1 my idea is i want to go rook h2
and i want to step out of the f file
well that really caught me off guard but
that looks
really fascinating rook h2
to just get this queen out of there and
go for oh
uh
yeah i mean king ju1 is honestly kind of
awesome
i love that move wow
and i maybe black has to just distract
white's pieces and play c5 in response
like get away from my king but this is
uh
yeah this is very dangerous looking so i
can completely understand why i reported
very double in a double-edged position
here actually
um in the game though uh report didn't
go f5 which certainly i
i like the look of it although i can't
even tell this position here i also
certainly like to look at it a bit for
white so report decided he wanted none
of that and went c5
and young kristoff getting his king to
g2 so now the queen has no entry squares
and also i guess it's in a way a little
bit of a prophylactive move because f5
could still be happening in the future
so i think the king just a little bit
safer
on g2
yeah it's definitely much safer over
here and
now it's starting to look promising for
white the rook on d7 is a great piece
the rook on d2 might join the rook on d7
the seventh rank later if this rook
moves somewhere along the rank and
i mean black
with the exception of f5 i don't see
active play here this bishop now can
move away it couldn't move before
because queen h2 check would have been a
problem now the h file is covered by the
king this bishop leaves f1 and this is
this is not good for black
yeah also this game here the time is
ticking down we see both players at the
board very focused uh i think we should
come back here let's quickly check i'm
reading that vidit
is pressing so let's go back to vidit
against uh shankland
all right i'll pull that up right now
and we see that vidit here he has the
white pieces
a lot has changed the last one was f6
ben feingold is saying never do that but
we left off just to quickly go through
the moves h5 c5 the break by shanklin
saying i'm not going to let you
checkmate me
i need to open up files for my pieces
and the rook came to c1 we see a trade
knight f8 is the choice and this is why
the eval bar
the players don't sit in this position
and say oh it's equal they think oh it's
interesting white has some chances to
make moves like rook c5 going after this
pawn here black says let me defend the
pawn and perhaps the other rook was
better but how do you know that you need
to calculate it's very difficult and
once this happened the rook came to c8
the rook came to d7 and then the knight
to e2 and the problem in this position
as the rooks were traded and the knight
came to f4 is white is first to the
action white's knight attacks his pawn
on d5 which you would love to win this
rook can slide to e3 or c3 and go for
the open file and if you play knight e6
you may just be strategically lost in a
position like this i guess
you see the eval bar going up because
white's rook will end up on this file we
can take on g6 first but white's rook
will then infiltrate and then this pawn
is a backwards pawn
it's not a situation that you want to be
in this king actually can i ask you a
question about this uh this position
right here because that's right here in
this kind of end game i'm never too sure
do i want to take on g6 or do i want to
go h6
and try and restrict the black king so
i'm curious to hear your thoughts on
that
normally i would want to play h6 because
i usually restrict the king try to get
my rook to the seventh rank but i think
in this position you can just walk here
like rook over here and i think that
this just is strategically one for white
because uh when we look at the position
white controls the open file and black
can't attack anything this king can just
come to e3 and it's trying to walk all
the way up into
over here into e5 and let's say you play
rook d7 and say you're not playing king
f4
after rook f7 now i have check and after
king g7 i move like rook to e8 and your
pawns are all in trouble so basically
this position is just already very
concrete
yes and the whole position is just
falling apart from black and
it's kind of crazy right it looks like
an even position by material what's the
big deal no white is just much more
active and has better pawns
yeah so looking tough for some let's see
after f6
so vidiq decided to take on f6 first
and
i think sam wants to play king f7 and
win this pawn back but
it's probably not that straightforward
but that's kind of the obvious idea at
least
when we have a look so if king f7
and that's what sam has just done
okay
and how much time so they both have
plenty of time given the position but i
was looking to see are they in huge time
trouble because then the game could just
end i think i would take on g6
and then i would make this move knight
d3 to go knight e5 i like that a lot too
yeah for black you can win the pawn but
it's not just about the material count
it's not the quantity it's the quality
now my threat is rook f3 rook f7 if you
play king to g7 i still play rook f3
rook f7
yeah my night covers this is terrible
for black this is really really bad and
vidic kept the pressure up and i know
fiona right we got there you're like uh
there's no queens the end game and most
players feel that way but the pressure
was mounting and shanklin he plays his
move f6 eventually and he may
liquidate a little bit but the resulting
position is a huge problem for him yeah
it's so tough in these positions i don't
know f6 maybe was not the best move but
i find it's so hard as the defending
side
to
i think this maybe it was difficult
anyway but it's so hard to to decide
when do you need to just sit and do
nothing and when do you have to try and
defend more more actively and it's a
it's a tough balance to strike
and sometimes you have to think
creatively and we often think endgame's
creativity what are you talking about
but this is a position where in
i don't put a number on it but i will
just because people like that let's say
99 of positions you would never play the
move g takes h5 maybe this is the
position where you do play g takes h5
because it frees up a square for your
knight um it distracts some of white's
pieces in the process so g takes h5 i i
don't think i could play that in the
game if i wasn't just talking about it
but now that i'm thinking about it like
this knight coming in that looks really
scary but maybe this is acceptable for
black even if it looks terrible like i i
can't even look at it i'm going to be
honest but you see the eval bar actually
saying that
yeah i'm shocked to be honest
is that are we sure
are we sure this is plus 0.6 but this
looks really bad for black and yet it's
apparently a position that you can just
continue it
yeah no very interesting uh stuff here
despite the reduced material
but this one is indeed
i really like your suggestion of knight
d3 here
it seems actually quite straightforward
is improving
does it make
does rook f3 make any sense
aha tactical
yes
it does
i'm wondering if rook
d6 somehow is a
reply here for black and then you can
play you know either rook takes f6 or
knight d7 after but
still doesn't seem all that comfortable
for black regardless like the rook can
swing over to c3 at any moment
robert i'm sorry to interrupt you i
think since these guys will make
time control i'm reading in the chat
that a lot is happening in the media of
games so let's go back there and we'll
come back to this one a bit later
okay here we go
wow and the first thing i see
is our
evaluation bar robert
see this is why we never speak of
results because as soon as we say
oh it's going to be completely this or
completely that it just never happens
and
how did this happen so it's just a few
moves have been played bishop b8
bishop e5 excuse me
knight e4
bishop d6
and then for some reason rook d8 is not
the correct move and
rook d8 makes a lot of sense but i'm
guessing there are some back rank
problems that black needs to deal with
and so rook d8
walks into something bishop takes b4
somehow like
wait actually is it just bishop
b4 i can tell you i don't know can
robert see the notes as well or is it
just me no so robert i can tell you i
got the answer here there's only one
move here for duboff that holds like
that gets the equality
and uh is it not bishop take before
because it's not bishop b4 oh well then
okay look how hard this position is
right like if i see
the eval bar shoot up to equal i'm like
oh you blundered upon as a background
checkmate so it's not that
um
rook a6 maybe
no that looks
not good because bishop back to b6 now
i'm playing this guessing game where i'm
not going to get it right and then
everyone can laugh at me
like this is a difficult position
because actually once you see it it
makes
sense i think because there's a pinch
piece in the position oh okay then
rookie two yeah okay too you don't you
as soon as you pin piece i'm like oh
wait a second yeah
ah so rookie two and f5 there's amphison
after
that okay i mean this is still all very
far from
very far from obvious
i mean rookie 2 is like
you should go through all your motions
and consider the options here but rookie
2 i understand there's a pin piece and i
should have thought let me attack the
pin piece but there's also background
checkmate problems so bishop takes b4 is
tempting to remove
uh your rook from the back rank and then
i can try to bring my pieces down to the
last rank so i mean rookie 2 is such a
nice patient move taking advantage of a
pin piece here but wow
yeah i think it's one of these example
it's very easy to get tunnel vision like
especially this a file tunnel like you
think okay these two pieces need to stay
there because that's how i can create
some
some counter chances and then to just
remove
uh one of one of those pieces sometimes
it's just very hard to to consider these
moves
and it's like not even the end of
variation like these are the type of
positions where you then have to study
like i don't even know how to make ten
moves like so rookie two f5 if you take
ambassador
on f6 i could take your bishop on d6
here and then you take on e4
and then i have all sorts of different
moves possible but my bishop one f2 is
loose that's part of the problem so how
do i defend that bishop i'm not really
sure because of queen b6 you take my i
can take my rook here you can also
like throw an f7 check for white at some
point maybe even before bishop takes e4
i play f7 to bring your king to the f
file nope apparently that's not right
like this is how
just wild this position is he's done it
robert rookie two is on the board
okay
and i mean mama jarv has
no choice besides playing f5 i believe
can we just answer one question from the
chat because i was wondering the same
thing from ranked uh i've lost him but
he was asking what was wrong with queen
b1 with the
with the same idea of hitting that
that pinned knight
queen b1
what is wrong with it um
so you attack the
94 that's the good news but i think you
have some back rank problems of your own
to deal with
in this position so
oh my gosh i really have to put my
thinking cap on for this game like i was
happy to be in a position oh it's gonna
be a win you know this position looks
all calm but you know black's just ahead
and then now you're like queen b1 what's
the difference here but i
there must be a back rank thing so let
me think about it so this is the square
ah
yes rook
rook d5
you walk yourself into more of a pin
but the point is that if you take with
the bishop i take on d1 and then when
you're bishop on e4 and if you take with
the queen your rook's hanging and if you
take here i take with the pawn and just
that's an incredible move with d5
this game is just ridiculous like
it
is so bizarre and yeah let's go back so
after rookie two shark instantly
instantly played f5
and uh look at the time situation here
we're only on move 27 which means the
players still have 13 moves to make each
and do buff is down to under six minutes
shack only three and a half minutes on
the clock
yeah this is anybody's game at this
point and e takes f6 ampersand played
wait
that has to be the move but i guess the
engine is trying to figure out this
position as well right uh the engine
being not on the highest of depth but
look it's thinking it's thinking there
it goes oh it's just
a little bit better for black but i mean
fiona the engine tells you the what
but it doesn't tell you the why so even
when i see this evaluation i'm thinking
after rook takes d6
as i mentioned before do i take on e4
right away or do i play f7 check trying
to draw the king out into the open uh
but the problem playing f7 or the
downside is you no longer have tension
on g7 which you may want to have in some
positions for like forcing a g takes f6
at some moment so
it's really interesting dynamic right
now and also we see on the camera
shakhir mahmed yaw of earlier we saw him
sipping
his tea you know he looked so calm but
now with the time ticking down and of
course the players although unlike us
they don't see the evaluation but i
think they still
sense um
even if they can't put it in numbers
like is the evaluation equal now or how
much better am i but they sense that
they've lost control uh of the position
that the opponent is back you can also
tell it from your your opponent's body
language if we look at duboff here like
this is not the same duboff we saw uh an
hour ago
and so uh yeah we see now shahid medyarf
looking slightly more and nervous which
is normal the position is a complete
mess all three results are possible uh
suddenly
and uh duboff there he is also sensing
his chance
and look at this moment here c2 played
by mama jar of the pin still exists but
now the rook on d1 is under attack would
love to take that so the question for do
both do i throw an f7 check do i move my
rook where do i move my rook to c1 to f1
i like f1 because it attacks the bishop
on f2 and the 94 is going to be captured
uh so i like rook f1 i'm just not sure
do i throw in f7 check first or not
and i don't know how to answer the
question either
yeah how do you how do you make that
kind of decision during the game i think
he has reached yeah he has gone f7
okay well it's clear
and now rook f1 for sure
and this is a problem
ah
wait i'm not sure at all like i'm
wait so if wait i don't know tactics
which based on knight g3 at some point
so the bishop
saves the day but yeah if knight g3 pawn
g3 and rook h5 would uh be a checkmate
right so they're very cute yeah
yeah that would not be fun for
white to see but we're not some time to
take on d6 i guess yeah
yeah i mean queen takes d6 let's say we
start with that then after bishop takes
e4 i mean this bishop is
lost on f2 because pinned and then this
is hanging so you know what fiona you
might need to start with this move here
c1 equals queen
this is game oh my god in the best way i
mean that was like a compliment to the
game like rook to
d1
like that's the uh sorry see when he
goes queen
d1 i don't know what i'm saying but see
when he goes queen uh is the move and
then if you take on c1 now queen takes
d6 and after bishop takes e4
there's some move here what is it
how does it survive i distracted your
rook away but i don't have rook f5
i've done that
what a mess is right but what is the
move here
like how is it just
i was trying to distract the rook
where is it
where is
what if i
take
can i take on g
three probably not right
oh my gosh you know what just happened
you're not going to believe this what in
my head i thought the bishop was still
pinned
like i'm like oh i didn't even think
about moving the bishop because in my
head the rook was still on f1 and you
should take on g3 i'm like if you're not
you're sacrificing your queen like yeah
what and then i'm like oh you mean
bishop g okay if the bishop can move
then obviously black is still fighting
here wow that was uh
okay i'm gonna but maybe then we also if
you just missed that then maybe not
bishop g3 maybe bishop
d4 or him
yeah the bishop can just retreat uh i
was looking like rook f5 doesn't make
any sense now that i realize the bishop
can move i thought the rook was still
here okay
it's been uh
been a fascinating morning of chess rook
f1 is indeed played and i do think that
mama jarv has to play c1 now
yeah this is a big moment here three
minutes on the clock now each
what do you what if you had to predict
the result
in this moment of time robert what would
it be
i predict that i will not be able to
predict most the next bunch of moves um
but besides that
i
i still want to say
mama jarvis good chances but his king is
the weaker king right now so in time
trouble usually the side that has to
defend the king
is the one struggling so
i think we will know within the next 10
moves i think it's very likely to be
this game is very likely to be decided
here in the first time control
yes and you look at their faces you
mentioned uh noticeable shift
uh dubo still doesn't look like that
thrilled and chess players even if their
current position is pretty good they're
still mad at themselves for like playing
badly earlier so
i think dubois is not exactly happy
about this game whereas mama jarvis
focused on the other hand
how many times have you seen daniel
duboff look really thrilled
wow that's a
great question
he's not easily thrilled or at least he
doesn't show it
yeah you really made me think about this
i don't have a good answer for you i've
played him once so i i stared at him his
face for hours and hours one time and
i've commentated a ton of his chest and
yeah you're you have a point there
he's one of these players who rarely
expresses uh joy at the at the board
um
like i mean
it's even rare that you see him smile or
look happy but at least he looks less
upset than he did earlier but i agree
with you it's strange to see him if we
didn't know the evaluation of the
position based on what i was seeing i i
would think that he's bordering on lust
but i look at shakha mama media with one
minute on the clock now
still has to make 11 moves here
yeah this is such a difficult position
they do have a 30 second increment which
will help his cause but look at mama
jarv he's up right he's trying to find
this move here and yes i saw someone in
the chat and i typically don't look at
you but did wait what
what maybe there was a draw for after
work f1 no
no no no
oh
look
i say this every time this happens i
understand why players do this to like
you know salvage a half point to make
sure that they have no risk but
draw offers are so bad
we've been uh we've been treated of a
really really exciting finale here
i am
devastated
yeah so of course a disappointing
uh draw agreement there for us chess
fans this was by far the most exciting
game of today
but
i think we understand i think from
dupoff's perspective he knows he was
lost and i think it's a it's an
interesting uh moment for drawfur
and uh putting shaq in a difficult spot
because mamadiar also knows of course he
was probably knows he was winning
um but
just this moment the tide is turning and
yeah a disappointing draw for us
i'm switching the game we're going to do
whoa
so dude is down a pawn but according to
the evil he's completely winning and
it's because black can't do much of
anything this king is coming into g5
there's a rook on the seventh rank and
no i i do understand it from the
player's perspective of course i've
played a ton of chess in my life and
sometimes you are nervous or you offer a
draw or accept a draw for um it just i
do feel like it deprives fans
and just the general public of like
there's no finality there it's like the
game has ended and you have to explain
wait why did it end they offered a draw
how come you can even offer a draw why
is that a thing and then we get
distracted by that instead of letting
the moves do the talking so i do get it
but
i don't like it and i haven't liked it
for a long time and i've been very
expressive about it so i i think um on
the bright side i think we're slowly but
surely moving
towards a future where
uh draw offers are prohibited and more
and more
events like i think if we compare the
situation that we have these days to
what it was many years ago uh i think
we're we're slowly but surely getting
there but of course uh
to that a day like today um certainly
very disappointing for for us as jasmine
i'm a little frustrated but the bird's
eye view is here to make me feel better
we don't really care about all of you
it's not making me feel better right now
uh but in all seriousness we still have
five games going and as i look across
those boards here uh jordan van forest
he's up one pawn and has some passers
rolling up the
queen side but his king is in a bit of a
pickle we see vidit has an advantage
against shanklin thanks to the superior
placement of his pieces the knight on e5
is wonderful the rook on f3 on an open
file while the rook on d8 is sitting a
bit passively
giri against pragmananda is level but i
still
you know think that if i took either
side it would be black in
dude against report we know that duda is
better even though he's down a pawn
because those pawns are locked on dark
squares and might fall off and the king
on g7 is less safe than the approaching
king coming to g5 at some point and then
we see carwana and karjakin in a
slugfest that might peter out with a
queen trade and
that's all the games because so which
one which one hasn't reached mu 40 yet
let's have a quick look at do die
um so do that we're on move
35
yep we could stay here dude is uh only
30 seconds on the clock
uh and about to make his move king g5 so
the king is approaching
uh rapport instantly responds with shade
and is there like there's no mating now
h5 it could share the square we made or
f6 would be checkmate so if you can
somehow
it's not made actually king would come
back to h4 but this king on g5 is a
great piece but it could also find
itself in trouble if you're not careful
that said it looks awesome
yeah so
what do we
okay so dude goes rook c7
threatening i guess
to to bring the other rook to the
seventh rank
and also of course you know hitting the
pawn on c5 that's a good point
it's just such a depressing position for
for report
i'm wondering though what happens if
black offers an exchange of rooks
because the second rook can land on the
seventh rank but the f3 pawn is loose
you don't really want to give up that f3
pawn so i'm wondering what happens if
black just chases the rook around
the rook v8
i like that that you convinced the
engine with your move robert
i feel powerful
rook c8 was in fact played and
if you trade
your f6 check is available is even
available before taking back on c8 but
it's available in the future f3 needs to
be
watched so
i think that black actually
isn't in quite as terrible shape as i
initially thought rook e7 though
but can we keep just keep hitting that
rook
if i
i think so
he can trade now that the rook will be
on a worse file i'm not sure if that
matters all that much
but it probably does and actually at
some point f5
can be considered for white like it's a
very weird move but f6 check
is
something you would like to
make works rook d7 he just goes back to
d7 and there's obviously no rook d8
you'd lose a rook
oh sorry uh
we have daniel duboff with an interview
robert so let's just go down we'll come
back here right away
uh danielle did you feel in any danger
during the game
not really no i think i was probably
lost but it's not about feeling danger
dangerous
that's actually i felt very comfortable
but was probably lost yeah this is
comfortable in what sense
life is good i don't know okay okay
but about the position that's what i
meant yeah
yeah the position was probably bad at
some point
but this overall aftertaste is kind of
nice now i think
it was a weird game i was probably like
much worse lost in the beginning then
i feel like
maybe
like i i don't know like two
two or three moves before the
draw agreement i was probably completely
winning but yeah it's uh
it's all in the game that's what you
mean yeah it's nice i mean also
yeah i must say sometimes like you your
results can be good but you can feel
sort of uh
not really comfortable yeah and
sometimes it's exactly the opposite like
in general
uh like within last year i was like
constantly tired i was playing like a
chicken a little like i was playing some
solid games and i mean okay the
results were for fine i even increased
my rating and stuff but in general i
didn't feel like it's
like it's me you know
and this time no i mean it's me yeah
it's uh like i'm probably far from uh
from my best shape but at least this
game you can actually tell who who
played it as well yeah i mean it just
puts the bishop on youtube
sacrifice spawns for nothing i don't
know starts start playing for tricks no
no this is i mean it feels nice to be
back anyway okay thank you thanks
well never a dull moment
with daniel duvoff that's for sure he's
back to himself with a trademark game um
robert what did you make of his
interview
you know i'm happy he didn't lose
because this way he gave an interview
it was it was definitely entertaining to
hear his thoughts and he called himself
a chicken which i wasn't expecting
but
the game itself was fascinating he
recognized that he was in big trouble
then he was so optimistic that he felt
like maybe you know he could even win
and then of course the game came to an
abrupt end with the draw and i'm much
more fascinated by this current position
but between duda and a report because
what duda did is really instructive we
saw rook c7 and then we saw rook c8 and
then rook e7
rook e8 and then rook d7 was like what
was all this shuffling about but the
reason is that black doesn't actually
have a good move right now if you move
this rook away from the e file you lose
e6 that pawn is pinned if you move your
king back in comes the white king going
for the crush and so
rook f8 was played and now he played
rook c7 and he might be doing a bunch of
the same stuff he's just waiting and you
see
rook h8 was played and now up goes that
evaluation bar and for black here there
are so many problems c5 is
loose there's problems in the seventh
rank and that move was not liked at all
by the engine and i assume it's just
let's bring the next rook to the party
yeah rook d7 and rook d7 was move 40 by
the way
so duda will now get an additional 50
minutes
um
which should be plenty to
to convert this from here
it's f5 i mean you just f7 goes down
because you can't take with the g pawn
after f5
you lose the bishop if you take with the
e pawn well then down goes f7 in some
way shape or form and i mean you're just
completely crushed here
yeah this
looks uh
very much like uh game over i'm hearing
that jordan van ferece is also getting
closer to winning his game so maybe we
can check in with jordan and niels
okay let's see how that one's going oh
many moves whoa two healthy protected
past pawns here and it's white's turn
otherwise black would play uh rook to c1
and that would be a bit of an issue for
white so
what happened here so let's move forward
move 40 was just played by black so
they're getting more time second time
patrol which means we can take a little
bit
to go back where was it here we saw the
queen trade
rook e3 bishop d4 i mean black has so
much activity in this position
f5
g3
so where did it go wrong
took
oh i think we found our culprit bishop
c4 was not approved of by the engine
that's immediately clear why is bishop
c4
we just not want to put the bishop on
the c file because of the pawn on c7
exactly now this one's hanging and if
you take on f1 the the f5 pawn's also
hanging so you're just dropping a pawn
and he tried to bring his bishop in for
the attack but look at this move you
don't just take a pawn because it's
hanging we talked about this earlier
because then bishop f3 is quite scary as
rook g2 is happening you're probably
just losing i'll even show that on the
board bishop f3 and good luck to your
king with
rook g2 about to happen and there it is
losing for white so instead
rook c1 great move that way bishop f3
can always be met by rook c2 with a
trade and now we see rook c2 this is
under attack this is under attack and
it's a lost ending this is amazing fiona
because we get here
and this type of ending is just losing
the king is cut off this rook can always
slide back to the fifth rank and start
winning more pawns and that's why he
didn't go for it
yeah fascinating
fascinating stuff and this one it was
really a topsy turvy if we come back to
well let's get to the current position
but jordan was better then things got
out of hand a little bit niels fought
his way back
but now jordan seems to be to be firmly
back in control we probably need to deal
with this
uh thread of
oops yeah
yeah i thought of rook c1
yeah i mean b6 deals with the threat
it would seem although perhaps there's
some mating nets that you need to be
careful about curious let's have a look
so if you go b6 rook c1
seven
there's nothing
no you're a little bit too slow it looks
like like rook f1 check king g2 you need
to go rook f3 bishop here
there's no time this way and if you move
elsewhere bishop f3 is just a single
check if i take with the bishop video
king will always escape if i have to
yeah exactly
check we have two and
i'll just go back and run away
you know what's um curious to me fiona
is at this moment here
after rook c4
he went king e7 and allowed rook 67 with
check
i was very curious
he's obviously in trouble regardless
he's just down a pawn and the knight's
about to get out
things like that but to play king e7
seems quite odd to me
especially with those
i mean the only thing i can see i think
both players were solo on the clock
maybe he thought he would get that
counter play with the rook coming down
to the first rank
um
but yeah it looks like that variation
you showed with the beep on running is
just convincing um
it was convincing
yeah so uh that was the problem is
knight d2 rook takes and the b pawn
going up would have been a problem so
that's why king e7 was played and we get
to the live position that's just
sorry
goes for knight d2
okay
which looks good enough as well and not
giving the knight the king
will be able to get out via f2 and
basically black is helpless against
those a and b pawns just running out of
devoid
indeed so it looks like uh this one is
about to be over um i just at the corner
of my eye saw the
karjakin position where karjakin is up
upon an end game uh it's going to be a
draw it's a very easy theoretical draw
and
i don't like to
you know state things about results but
here
in their game it's a
it's a complete draw
no chance to win in both an impressive
and impressive defensive effort oh and
just as we say that the drawer has been
agreed between fabiano caruana and
sergey
karyakin so we're still waiting for our
first decisive game but it looks like
jordan
the current
title holder will be the one to to
deliver that unless duda gets there
first
yeah they're in a race to see who wins
uh we can you know we can come back to
this uh
caruana kayaking game later but
props to sergey he is such a good
defender and here expecting f5 from
duda it looks just crushing and yes
by the way for the clock situation once
the player
you know gets to their zero with the
next move they make they will be gaining
the time they've already gained it on
the physical clock the dgt relay the way
it works is it will
uh add the time once the move has been
made but they have not lost on time
don't worry
and let's maybe just the only let's
quickly very quickly check in with vidit
and then with anish and then we'll go on
a on a short break
well this position
rook knight four pawns per side and yet
the eval bar is sky high for
gujarati a fan favorite um you know of
course he is a top player in his own
right the indian number two but he's
also become very popular as a content
creator and a streamer and look at this
position fiona where it's equal material
and yet
white is well ahead and the reason why
is after rook f7 your knight on f8 is
not going anywhere if you ever push this
pawn say to b5 this rook can go over to
a7 activity speaks volumes and white's
pieces are just perfectly placed if b5
can we not just simply take the pawn as
well
off
even better point i was going for the to
win a pawn you said why not do it
directly then a takes b5 the knight is
loose
it's funny i'm looking at like these
longer term thoughts and you're like
robert slow down a takes b5 is free the
taker fun
i like it seems like a
uh strong idea here i mean black has
problems no matter what move is played
here like let you say play b6 let's just
wait what's your next move right you
just don't have one
it's a
it's a really depressing position for
sam and vidit has all the time in the
world here to decide on a plan is he
gonna bring his king in is he gonna go
for a pawn push
um yeah i i don't think sam is gonna be
able to to hold on here
yeah and i don't envy his task it's one
of these positions where
nobody in the world would want to have
this position from the black side uh
it's just clear that white has the edge
and can press forever and black will
have to play accurately and
what move do you even play is black here
that's another question do you play king
d6 which
will lose the g pawn but i wouldn't even
cash in if i were uh white like i could
take this pawn because i have rook f6
check at the end but why take it it's
not going anywhere and black still can't
move
that's right that's a
rough day at the offense today has not
been a fun day for for sam who really um
from what we saw
never really got
a chance to to get into
the game and was just on the defending
foot all game long but it looks like a
nice game from vidiq who will now just
need to put the finishing touches on it
that's right and uh we have an interview
with sergey karjakin so let's go there
uh sergei from the press room it seemed
that today you had to work hard for the
draw
did you feel the same
yes i got a bad position
at some point a moment uh he played the
sideline which
okay of course i didn't expect but later
on
i got very unpleasant position and he
was pressing pressing and i think he was
playing very well and
i was lucky that he played rook c1
allowed me to play c5 and maybe after c5
i'm still worse but
not so much
but as usual you defend it very well
well
it's not that i want to get such
positions but
i have strong opponents and
they're really good
uh i saw you yesterday at the opening
you seemed very happy to be back and say
again is that true
yes i'm very happy to to be here
for me it's it's like a my best
moments in inches career
is to face
strongest grandmasters and
before that
many tournaments were not played and now
i'm here and i hope everything will go
well and
i hope to
to play and to get some experience
before they can do this and and
basically uh
even without candidates
it's very nice to play here thank you
good to hear from sergey karyakin who is
happy to be back here
in vaikanzi we still have a few games
going on we've had three draws already
one between magnus carlsen and nazipanko
between sergey and fabiano and we've
just had a result let's quickly go there
on the camera
report has resigned his game against the
anchor of duda who becomes the first
player to win a game in this tata steel
masters 2022
robert so much happening today
yeah it's been a really exciting day we
see the players talking about their game
they both have tremendous amount of
respect for one another and duda has the
lead the world cup champion the vice
champion at the world blitz that was
recently held he is just in phenomenal
form fiona and i think that some people
they've thought well duda he's been
27.50 for a little while now 27.60 like
is that is that it and that's already a
tremendous accomplishment but he is
showing that he's still improving he's
so young he's exceptionally hard-working
and talented and it is good to see him
win these games even if you are a report
fan because rapport is
awesome to watch as well it's good to
see duda continuing his climb
absolutely i mean he said to me
yesterday in an interview you know 2021
for sure was his best year but he didn't
have such a great event here in vaikanse
so he's looking to improve
on that this year and for sure he will
be looking to get his confidence up
before the candidates tournament which
is coming on later this year which will
be
at the main event of the year for the
eight players who are looking to become
the next challenger to
magnus carlsen and robert i think we're
going to take a quick break now
and we will be back in just a few
minutes with all the remaining action
here from round one
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to this first round of the
tata seal just tournament 20
20
and robert three games
remain one of them is this game we're
looking at between jordan van priest and
niels grandelius we've had one decisive
result so far uh yankrishov buddha
winning his game against richard reports
and it looks like jordan is about uh to
follow duda into the lead
on one out of one
yeah jordan playing a very good game
neil's stuck with a tough opponent he
finished off the 2021 tattoo sale event
by losing to jordan von forest and he's
going to begin 2022 in a similar way so
you know we want
more
good for niels grandilius and less of
the old more of the new and the new
needs to be a different result against
jordan just tough opponent for him
yeah
hopefully nils who actually had a great
start to the event
last year then things didn't go his way
so much
in the the second half and we see
needles there just
coming back
to the board but maybe we can bring up
the the big board uh with that b pawn
that is running only two squares away
from
from queening
and it's hard to see how how those pawns
can be stopped
and black has nothing going for him not
even a past pawn if your rook and bishop
are tied down to stopping the past pawns
on the queen side white can also make a
pass pawn on the king side the knight is
about to venture over to b3 at some
point a5 can be played that's two clear
extra pawns for white and they're not
going to be stopped
absolutely so this one looks
pretty over
and then one of the questions is can uh
vidit join the leaders as well he seems
to have played a really nice game
against sam shankland
who is
pretty tied down
in the the last position
uh we saw uh i don't know if you want to
go there or we could stick with jordan
okay i brought it up but we can jordan's
game is going to finish very shortly i
believe but we can uh have
uh jordan on screen maybe the game will
end
you know moves but i also brought up the
video game against shanghai which is
so promising for vidit
yeah so what has been it since we left
off he has brought his king to e3
and this black king is up on f5 there's
a pawn on g5 here
i
don't know what black's next move is
because knight e6 rook f7 checkmate i
mean that's
uh the point is that the king needs this
retreating square so the knight still
cannot move fiona even though you would
like to play this move yeah i would love
it
so can i just like king f3 and just say
what
you're up
what's your choice
i guess i didn't love my move but it
still says it's uh sufficient for a
large advantage just to show up in 96
work f7 is mate
yeah it's
tough tough tough to find moves for even
waiting moves are getting harder and
harder to to find for for black
hey what if
what if i try and activate my rook
okay so oh i guess so let's get king f3
and you play rook
where c uh let's see it is a work b7
coming at some point
like check first oh and uh
sorry robert you were absolutely correct
that the jordan went for race game was
gonna end shortly and niels has resigned
so jordan
continuing where he left off last year
with a victory
against niels grandelus and what a
fantastic start to the tournament for
him uh with a quite a
tipsy turvy game here between the two
yeah it was certainly not an easy win
but jordan did gain the advantage after
niels played b5 earlier in the game so
niels went aggressive jordan was able to
parry off many of the threats and he
secured an advantage and the victory so
good on him i think a lot of fans will
be happy to see him compete and it looks
like anish giri's game has come to a
conclusion against prague
the players are talking and that one was
a little bit less exciting than the
jordan van forest game but a draw is
held by pragnanda and his fans
and the country of india should be
thrilled because pragmata holds with the
black pieces against his much higher
rate opponent and vidit is
maybe on the cusp of victory so a great
start for
the players from india absolutely i just
wanted to get back to
jxx in the chat was asking what about an
interview with duda that did happen
while we were on break so we will show
you that just a little bit
uh later and for now this has all
happened so fast leaving us only with
the visit
against sam shankland uh game in the
masters
let's remind everyone we also have a
challengers group here in vaikansei but
uh for our coverage we will focus mostly
under 14 players in the masters
indeed and we just have this one game
left so we have no choice but to stay
present in this one and hey wait was
that my analysis or was king of no it's
my analysis king f3 i was like okay he
played my move but f3 king f3 just a
waiting move
and i really don't know what black's
gonna do here
so what do you want to do king f3 rf3
let's just play f3
okay so what will happen if i try and
activate my rook rook c8
rook
c8
so i'm wondering if i can pin your
knight and try to just
go this way
um that's one possibility i can also
move my rook so you don't have a threat
because rook c3 rook takes b3 i win your
night on that fate so it's like even
when you
attack something you make a threat it's
not really a threat but i've got to do
something robert
i i don't disagree it just feels like
something may still be nothing in the
end
oh it's so depressing
oh gosh yeah i don't mean to
you know be so pessimistic about the
position but okay but still you haven't
shown me
how you're gonna beat me so let me make
my move rook ruxia
i'm not gonna go and take your b3 pawn
i'm just gonna
oh wait no you did sure yeah um and
and if i go back to b8
so you kind of have knight d7 don't you
uh just as hard
why am i it feels like i should just be
winning in a million ways but i'm not so
maybe
what's black's next move i'm still
trying to figure that out as well like
let's say if i play king f2
oh you're just waiting you're just going
to see me can i do
you've already shown that i can't do
anything so i've resigned myself to my
fate
and if i go rook b7 you still can't play
knight e6
because um let's check me on f7
and now your pawn's hanging
yeah this looks
this looks no fun
okay so i can't leave v8
but you also can't stay on pa either oh
my goodness it's like the most
upsetting position ever like all right
f3
as soon as you leave v8 i can play rook
b7 i can start with it
okay so what can i do
do i just actually have no move
um you don't really have many that's for
sure
okay but what about b5 noun
you can still take it home i can just
say yeah
this is not a fun why don't we turn
roles around and you try and defend us
as
i'll try to defend it so okay you're
going to play white what's your first
movie
a wise man suggested f3 so
okay
i really don't have moves here
um
to be honest like what i'm curious about
is why does the engine not give a bigger
advantage
that's a that is a great question i was
wondering the same thing it's like uh
is it
me just assuming that it's winning
because it should be winning
and actually black can just be passive
and hold or what is the reason
for this here so like let's say we play
i guess ruxia right
what was i doing
inside
yeah
i can make any moves
i'm also wondering about rook g8 like
just the pin you said rook ba here
can i make a move like knight g6
i obviously can't play knight d7 because
you take and defend
and knight d7 does
does feel like
an actual good idea for you
so
okay so i'm going to stick to my
original plan i'll play king f2
and just ask you what's up no i thought
i was asking you oh yeah sorry sorry um
you you are asking me you're right
maybe i'll just keep sick i'm tired of
sitting and waiting i don't know what
else to do okay
so what if i
go rook b7 then
i oh and we have an interview so we'll
come back to this we have an interview
with jordan so let's go there
uh jordan congratulations uh you picked
up the way you left last year it seems
yeah i i'm definitely happy with with
the result
but the game myself was probably rather
shaky
i missed a lot of things
but it helped that i think i got a good
position out of the opening so i was
never worse i think
and
what did you consider his mistake or
decisive mistake yeah i'm not exactly i
think i made a lot of mistakes but um if
you're talking about my mistakes his
mistakes i i'm not also not exactly sure
what was the decisive mistake but it was
quite strange that he took on uh e3 with
the bishop immediately instead of just
rook takes b2
um that gave me
well basically an extra tempe and
i always had a lot of extra pawns and
finally only one extra pawn remained but
it was good enough to win the game i
guess
so a great start is it realistic to
expect a similar result as last year
no it's of course not realistic
but i'm happy with it
with the first game the result at least
but
it's 12 more rounds i mean it's just
we cannot draw any conclusions from this
game i always checked
the bookies
last year
they paid like 800 to one for you
and now that dropped to 30 to one is
that a good bet it's probably not a very
good bet no
but
yeah i wouldn't put your money on
me okay thank you okay thank you
you're then being very humble there but
i i think
you know he still fancies he of course
he's not ever gonna say it but he's off
to a great start and i think he will
certainly be looking to defend his title
here at the tata steel tournament he's
off to a winning start as is jan
christoph
duda and i think robert we're also
immediately going to listen to duda's
interview which took place
just a
short while ago while we were on a break
so let's hear what dude i had to say
after his win over report
[Music]
christoph congratulations
today
was it a difficult position with
long-term compensation for you
yes the game was very interesting indeed
um i'm i'm not sure about what i have
done to be honest like um i mean this
the whole sequence with rook d185 i just
believed it to be very interesting but
probably not that great for me i mean
black should be fine with
precise play
um
yeah but somehow you know i was very
tempted to play this 95 stuff and
of course the idea was to play against
the night squad bishop um
on g6 so
yeah and i temporarily sacrificed the
pawn
um
yeah i think that actually playing this
rook d7 i mean i was a bit annoyed on
myself when i played rook d7 because um
i forgot about the a5a4 but then
i mean rookie 7 followed by rook hd1 i
think made perfect sense and i was just
aiming to get the positional
grip i managed to get actually later in
the game
uh yeah and once i mean
he didn't do anything concrete i think
his position was um
maybe even lost positionally i mean
um
okay once after i free buffy i didn't
see anything for him to be honest like
perhaps earlier also he could have
played f5 at one moment
that was um
very double edged and i
actually expected him to play like this
because
yeah richard rapport is known from
such aggressive play but
yeah somehow in general in i played the
london because i was hoping you know to
get a very slow and very boring position
and just um
and just you know we stand
we send this stuff but yeah somehow the
game was quite interesting well and
especially in the middle game and in the
end and in the end his position
collapsed
with what ambition did you came come to
waikiki this year
yeah of course i'm very happy to play
here i am as always i don't expect that
much um i mean
obviously in this year candidates will
be like
like everything for me and here i think
it's just
a perfect way to i mean to have practice
against very strong compositions
so he's very strong players so that's my
main goal just to play um some decent
choice here
and um
yeah and actually you know it's it seems
to be going uh pretty well right now i
mean i
i probably haven't been in such a
situation before i mean in previous
editions so winning in the first round
you've been yeah yeah exactly
so
yeah but also you know
for the first time i'm not number 13 but
number six so that counts for something
i guess
okay good luck thank you
always nice to hear from duda who of
course confirming what we were
suspecting the candidate's tournament is
the main focus
of the year but if on route to that he
can win tata steels he's certainly not
gonna turn down that opportunity robert
i was also just looking at the live
waiting list i don't think that's so
much on the player's mind but with his
win today duda is back i think he's back
he must have been in the top ten so
currently number 10 in the world with
his win today overtaking
vashila grav rishuk and richard report
i think this is actually duda's highest
ever ranking it might be his highest
rating highest ranking so i'm sure he's
thrilled about that but yes his honest
response
was great to hear it for him the
candidates that's everything and he does
have a realistic chance to win i would
not say he's a favorite but of course he
does have a chance he's an exceptional
player and i mean look at sam shanklin's
face fiona
that is a man who is not happy with his
position yeah this is a man who is
suffering
on the chessboard he's been suffering
for a long time today he is still
fighting
uh vidit didn't play f3 instead he
played king f3 but the questions are the
same for sam how do we
how do we defend this position how can
we find a useful move how can we
untangle
and uh the problem is there might just
not be any answers
if you know an important question to ask
is if
a side passes what is the opponent going
to do and so right now let's say black
were to pass the move and we can do that
by playing say rook c8 i think white's
plan is actually quite simple let's say
you play rook c8 rook f7 check
king e6
king g4 now the king is just going to
win this pawn the rook cannot leave the
eighth rank because the knight is lost
and if you play knight to g6 i play king
g5
knight takes e5 and very importantly you
don't just take back the 95 because your
rook is lost but rook f6 check the king
has to step back to either e or d7 i
don't think it really matters and white
is completely winning one pawn on e5 a
second pawn running up and joining and
the b6 pawn is weak the rook can stop on
d6 to try to pick up d5 this is
a hundred percent over in white's favor
so
there's a clear plan a clear path to
victory for vidit and so if rook f7 king
g4 is just going to be decisive i really
don't know what sam is to do here to
even have the smallest of chances
yeah i mean it could also
like i think it's not unlikely that this
game here is over
quite
uh soon and that sam decides he has seen
enough like i just don't know what we
can do against this plan that
that you just
showed and although
the engine has jumped a little bit
but it might even be higher than than
2.7 at this point anyway it's just
numbers
um
but we also see from sam's
uh body language it's almost like it's
we almost past that phase you know where
it's
uh had
enhanced deep focus now it's more like
realization is that too
too horrible
no i i think it's uh correct
and one of the things about sam shanklin
is he's known for his
amazing preparation and in this game he
was slightly worse from the start he did
have the black pieces so it makes sense
uh and then in the end game it seemed
like he was on the verge of neutralizing
fitted edge and then he played this move
f6 in a tough position so the position
was never completely equal never easy to
figure out but then it sort of fell
apart at the seams very quickly and for
a player like sam who is quite emotional
and he gives amazing interviews
especially after he wins games but i
think he can be emotional and losing a
game like this to start the tournament
that's not what you want if you're sam
shanklin or a fan of his and on the
other side of things vidit
you know he's shown that he can be a
force he's hasn't
gained rating points in a while like i
feel like he's been in this 27 20 zone
for a while and if he can win this game
start going over 27 30 maybe have a
great event
we could see vidit eventually overtake
vishyanan for number one in india and
vichy doesn't really play very much
anymore it seems like he's uh inactive
not retired but he is not playing very
much at this point although he did play
in the extreme memorial right in the
rapid blitz event and he doesn't seem
like he's playing much classical let's
put it that way so for vidit i mean now
is the time to really start making his
moves try to become the number one
player in india and not just that go
beyond and try to really punch up
towards the candidates towards the top
players in the world
yeah absolutely and speaking of with it
we see him there on the camera
uh we we're familiar with the head bob
but this is the
the
the next step the body bob
he's dancing he is dancing
um
yeah you know it's like when you go to
one of those parties and someone like
wants to dance and doesn't want to sit
in the corner but doesn't really know
what to do so they just start shaking a
little bit so there he is and we can see
it from the distance now
this is me dancing at a party
when i'm sober
oh did it he's a a great guy a friend of
mine and uh you know i am happy to see
him succeed it's been a while since he's
been able to play in a classical event
he was not able to play in the
uh grand swiss in riga latvia and he
will be playing in the grand prix to try
to earn a spot in the kitten it's uh six
of the eight places decided he will
fight for the final two so it's uh good
to see him in good form uh but sam
shanklin it's early in the tournament
even if he does lose his game obviously
has time to rebound absolutely robert i
think we're not going anywhere the
players will be here for a little while
longer so we're going to go on a short
break and then we will be back with the
end of the first round here from vikanze
so we'll see you very soon
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the final part of this
first round here at the tata steel just
tournament 2022
robert welcome back
and uh interestingly enough in the game
i was gonna ask you this one question
someone in the chat had asked us and
then i didn't get around to it but
someone in the chat had asked
is g4 followed by knight e6 an option
and that's exactly what sam went for
it is an option it was probably the only
one and now vidit is back of the board
and thinking because black was stuck
there were no really good ideas to play
so finally sam was able to bring his
knight out from f8 to e6 it attacks the
rook on g7 attacks the pawn on d4 and
that looks like a double attack that you
can't deal with but i do think that
knight e3 check the king has to go back
to f6 only legal move and then rook to
g4
retreating this should still be
sufficient for a huge advantage for
white the d5 pawn is now under attack
white is up in f-pawn here and so the
game will continue and sam will try to
hold on as best he can but you're just
down a pawn and it's a pretty clean pawn
at that that can start pushing up the
board once the king moves out the way so
i don't
like the look of this i don't think that
black has real real at least not very
high drawing jet sets yeah this looks
convincing uh enough if we go back to
knight e6 could we even
would there even be more is this the
best
we can get what is work f7
oh are you trying to check me
you can you can't go to g6 because of
rook f6 jack
i think once again only move king g5
king g3 is like super close to checkmate
but if you go for this then i think then
i can take on d4 and vinit has just gone
for the line you suggested uh and
defended his pawn with rook g4
and he now well sam has managed to
untangle but at the cost of a price
at the cost of a price
yeah it's a pretty important pawn and
it's a situation because
here it's rook knight four pawns for
white rook knight three pawns from black
and
end games with knights on the board are
most similar typically to king and pawn
end games so being down a pawn is a huge
problem in this position if you trade
knights and now we're in a rook end game
where you're down the pawn then black
suddenly would have some decent chances
to hold in this particular position but
white's knight isn't going anywhere it's
uh right here on e3 already attacking
this pawn and i think black is kind of
forced to either play knight c7 which
looks really bad because you're
retreating again or make this move rook
to d8 which still doesn't look great
because you're resorting to passive
defense and there's no real way to get
active
and i'm curious what will the next white
steps be are we going to keep the king
on the king side or is the king going to
go around
the other side do we activate rook i
guess i like
this idea of bringing the king to d3 so
that the king can take over the defense
of the pawn
uh on d4 and that way the the rook is
free
it's just
before black couldn't move now black
still can barely move but has a little
bit more room and what we're looking at
is here what's black's move knight g5 i
guess is possible but you might just run
into a rook f4 rook f5 type of stuff
f4 f5 is an option the king can always
come to d3 you can't play knight e4
regardless because knight takes d5
removes the guard so
i i see
single moves for black along the way i
just don't really see a plan of note
yeah it's uh
it's not been a fun game
um
like i feel like i'm repeating myself
but simon's fighting valiantly he's
trying to put up maximum resistance and
i think we can only command him
for that like
um who said nobody's ever won a game by
resigning
i don't know who was first to say it i
should but i don't
but we do know that sam and i don't
really want to
you know
pile on to a situation where he's
already unhappy but he resigned that
famous scam against anish kyrie in what
was a drawn position and i was
commenting on that game um and it's just
you know remember just
can't do that and he's of course laughed
it off and he's had success since then
but he knows better than to resign too
early and this is not a resignable
position but it will be if vivid is able
to continue precisely i mean seriously
black just doesn't have ideas here
yeah it's a tough one it's it's a funny
memory that once sam mentioned it
himself in the interview he's had many
incredible moments here this one
resigning the the drawn position
against uh anish beating kramnik in his
last classical competitive
game
i liked that in the chat master chest
dodgers saying tartakover said most of
those things yeah it could be
what would i say did i say command
instead of
a man did i say we can only command him
i don't know if they're talking about
asking for a command or what i think i
think they are right i did say we can
only command him when i men commend
english is difficult
i i also just don't read chat so i think
this is one of those things where
i'm not going to say i'm right but i'm
not going to complain about my uh
procedure while i
commentate
what's there not to like about chat
robert oh wow um
[Music]
where to start
yeah so about that we're gonna have to
have a conversation you and i
chat
um yeah can we get me off the big campus
oh it's such a sad story of unrequited
love
yeah it's just it's never gonna happen
and the people modern day tragedy
i i think they appreciate my honesty
though you know it's like someone has to
tell them the truth
meanwhile well meanwhile actually is
trying to get active
he has just pushed
uh b5 which somehow the move i didn't
have it on my radar anymore but now it
is of course possible with the night
having gotten out
i actually kind of like it like it's an
at least put some pressure on vid who is
going to take a pawn in the center he
did for free with check the king drops
back to
f7 and what sam's idea is to trade on a4
and bring his rook into the game so he's
giving up material
in exchange for activity but i think
that white can even play them with king
e4
right now
and then even use the king as
an aggressive piece to eventually go up
to e5 to push the f pawn up the board
maybe f4 in the near future as well so i
just
think that even though it's a good
effort by shanklin i don't think it's
enough
yeah and with it very likely to join uh
jordan van fereced and jan kristof duda
in the lead
i think is it tomorrow that we already
have another
of course every day there are going to
be big clashes in this tournament but uh
tomorrow i think there's one in
particular that we can look forward to
it's magnus carlsen we'll be playing
white against aneesh
giri wow i think that everybody except
for anish is looking forward to that
game um of course we
respect both players so much and magnus
carlsen the strongest player on the
planet and he's probably not thrilled
about how today went because when he
finds out that he had d4 and didn't play
it against yesopanko he's going to be
kicking himself but a missed opportunity
in a niche he had the white pieces
against the lowest rated player in the
field and he didn't really ever
get anything it looked like he could
have the initiative but then pragnanda
played very good defense so for a niche
that's a spoiled opportunity with the
white pieces against a player that if
you're gonna beat anyone in the field
that's a player you're gonna try to beat
pragnanda he's young his rating may not
have caught up to his strength
especially during the pandemic with
fewer over the board tournaments but
pragnanda he is
a fantastic player in his own right
there was also a funny little story
there was some trolling going on and
there we see the pairings uh for
tomorrow with at the top magnus carson
taking on anish giri
uh vinit has another tough game to look
forward to
after today but he's starting with a
double white which is always nice he'll
be playing uh fabiano
and jordan uh one of our early leaders
he's i think you're always happy in
general playing someone who just lost i
think it you have a small
a small edge but he will be playing with
the black pieces and duda might be
looking to strike again against the
the bottom seed of the tournament
pragnanda i
i knew exactly what you're doing just
like earlier when you asked me that
question at the start of the show and i
was delaying about my predictions
i see what i'm going to have to announce
that sergey karjatkin is playing his
best friend daniel dubois and we know
the backstory during the world
championship when dubov was working with
magnus carlson and karjakin had some
choice words for him about how uh you
know he's magnus playing a russian
player you should be supporting yan and
um
dubois disagreed especially considering
he has worked with magnus in the past as
well so i don't know if that's going to
be chess boxing if it's just going to be
chess
they don't do handshakes here for um you
know health
reasons but i don't think they'd be
shaking hands anyway so uh we'll see how
that game goes yeah actually
i can't believe i hadn't seen that there
because all the time in the run-up to
the tournament i was thinking i'm
curious how that's gonna go
and then i literally just didn't see it
there and so yeah that would be for sure
an interesting uh an interesting
match-up
uh i was just going to tell the quick
story about the trolling that took place
yesterday at the opening ceremony so
at the drawing of lots i asked every
player a couple of questions and one
question that we asked to each player
with the same question was
whether they have a favorite game here
that was played in vaikunzi
and
guess what magnus said
what was his favorite game doesn't
necessarily have to be a game of their
own uh his favorite game played here in
vikenzi
magnus's favorite game yeah
i don't know there's so many good ones
what was it well it was a troll answer
so
a troll answer so that means he was
trolling his best friend danish
so he said his favorite game
that's ever been played here was the the
armageddon game last year against jordan
that's that's brutal that is
oh gosh
denise cry
he has back the tears
but it was he even and you know how
magnus is in these spots huge times he
was like actually let me think if
there's something no that's just that's
just my favorite
yeah it's kind of funny because anish is
like the ultimate troll on twitter but
in a positive way and magnus is that in
real life like when he gets these
interview questions he's so good at
cracking a joke and you know sort of
reading the room and of course anish and
magnus they trade barbs all the time but
it's friendly uh they get along very
well so
dang that is that was a good one for a
niche but also poor sam shanklin because
the king did just go to e4 and that's
where the king will end once they mark
the results you know kings on e4 and d5
when white wins and
yeah this is not looking very nice for
sam he's just down two pawns the pawns
are gonna start rolling up the board
here and
i don't really see a way that he can
even so what do we do if some if some
goes rook b4
do we just bring the king forward or
there's the knight well oh oh
it's okay i thought a bishop was pinned
earlier and there was no rook on f1 so i
get it
i thought okay let me at least attack
maybe take the a4 pawn
no i get nothing
no you
no soup for you so
i think you have to play rook b2 and go
after the f pawn but that does invite
the pawn forward maybe even can go one
square but i don't see why you can't go
two
the one thing though is you can't be
careless if you're white you can't just
like start pushing your f pawn and i'm
just gonna win whatever you do need to
calculate and that's why avidit will
spend time ensuring that he secures the
full but you do not want to waste this
opportunity
absolutely not no and i mean he is right
to use uh to not rush here of course he
knows he is winning but i think he
despite his young age he is experienced
enough to know there is no need to rush
here he still has 27 minutes
on the clock and in 10 moves he will get
an extra 15 minutes so really
plenty of time to
[Music]
to convert
this
to to pawn
advantage and now it's just a matter of
what to do about this pawn here
i want to play f4 i don't see why i
couldn't play that f3
being a little slower
but
perhaps make it harder
so king
d3
you have to go to d3 i guess yeah
yeah that was my only trick i thought
maybe robert's going to step onto f3 or
f5
uh maybe he'll blow under the d4 pawn in
one turn
so let's see what the f3 was played i
actually do like that more because it
leaves the rook defending the pawn on uh
d4 so that does allow the king to go to
f5 without dropping a pawn if the rook
was e2 would check and
a more advanced king is usually a good
thing in an end game like this
we miss something i i i see that uh
blunder panda in the chat is saying
that f4 is a draw for i i don't think
did we miss anything after f4
may rook d2
oh
also it's not a draw offer it's just a
mistake there's two very different
things you know how i feel about draw
we've just talked about this before
there's i'm sure there's a clip out
there
robert i know your feelings about chat i
didn't read the comment out as it was
written because it said wrong and for
the draw for what are you smoking
well i thought i'd spare you that
now i have to respond what am i smoking
i've been on camera for the last five
hours you know the answer is nothing
and people are just being wise with
their engines telling them what the move
is response
all right give it a rest
people are just this is why i don't read
chat i mean this is just a clear example
of
why it doesn't happen
bruh
oh
gosh
i love those end of day
the end of the day when we break you
robert
yeah you get weak in the last hour
just
bringing out the the internal rage
anyway
anyway meanwhile sam has played rook uh
b3
okay so what does that
do
so what's the threat like because he
could have won rook eighth or rook a2
before to attack the pawn a4 so i don't
think he's that focused on also in a way
it's not like i my feeling is it's kind
of nice to cut off the king at least it
feels like the white king
could get into some kind of net
if it cannot go backwards but um
i don't
i don't see a concrete threat right
no i don't see anything um
i i want to bring my rook to h4 so i can
go rook h7 check
i want to activate my rook
so that move is coming to mind
i also want to checkmate the black king
so if i can force your king to the last
rank and get my king to e5 for example
or to f5 i'd be happy about that but i
think sam is trying to line up rook a3
and just keep his rook as active as
possible and keep white's pieces tied
down
robert we uh we're gonna take just a two
second
uh break to to look at a clip from
earlier today with grandmaster has in
the in the star roll
salvage a half point to make sure that
they have no risk but
draw offers are so bad
we've been uh we've been treated of a
really really exciting finale here
am
devastated
robert
that draw offer
i already made my feelings known i like
to express myself it's important to
express your emotions and feelings for
those who don't
well i don't know you know hopefully
there are people in your lives friends
that you can talk to but never looked at
it that way as a broadcast as some kind
of therapy for us
i usually don't think about it that way
but after you know dealing with chat
sometimes you just
you know it just is necessary so um
anyway the draw for i you know on a
serious note i'm not a fan i think it
really deprives people of entertainment
and it also just adds a lot of question
marks where
wait why did that game end in no sport
can you really just say let's call it a
day and leave draws happen i have
nothing against the results but the way
it happens is important
i agree with you i am i think we've both
said we understand why the draw was
offered why it was accepted
but i think especially in the moment
when nobody is expecting a handshake i
think there's also
this confusion
when we see the handshake of what just
happened did it someone who's on time
did he resign what's going on because i
think we just
don't expect at you know the culmination
of the game as so exciting and suddenly
it's just over as you say it is very
hard to to explain that to to trust fans
as well when even we don't really
understand it but it is it is what it is
um i'm sure we'll see plenty more
fighting just from these two players
throughout throughout the tournament
and yeah for now we're still waiting on
a village
you were talking about you wanting to
checkmate the black king
yes and i also
made a draw offer allegedly or just a
blunder before by suggesting f4 and i
was triple checking just now can i play
f4 or am i blundering my d4 pawn the
answer is no so there's no rook d3
there's no rook b4 so i think f4 also is
a reasonable choice at this
what
what's with this evolv bar
how could f4 possibly be that bad of a
move
oh my gosh it's gonna go back up
so i tell myself it's gonna continue
rising oh no i went back down
let's figure out then why or do you
think it's gonna rise
but it says there's like some winning
move here this just
i wanted to play rook h4 first
could it be king e5
but king e5 this rook takes f3
sorry now the workers did not
before no i thought i didn't check on h7
i think this bar is lying to itself and
thus lying to all of us so speaking of
needing therapy this eval bar needs
therapy the game will continue vidit
will continue thinking
i think uh we gotta go on break i
don't even know
we can do that
oh
are we gone and i think we're still here
but we will be gone in a second
i think robert
robert needs to cool down we're all
gonna take a
breather we'll calm down collect our
thoughts and we'll be back with uh
the the finale of the sun game between
vidit and shankland so don't go anywhere
we will be right back
nakamura is playing for the win even
though his opponent has a pawn one step
away from becoming a new queen it's
sensational the amount of risks hikaru
is taking here it seems like black is
making some progress finally and well he
just made the decision to trade off
everything he did get a draw but that
could very easily have been a win it
looks like it should be winning for bb
sarah i mean black only has that one
queen in the attack and white has an
extra piece of lots of pawns i think
we're going to see a little bit of an
upset in this game and music ends up
losing on time and assoba yeva confirms
her excellent form by winning that
matchup this is incredible bartos
sachiko is up a piece against magnus
carlsen sachiko playing in his native
poland has a winning position and magnus
resigns sachiko is on a perfect score
having defeated the reigning world
champion the lead just keeps changing
but soba eva has already been in the
lead and now she's going to get it back
i mean because this game is about to be
over and shubalova has to resign in the
end she was five pawns down there's no
hope saving that we got cinderella and
fedo save is actually the battle of the
leaders on seven points out of eight
there's a pawn end game now only pawns
remaining and cinderella is going for
the win cinderella is going for the win
try to say it brushes his king back into
defense and the guys agreed to a draw oh
my gosh and both of these players remain
in the lead
a run-in with an extra pawn in the brook
end game and fedo say if he's unable to
do anything about the white pawns in
conjunction with the white king just
making their way up the board it's over
levana brunion taking the lead in the
tournament
of ronan rushing his king over to the
left-hand side trying to get rid of
black stroke the king is now coming to
the aid of the pawn that's only two
squares away from becoming a new queen
and of running is making very good
progress here and anish giri resigns the
game lavon aronian 13 points fantastic
results he's playing so confidently
hikaru nakamura is not on the list he
tested positive for kovid and had to
withdraw from the tournament bb sarah
has a one and a half point lead she's
gonna win it if she wins this one and
look at this bb sarah with her queen can
go for the queen trade if the queens are
traded she's gonna win this game and she
does go for it the queens are traded off
the board the bishop coming in against
the white king to give a check and
koryakin of recites a sophaeva is the
world champion
a lot of credit to our women's world
blitz champion the young player from
kazakhstan making her name known to the
whole world maxim making his
calculations can he stop that black pawn
in time and he thinks he can do that
after lots of captures it's iranian
who's down by a pawn but a runner's king
is unable to assist against the white
king making its way forward and iranian
now will resign the game and what a
stunning turn around there he made a
couple of mistakes and the frenchman
capitalizes on that dubois trying to get
his pieces pointing in towards black's
king but olivereza has a pawn one step
away from becoming a new queen and he
has made a queen and he knows that he
can always stack that queen for the
bishop and that is the end of the game
and we're almost certainly guaranteed a
tie for first place after the final game
he's using his queen to help out that
pawn is moving forward and aronian now
he's gonna have to resign the pawn is
becoming a new queen of runyon does keep
on playing but there's no hope he
resigns the game was that the
championship for aligraza for rurja
actually it's definitely not the
championship because ian christoph duda
has managed to win his game so there
will be a tie the question is whether or
not maxim bashir lagrave will be able to
join them and mashiach
has beaten magnus carlsen john
christophe duda and maxim bashir gagrav
will be playing for the gold medal
it's less than 30 seconds on the clock
for duda who needs to figure out this
end game and he chooses to push his pawn
forward exactly he chose to protect it
with this rook before not going in for
that trade where he might lose a pawn
yeah the pawns are just getting
exchanged off and the guys agreed to a
draw the handshake there a solid game
from duda duda is actually giving away
his bishop a strange decision from the
polish player there he chooses to move
the one knight losing the other i'm not
thrilled about where white took this
position because certainly he's not
better at all in this end game duda is
going to have to play for a draw yeah
certainly i don't see any danger at all
black they just agreed to a draw now to
find the victor of this tournament we're
going to play one game at a time and if
someone wins that is the world champion
maxim bashar ngagrav now in the end game
judah trying to use his king to stop
white's king from getting into the game
but here with simba shiela crab is able
to capture another pawn on the side of
the board two extra points for him now
dude of recites mcsimba shiela grab the
world champion in
2021 and here we see a maxim basher
being congratulated he is the world
blitz champion
tata steel is not the only big important
classical chess term of the year no in
fact the fide grand prix starts at the
beginning of february where 24 the top
players in the world will start their
fight for qualifications of the 2022
candidates and you will not want to miss
dingley ren anishigiri hikaru nakamura
vida gujarati and many others battle for
the right to play magnus carlson the
grand prix returns february 3rd with
coverage here on chess.com
certainly a very exciting event to look
forward to as you mentioned vidit who we
see there at the back of the empty
playing hall
all other six matches have finished
he will be uh going to berlin unless he
skips the first one which i'm not sure
but straight after vike a very short
break for the players who are playing
vike as well as the first leg of the
grand prix and here we see the results
uh so far today two games ended
decisively do that beating report and
van forest
uh beating grendelius
yeah so far just a few decisive games
but vita guzrati trying to make it three
and right now he has a great chance to
do just that sam shanklin is digging in
trying to
hold this game where he is down two
pawns but with limited material
remaining so we'll see what vidit
chooses he has several good options we
mentioned pawn to f4 we mentioned rook
to h4 there's also knight e3 trying to
reposition the knight and play d4 to d5
to start advancing the past pawn so if
it is even thought though he does not
want to mess this one up yeah he's gone
deep into thought here after uh sam's
move rook b3 but sometimes this is a
tough spot when you have so many
tempting moves
uh and you just have to to pick
uh
to pick which way you want to go
yes and
i like f4 just to play f5 maybe even
eventually throw an f6 but it's
advancing the the pawn in the end game
and it also makes the black king feel
uncomfortable because that king is on
the seventh rank if i can give it a
check i might force the back rank and
then i would love to start a mating net
so i just
but that's the issue fiona is when you
have too many options and right now
there are
three at minimum good looking moves for
white you start burning a lot of clock
and we already moved 51 he needs to get
to move 60 to gain the
time at the third time patrol uh but
right now vidit he's uncertain about how
to continue yeah he's really i mean i it
feels like just a couple of minutes ago
that i was saying vidit has plenty of
time he had 27 minutes uh on the clock
but only a couple of moves have uh have
passed
since that moment um
so yeah with it just making
sure or or choosing which of the which
of the lines he wants to go with i like
your suggestion uh suggestion of pushing
that f-pawn because
uh because why not and not like this
the the thinking pose is uh back
but he will have to make up his mind
soon um
get to move 60
and then i mean it's such a long time
control let's remind everyone maybe we
can talk about the time control one
final time for to today so the time
control the longest on the circuit
hundred minutes for the first 40 moves
then another 50 minutes for the next 20
and even after move 60 there's still a
15 uh extra minutes all of that uh also
withered a 30 second increment from
move one which in general i feel is very
nice though robert i don't know if you
would agree but i feel that it gives the
players a bit more time and um
i think it's very often reflected in the
quality of especially the end games
yeah i think one rule in the format that
would make it better as no draw offers
but besides that uh the classical tie
patrol the
really long games but it allows the
players to
maximize their strengths right if they
have a good position they have time to
calculate through if they're in time
trouble heading towards move 40 or 60
they can
build on the clock and of course the
increment always allows them to regain
some time by making quick moves so this
event has been around for a very long
time it's uh the 84th edition i believe
and it was moved to vike in 1968
and of course sponsored by tata steel
since 2011 so it's uh just a fantastic
event it's called the wimbledon of chess
and it does not disappoint ever
yeah and well today magnus who is
has announced recently his next big goal
is to get a
2900 classical rating today he was held
to a draw uh by jesse panko but magnus
in this tournament i mean magnus has
played here 17 times before it's
actually magnus's 18th appearance here
in vikenzi and he's
of course in so many appearances had all
kind of results but sometimes
i remember he was quite slow to start
was it a year or two ago
where he made like five or six draws to
start and then he he won a string of
games
so uh we'll see magnus he was in high
spirits today at the end of the game
and of course one of the main intrigues
is always how is magnus going to be
doing of course there's the intrigue of
will jordan will uh will he be able to
defend his title so
uh a lot of things to be following here
during this event
and you said the name jordan and it made
me remember that magnus started with a
string of draws and then he beat jordan
von forrest i want to say that was 2019
and he ended up winning a bunch of games
after that maybe like four in a row
but it allowed him to go on a tear so
sometimes magnus just needs that first
taste of victory and then he's the
unstoppable force that we all know about
but other times he can uh
be stressed out and frustrated by his
level of play relative to his peak and
it's not good for his overall tournament
i'd say when he is feeling like he's not
playing his best chess it really
frustrates him yeah and i i believe last
year was probably one of the years where
he had
one of his worst showings here i think
he ended up if i'm not mistaken in sixth
place which is quite uh uncharacteristic
but this year i'm sure
magnus will be eager well i'm not saying
he wasn't eager
last year but i think especially after
the world rapid and blitz where
uh he didn't manage to to win a gold
medal in night event i think he'll be
especially eager to win the status deal
indeed and we just saw shanklin play
rook to a3 hitting the pawn in a4 so a
big question for vidid is do you ignore
this pawn on a4 or do you protect it
because he can just play knight to b6
right now which defends the pawn in a4
and after knight b6 maybe this knight
will reroute to c4 at some moment just
trying to attack a5 get towards the
center and the d and f pawns both can
start running up the board so it's a big
choice for
vidit and
let's see he's thinking yeah it looked
like he was about to to make a move and
then
thunk
flank back
into reconsidering things for a minute
i wonder how nervous he is right now
it's a big moment for him you know
starting the tournament off
with a victory
would be big and looks like he played
knight to b6
if i'm not mistaken he has only played
in the masters group once
so he i think he won the the challengers
in 2018
and played the masters
i guess in 2019 and i think the one time
he played the masters he did very well
so
i'm sure he'll be looking not only to
repeat that performance but even improve
on it especially as you mentioned with
these very important grand prix
events coming up
he's a fantastic player uh has a
very universal style i think he tends to
shy away from tactics uh more so likes
positions where he can
slowly outplay his opponents
from a solid foundation and he's doing
just that in this game and now after
rook to b3 the knight is under attack so
where are you going to retreat this
knight to knight c4
makes a lot of sense to me
just attacking the pawn a5 also
having knight e5 check
up your sleeve and that means there's no
rook before fiona in fact like knight
to
here before 95 check
uh the king
can't go to f6 because of rook g6 check
and the king can't go to e7 because of
knight c6 check so
something like this
would force the king to the back rank
and
i think maybe we could even bring our
own king
bring the king up and
try to uh deliver a checkmate
not another question
yeah i like this idea what are the other
options
um
knight c4 just
speaks to me
and then the knight can just go e5
knight to c6 things like that and i just
don't see how
black is going to keep everything
together especially with the white's
king marching up the board in the near
future
but with it yeah i'm not so curious
i don't know if he's nervous for sure
he's very
very focused he might get nervous if he
let's say he spends five minutes on this
next move which i don't think he will do
but i think that's the
like if he's only under two minutes and
still for like five moves to go for
everyone who's watching if you're not
sure we're currently on move
53
so seven moves uh are left to be made
before the players get the final
15 minute increment
not increment
additional time
yeah the increment is there and it will
remain
and
we see here that
vida is thinking
i s no f5 comes to mind but the knight
on b6 is under attack so you want to
deal with that threat before you play f5
um i'm surprised he hasn't already
played your move knight c4 which looks
so natural
you just get into these moments fiona
where
like second
third
you're just like guessing yourself
non-stop and you want to triple check
the position
but i think that vidit knows that he
should win this game he just does not
want to make a mistake so
psychologically he's just trying to
prevent that from happening but i feel
like oftentimes when you're
super worried and you're overly cautious
that's when you don't win one positions
yeah i'm also i'm not sure when was the
last time that village played a
classical time control tournament i
think he played the world wrapping in
blitz and he also played
the tata steel rapid and blitz in india
but classical
i think it's been a little while and
then i think
for a lot of players when they come back
to the board after such long hiatus
especially then you get a winning
position like
um
i think some nerves or some adrenaline
and you i think you just want to keep
all that um
in check so i think he's doing great as
long as the time doesn't take down
too low i think he's absolutely right to
be to be taking his time
well he did just give up the a4 pawn
and
he went king e5 which
leaves me he wants to go f5 next and oh
look at this if he had started with f5 i
guess there was knight takes d4 as a
tactic because the king can't take on d4
as there is a problem on the fourth rank
a skewer there so very nice um
that's why he would start with king e5
and he's trying to get out of that but
after rook takes a4
pawn f5 maybe there's knight c5 now
there's no
this pawn is pinned on the fourth rank
and
that could be a bit of an issue that
i need to deal with
yeah i mean it just shows you these
lines show you even this game which
looked like oh it's just a clean pawn at
first and then two clean pawns knights
are tricky pieces and that's why also
sam is absolutely i think some has done
a great job and i absolutely take back
what i said earlier about you know he's
just
sinking in i i was absolutely
wrong and i think sun has done great to
just keep that's what you have to do you
have to keep asking questions and keep
asking questions
and most of the time the opponent will
answer all your questions but sometimes
he doesn't and that that's when you get
rewarded for for putting up maximum
fight
yeah and
sam is doing a great job of keeping
himself in this game f5 was just played
so knight c5
is an option and what else because the
knight needs to go somewhere if you're a
knight to
f8 or some kind of knight retreating
move
i'm wondering if white can play pawn to
f6 or
if the king will
try to venture in to a square like d6
and go from there but
i'm still looking for a mating net
against the black king it feels like
white is making progress there
yeah i wonder how we can bring our rook
uh finally get that rook in it feels
like that rook has been standing on g4
for a while now
well i guess once the knight moves you
play rook g3 rook b3 and
go up to b7
that might be what the doctor ordered
i like that idea a lot it feels like
it's time for our work to to join the
game
and sam is still thinking where is that
night gonna go
i like your suggestion of knight c5 with
this tricky little move as well
at the very least it causes white to
calculate all sorts of things that
knight might come into d3 it might come
back to d7 with check the d4 pawn is a
bit vulnerable so
knight c5
will force vidit to come up with a reply
and of course taking on c5 not possible
the rook on g4 is loose
justin wants to know how there could
possibly be a mating net here with a
knight rook and pawn and with a king
near the center of the void
how could there be a meeting net so
let's try to create one
um
see how can i
force the issue it's not easy to do but
like let's say black kind of plays into
white's hands and goes like rook a1 here
and then this rook comes to g7 with
check and the king has to go to e8 all
of a sudden your king's in the last uh
rank and it's not just getting
checkmated but white also has these this
past pawn that you have to deal with and
here um f7 and
rook to g8 probably is uh
sufficient for a win the king can walk
into d6 and continue
posing problems
for this king on e8 so
it's just that the king is about to be
stuck and facing a vicious attack
and sam has decided to not go for it so
he's gone to f8
okay
and
oh there's another mating net wait a
second
so
okay king d6 looks good because this
knight
can't move to d7 so i took away a square
and if you play rook to a1 i play rook
to e4
and my idea now is my rook e7 check and
force your king back to g8 so like if
you make a movie rook f1
i give you a check
king to
g8 knight f6 check
king h8 and this would be checkmate in
one if the knight were not in f8 so i'll
play rook f7 and
bye bye
that's a very very cute pattern with
this rook f7 in the end attacking the
knight and black is is helpless either
the knight is going to drop or they will
be mated
on h7 so a lovely lovely
tactic there so
king d6
kingdom 6 indeed looks
like a nice move
a white with a
lot of threats coming up and not clear
how black can defend against them
and i can understand if it doesn't want
to move the king there because the d4
pawn is a bit loose but black has to
move and white is just going
right after the black king it's
sometimes difficult to put yourself in
that mental position of and there it is
king to d6 by vidit and he's playing
this so well and i was about to say when
you pass pawns you often want to push
them but you need to
maximize the potential of your position
and pushing the pawn up to f6 actually
would have allowed that knight to jump
out from f8 to g6 or e6 so it's like kd6
played the knight is dominated by a pawn
three squares away i often discuss this
early stages of a g of a game when a
pawns on c3 and knights and c6 things
like that but this still holds true deep
into this endgame here and just because
it's an endgame does not mean that there
isn't pressure and isn't an attack this
is a real attack and black's king is in
trouble
absolutely and i mean we just looked at
the move rook a1
um
it was in this position that you had
suggested okay one right yeah
followed by by f6 but
it's hard to see another plan i mean the
night at the moment as you said the only
night the
square the knight has is h7 and we
certainly don't want to go there
the king doesn't well the king has one
move with
to go to eight but that's also not
really a move we want to play
so
black will probably have to to
try and move that rook
and maybe you keep it in touch with the
pawn on d4 but the plan is just
straightforward rook e4
rookie 7 and knight f6 check is the you
know knockout to force the king into the
corner so
i
yeah i'm not really seeing much after
this rookie four move coming for black
to do
to try and hold this game it looks like
white's just dominating all across the
board
yeah absolutely and i agree with you i
think vidit uh has done great i think as
an outsider it's easy to get um
to get
the feeling
that oh he could have gone faster this
could have ended soon i saw a few
comments in the chat of people coming
back and being like oh is this still
going on
and i think it's just very often
harder to convert these positions
than it looks like to us
the bar has been screaming for four
hours you know plus two plus uh three
but sitting at the board and and
fighting it out is always such a such a
different
uh story and i think all in all uh as
you said i think that it has done a
fantastic job and i think now he's very
close to to converting this into a full
point
i agree and i did see a question yes i
read the chat about that line we're
looking at it's a great question in fact
uh with the sequence of rook a1
rookie 4
rook f1 this whole thing that i was
showing rookie 7 check king g8 knight f6
king h8 force rook f7 the knight can't
move because there's mate and so rook
takes f5 was the question because at the
rook fa check king g7 you attack rook
and knight at the same time but white
has this move king to e6 which is a
fantastic move to play because you
defend your knight while attacking this
rook so if black takes the rook on f8
then he loses the rook on f5 and wipes
up a piece so a really good question
that rook takes f5 almost does the trick
there with king the g7 to follow but
unfortunately for black this king e6
move can be played and after the rook
moves away somewhere let's say well rook
f4 doesn't help knight h5 check but
let's say rook here then there's a move
like rook to g8 check and because the
king protects the rook that is the game
white wins
very nice and a great question
indeed
so if it wasn't for that saving resource
this would be a great try for black but
uh thankfully for video he has this king
e6
uh resource and we see sam is still
thinking but he just gave a slight
shake of the
of the head
because i i think we just went pretty
much to all the pieces that can legally
move
and
unfortunately there's just
no good no good move here
not just that there is no good move but
there is
we were talking about playing moves that
keep asking questions
and keep posing problems
and here vidit has managed to improve
all his pieces in such a way that i
think
um
that i think there's just no more
resistance i think sam has put up great
resistance but
uh vidit has uh
has cleverly um
avoided
any any problems
yeah i think that
the winning path is very easy to see
like rookie four
rookie seven both players are looking
that and sam's like oh uh there's
nothing i can do once that happens to
even prolong the game so
shanklin's been fighting he's been doing
really well just to stay in the game
this long but now that we've reached
this position with the activity of
white's pieces
the positioning of the black king that's
actually in some serious danger vidit
now is
closer and closer to that victory
absolutely and
i know i said this two hours didn't i
say two hours ago we could see
resignation here
um which also i was absolutely wrong but
here i think
we could
genuinely see
a resignation any moment
i would play it out if i were sam you
know just force vidit to
find
whatever accurate moves remain it
doesn't seem
that challenging right now for vidit and
he's fully concentrated and has been
throughout the game
and sam he has the body language now of
somebody who's in the process of
resigning like he's looking like he's
like this is this is it i'm lost nothing
to do here uh but you just have to fight
at least what would you play rook c4 to
at least keep an eye on the pawn on d4
yeah rook c4 but still rookie four and
i don't know i don't know what next like
you want to push your a pawn but same
problem arises with that checkmate of
squeezing the black king into the corner
so
yeah
i just don't have answers
and
so what about any of these other moves
that we we talked if we don't move the
rook what about king
king e8 is just too terrible you know
with
i think we're walking straight into the
net
yeah
rookie four comes to check and yeah it
doesn't seem like much has been solved
there
and you have to move your rook and watch
the game come to an end
yeah people are asking about knight h7 i
have said h7 is the only the only square
we can go to
so well let's have a look knight
h7 i think the answer is pawn f6
because now i'm throwing rook g7 check
which
uh wins your knight and if you take this
pawn in f6 white has rook f4 pinning the
knight and
that's game
yeah
that seems convincing
there's a question did sam resign no so
we are watching the live
camera feed sam uh is still thinking
but i think we're
we are getting now to towards the end um
the end of the
of the game
i agree with you i guess sam is going to
make
a rook move and vidit will play rookie
four
maybe we'll maybe we'll even get to that
moment where maybe it would be nice to
see it play out on the board this uh
rookie seven
knight f6 and uh
rook f7
that would be a nice finish to the game
but we'll see what happens
and
i do feel this way of course
players resign all the time they know
the position is lost and it's often a
sign of respect to the opponent but
sometimes it's nice for the fans to get
to see a checkmate or a
a nice knockout
like a checkmate in the corner
it's good for the broader game even if
it doesn't feel good for the player they
are making up for all the action we
missed out on in the duval film and the
earth game
okay it looks like sam
did in fact play knight h7
and
okay f6 is definitely the move yeah f6
looked very very convincing
that is plenty of time so he doesn't
need to rush these choices as we've been
reminding people there's a 30 second
increment with every move made so
even if he gets down to three seconds on
this move once he presses the clock
we'll get to 33 seconds and so on so
uh he
is going to play f6 there's no way he
doesn't
and there's no tricks i guess after f6
if knight takes ook f4
but there are no
i was thinking of course if black could
take the last pawn on d4 that would be a
theoretical draws you cannot win
knight and
knight and rook against rook but i guess
there is simply no way
yeah that's a good point though
something to keep in mind for people who
would like to improve it defending
positions like this if black could take
these two pawns as fiona was saying for
the cost of this knight over here then
that would be
of course if the rooks weren't staring
at each other but if in generally
speaking rook and knight versus rook
and just kings otherwise that is a
theoretical draw so that's the goal that
sam would like to achieve but i don't
think he's able to do that because the
rook on f4 will pick off the knight and
f6 while defending this pawn on d4s the
knight will be able to take the pin
piece so f6
is powerful and
and there he goes upstairs is on the
board
and instantly king f8 is played
don't play rook g7
that's how you don't win winning
positions because then knight takes f6
this pawn is needed in the defense of
the rook that's coming on g7 so knight
takes f6 gives up that knight but the
rook would lose its defender so rook g7
is a bad bad move in this position what
if i go knight e7
but i'm not even threatening oh no i'm
threatening rook g8 and rook g7 right
trying to go for uh no sorry wait yeah
did i just plunder my pawn
yes i did
okay
we're all out of blunder
no rule against that
so
so if you move then oh but knight b6
comes with tempo so you actually
wait i think 96 does what you were just
trying to make happen where you're
attacking the rook and then you play
knight d7 check and you end up with a
rook check on g7 in the end so actually
that's winning by force
yeah let's have a look at that
knight b6
look
somewhere knight c7
and king it only prolongs by one move
because there's rook g7 and
check and your knight is gone actually
it's just a force checkmate with f7
check coming but
winning the night would have been good
enough
yeah this looks uh first now
and i think that it is
reaching
for the night no for the king
the king comes back to e5
he wants to trap the knight rook g7
actually
wait a second rookie seven that could be
like knight takes f6 ideas still so work
h4 but the knight
g5 it feels like black still has a
little bit of life here
i'm shocked actually knight b6 looked so
forcing
black's pieces still can't really move
very much can they true
very true
um
i'm sorry
now if it were my move now i could go my
knight e7
which i was trying to box through
so what i'm gonna do let's say okay one
i guess
and activate to work
i think you have to do something like
that
and then even knight f4 i'm just trying
to bring that knight into the game
yeah this is
and then h7 is trapped over here
yeah
and it's probably never getting out
rookie one has been played by sam
and the next move by the way is going to
be move 60 so after they make the next
move the players will receive 15
additional minutes
so
fitted
not concerned about his clock because of
that
60
and
there must be many ways to win but you
just want to win the game i guess
you don't mean a position where you're
still struggling and that's how one
positions
are not won and they do say the hardest
game to win is a one game right
absolutely and i i really feel that that
is true like universally true across
uh across all all levels it feels
different of course but um
i don't think anyone escapes that
that rule
no
and
vidit
still super concentrate here he is
not for a second taking his eye off of
this board even when he's walking around
he still has the game in his mind's eye
he's still
calculating and
he would like nothing more than to
secure the victory he's just a few moves
away now he can bring his knight back to
f4 threatening knight e6 check
which will be devastating for black to
deal with and then the king can tuck
itself on f5 for white hiding in front
of the knight so while the rook tries to
check it a bunch the knight will be
stopping the check so let's say if i go
knight f4 and
and you give a check and i go to f5
and i try to pin you with rook f1
rook g7 doesn't work again because of
knight
that tactic is always annoying so rook
h4
does the trick because the only way to
save the knight is by playing kingdom g8
and then you f7 check and then you're
able to sacrifice your rook for
the knight and promote so very nice and
vivid has just played knight f4
okay
he's
well on the path
g peterson in the chat is asking what if
it did flags well if he had flagged on
the
previous move he would have lost the
game um now he's not gonna flag because
he
uh
he now has an extra 15 and
an extra 15 minutes on the clock
and
um
[Music]
yeah for some i think we're getting to
the end let's remind everyone for his
win today let's not fix it but with it
probably about two wrappings up here he
will get a one point so we have a
classical scoring system it is a 14
player single round robin one of the
longest
events and the most traditional of the
the tour
and also the longest time control so the
players have just made moves 60 or at
least
viditas some will make the 60s move with
his next move and they get extra 15
minutes
i think sam is
three to four moves away from resigning
it just you you know you kind of have to
give the check on e1 the king tucks
itself on f5 with rook h4 to follow and
once you're down a full piece it's just
it's just done
yeah it's hard to
see how you hold on to the knight for
more than three or four moves
that's the knights on the rim are dim
and this knight
no exception to that it's a trapped
piece
and white has those pawns that have been
push up the board and yeah it's just
a matter of sam making a couple moves
absolutely and then well after after
this game is over i guess we will be
hearing uh from vidit i see there's a
couple of people in the chat who are
maybe just joining us now so maybe we
can bring up the results so far uh one
more time since we had a couple of
people
asking so so far out of the six games
which have finished
we had two decisive uh results duda
beating uh rapport in an interesting
game and the jordan went for his same
and taking out nice grandiose which was
a repeat of
last year's last round
result
and the others were all drawn as some
very exciting games especially the one
between dubrov
and mamedyarov in which a draw was
offered in a very very exciting
positions but we're not we're not gonna
go back there and so now we're just
waiting for this game between vidit and
sam shankland to conclude
and
[Music]
it has been a fascinating day two wins
and about to be three so the white
pieces are striking in the first round
and that's no surprise the first move
does give the player an advantage
that's long been the case sort of the
mantra of top players is
win with white draw with black right you
need to hold with the black pieces and
then try to make the most of having the
first move edge and some players were
able to do that today others were not
but still early it's just the first game
of a 13-round tournament the players
will be in vikings a for a couple weeks
many rounds to make up if they are
behind the scoreboard they can string
together a few wins and every player in
this field is capable of beating
everyone else absolutely and there we
have to schedule the tournament we'll
conclude on january the
30th so still as you said a couple of
weeks away puttypanna in the chat is
asking didn't fiona guess both those
results unfortunately not i had i had
duda to win but my other pick i think
was anish
so i had one one correct win i think
robert had somehow managed to escape the
entire prediction i know he predicted
fabiano to win
i think i said that i don't even
remember because i was avoiding it
but i i do think that i
have zero correct answers but you also
you did i think you only predicted the
first two and then
i took over i thought i'll let i let
rubble off the hook it's the first
day i do appreciate that by the way
and king e8 played by shanklin he wants
to be able to retreat his knight back to
f8 and so the game does in fact continue
here i think rook g8 check just that's
that right because if the king goes up
after rook g8 check
then you lose the knight by rook g7 and
if the knight retreats to f8 the knight
g6
is a winning move with a pin of the
the knight on uh
f8 but uh what about in that line um
so can we put that on the board rook g8
knight f8 knight g6 what if i give a few
checks and then go king f7
yeah that's a good question
um so you give me a check
king e5
maybe this isn't
the easy win i thought it was going to
be because if i ever king d6 you'll work
e6 check but if i go king
d5 you want king f7
oh chess is hard even when it's winning
it's like still
have to prove it all over again
you know like
see this is why sam is smart to continue
the game maybe it will play
a poor move like i did
okay robert i suggest we take a final
quick break we'll leave the players on
camera and we'll be back in just a few
minutes uh for the end of this game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we're back for the final part here
of this
round one of the tata steel justinman
2022
vedic is still fighting to get the full
point against sam shanklin but robert it
looks like he is making big progress now
and a great lesson
in how to convert a winning position he
did not rush he did not play knight g6
which probably was winning uh with
precise play he just went d5 so that he
could put his knight on e6 in the near
future or he can just use his d-pawn as
a decoy that the king will have to take
it then rook will be able to win this
knight over here on f8 so i really like
what vivid has done he's showing
excellent technique sam has been putting
up a great fight most players would have
lost many moves ago but sam made vids
life as difficult as possible and yet it
is vita gujarati who is still going to
get his first tournament victory here in
the 2022 tata steel tournament
absolutely and things are under control
for him now it's always nice when your
king is standing in a spot where it
cannot be checked where it isn't in any
danger
uh sam's king meanwhile has been pushed
back to the
uh the first rank uh where it is
tied well where the knight is
is pinned tied to the king
and uh yeah it just looks like there's
too many threats now knight e6 just
pushing the d pawn
and black
cannot move the knight any longer
can move the king to f7 but that isn't
going to help
um
so yeah i think the end
really is near now
yes and schengen's still calculating
he's really working
at the board here he's not
given up he may mentally be ready to
resign he knows that the game is winning
for vidit but he's really trying to make
things as complicated as possible and
that's the way to save games like this
you need to be resourceful you need to
dig deep you need to find every last
effort that is confusing for your
opponent or says that there's only one
way to win and make your opponent find
it but in a position like this the way
vid has been playing it's not surprising
that he is about to secure the full
point
yeah absolutely and
some
um
sort of going through the through the
motions here looking
uh
looking at this position one last time
but there is just um there is nothing
and
with it here make having
been made to work very hard for for the
full point but
i think these players uh it doesn't
matter even if they have to sit at the
board every time for seven hours i think
a full point is always so sweet in this
kind of um
super super elite tournament so they
don't mind and the time goes by quite i
don't know if you can relate robert
probably but the time goes by quite uh
goes by quite quickly when when you sit
at the board
it does you don't even realize how long
the game just went then you try to stand
up and you're like well my legs are
wobbly i've been sitting here for a long
time and then you you know you talk to
your opponent do an interview walk back
to the hotel you get to the hotel you
sit down you're like i am
exhausted i need to sleep and then you
look at the clock no i can't sleep for a
couple more hours and guess what you
need to prepare for the next day so
the
challenge remains for vida to win this
game and then as we saw earlier his
second round pairing is white against
the other american player fabiano
caruana so vidic gets the double white
he gets the back-to-back americans and
well he wants to make this tournament a
hugely successful one
absolutely and then tomorrow i'll i've
somehow managed to miss it earlier but
uh
i'm sure the the chat won't have missed
that karjakin will be playing duboff
there was a bit of drama going on there
in the aftermath of the the match
and then while carlson
anisha especially here at tata steel
where anish's on home turf
is always an exciting one
and shanklin gets the white pieces
against niels grandilius tomorrow so
that should be interesting we'll see
what sam will cook up at home for his
preparation uh but that's also one of
those trap games where you're like oh
i'm playing niels he's low rated than i
am he's the second lowest rated player
in the field after pragnanda like that's
a game i have to win no there are no
have to's in a tournament like this
niels can beat any player in this field
with the black pieces so you can't get
into that mindset you can't be results
oriented
but in this moment right now of course
the players are results-oriented it's
towards the end of the game and vidit he
is
he really played a nice game today i
thought that he held
control the route he never gave shanklin
any chance to play for an initiative and
shanklin tried his best to hold steady
and yet vidit was able to
outplay him in this endgame
in hindsight would you say that this uh
what was it was it f6
the f6 move by some
what was the movement it was f6 yeah
in hindsight would you think that that
was one of the
the turning points where things really
became very difficult
yeah i think it was just the type of
position
that arose from the opening like
it was a situation where yes the engine
says white's only slightly better but
you never feel like you're coming close
to equalizing you start seeing all these
ideas that vidit has and so shanklin's
sitting there trying to figure out okay
he can do this that a third thing maybe
eight different options and what am i
gonna do i'm gonna respond to those
options but i can't create counter play
for myself and he tried his best he did
strike when the moment called for it
with c5 earlier in the game but
ultimately he never really had a chance
to play
for anything but
neutralizing his disadvantage and that's
not comfortable a lot of players don't
enjoy that
one player who's fine with it as
mentioned numerous times this point is
karjakin and he was able to survive
today's game but most players just are
miserable
sitting and trying to defend a
two-result position
yeah it's uh those are some depressing
uh some depressing days at the office
unfortunately
it just happens sometimes
so yeah tough day tough day at the
office for some but as we mentioned
and full with it it's a great start
a great start to the tournament what's
sam's remaining clock time around 15
15 minutes
but i i think this looking back
often indicates where is my
my opponent
um
sometimes looking around when you it's
it's frustrating when you want to resign
i'm not saying that's what's happening
here but it has happened before that you
want to resign and your opponent is just
not there
right it's like i want this game to end
now i know i've been making you find
accurate moves for
over six hours but right now i just want
to go where are you
why is that video running yeah it is
[Laughter]
oh gosh maybe he saw sam looking for him
and he was like i'm here
and don't you worry
uh you know he
has plenty of time but you don't really
want to have your clock ticking and then
need that time that you lit a lapse so
that was pretty funny though
did it sprinting back from the bathroom
but no time has elapsed because um
is still is the thing i think sometimes
you can also just if you're not totally
sure how much time you had or how much
how long you were gone for like that's
the last thing you want to to return to
the board and suddenly it's like
the clock says you have 10 seconds i
sometimes have nightmares about that
kind of
stuff like i come to the board and the
tr position has been changed or the
clock has like all my time has
disappeared
so yeah you want to talk about it
do you want to talk about it
i'll talk about it with chat rover don't
worry
i don't know it just sounds like this is
something that you uh you know struggle
with and i just want to make sure that
you knew that i was here if you wanted
to discuss it i appreciate that
do you never have chess nightmares
i don't dream about chess ever
are you serious
i'm completely serious but you do dream
i do dream
interesting
i dream a dream of time gone by
such a poet
[Laughter]
um
yeah no i don't dream about chess ever
so
i
can't totally relate but i will listen
and i will take it in i'll give you just
an ear to speak to my one of my worst
chess nightmares was uh when they
introduced the the zero tolerance rule i
had a couple of nightmares that it was
like a big tournament like the olympiad
and i couldn't find my board
and i knew i was gonna be defaulted i
was in the playing hall but i just
couldn't find
couldn't find the board so very very
stressful dreams
i i honestly that does sound stressful
um wow i i can't even imagine how i
would feel if i woke up from
that kind of nightmare but
meanwhile in the game um
thankfully they have made some moves
with that d-pawn now all the way up
on d6 just two two squares away
from becoming a new queen so sam is
trying to stop by that by putting his
own rook behind the d-pawn but here
finally comes this move we've been
talking about for a long time
knight g is six and
now the black knight on f8 is going to
drop and very important fit it is going
to
save one of the two pawns
right he's going to bring his king to e5
then bring his king to d5 and
then you have to deal with both those
pawns that are advanced and even if you
end up trading knights rather than
losing the knights that pawn that was on
d4 is now on d6 and the king is helping
support it so it will reach the other
side promote and black can at best
sacrifice the rook for it in which case
it's just a lost position
and i wonder where vidit is going to
hide the king
and now he's off on d5 maybe he will
hide behind the black pawn
that'll be something
i mean
so many checks but the king can just
keep sprinting
king c6
king c6 is on the board indeed
do you think that's january generally
genuinely where he's off to a6
he might stop at b5 and then decide do i
want to take the pawn or do i want to
hide on a6 both of which are
completely winning
some has paused but
what are the alternatives to keep
backing
i mean right now there's a mate in one
thread of rook um
book takes f8
and if king f7
rook takes that f8 king takes g6 the
problem is this pawn is going to d7 and
promoting so
that doesn't help he gives another check
but the king can just run and i don't
think it matters
where fiddle puts that king right now
yeah i agree with you he's probably
going to go to b5
and then if another check comes he can
think about as you said does he want to
take the pawn on a5 does he want to hide
the king
this is the
you know
a little bit of a sad question but is
there anything worse than losing like a
six plus hour chess game
no actually i find these really brutal
especially a game like today where you
never
you never
like those games where you just defend
the whole game and you sort of
know from the start this is not gonna be
a fun day and
and it isn't a fun day and
yeah these are rough
yeah it's one of these games if you make
a one move blunder and you drop your
queen you can just like all right that
won't happen again but then when you
lose a game like this where you're
outplayed pretty much from the earliest
stages then you start getting in your
own head like am i not playing well like
what do i need to work on
is this not am i not in form
and then you start questioning a lot of
things so i think for vidiq couldn't ask
for a better start for shanklin i mean
it's really a
rough
beginning to this event of course he can
right the ship at any moment he gets the
white pieces tomorrow
but this has not been a game that he has
enjoyed that's for sure
but robert what do you find worse the
kind of game that we saw today where you
don't have a chance or and you lose
after six hours plus or if you were
winning and then lose
oh
yeah uh winning
like when you're well ahead and you lose
that feels terrible that's for sure it's
even worse right but that those are
probably the worst
um but yeah today today hasn't been
hasn't been a fun day but i think we're
coming
towards the end uh of the church and
again it's not to say i think we've
we've pointed out plenty of times i
think sam did fantastic and really
pushed uh vidic to the limit to
who had to remain vigilant at all times
there were a lot of tricks
along the way i think i had for example
written off the same game way too soon
so
he did he did fight but i fit it
just stayed on his guides and didn't
allow any tricks
and that's the
thing about these
2700 plus super grand masters is that
even in lost positions
they make your life a nightmare they're
like you're not gonna win without ultra
precision and it may take you 30 more
moves and these two are used to it right
they they know that when they're playing
their colleagues that it's never going
to be easy but i think it's something
that we can often take for granted if
we're not in the events ourselves or
we're just like watching with an engine
just like how difficult the task has
been for vidit and
now look at sam play king to d7
giving up his knight which was pinned
and he's just trying to win those final
two pawns you said this a long time ago
fiona if somehow sam can take both d and
f pawns he will draw this game so that
it still
needs to be careful and keep that in
mind
absolutely
so that is i guess what sam is still
trying
to do
now
but vidit has captured the knight on f8
with the rook
uh and all he needs to do now is be
careful not to lose that final
f pawn so let's have a look at this
position
can we
go f7 immediately yeah f7 for sure wins
because you can put your knight on h8
and then move your rook and then promote
it's a very weird
uh move but knight h8 will
help free the rook
you know i see this question in the chat
and it's one of the questions that i've
been finding hardest to answer lately
with so many new people coming into jazz
and the question about um in this case
it was asked by james smith
what are they writing on the notes i
don't know much about competitive chess
and the question of why do they
write down the moves and i've i found it
quite too hard to answer other than it
is a tradition and
um what's your answer
yeah dude you know people these days
even know how to write anymore with pen
and paper like you know we're typing all
the time using our phones
but it is a tradition there are certain
moments where it's necessary where let's
say you're
approaching a move 40 but you can't ask
anybody what move are we on you need to
know what movie you're on
as you approach time control so those
are the moments where knowing the move
is important otherwise i think it's
often just a waste of paper and you know
that's not great for the environment so
we could save some trees by not notating
and they don't notate a quicker time
control so if you've been watching rapid
and blitz chess no notation to be found
there and i don't really think it's very
necessary
in this day and age but maybe i'm not
looking at the whole picture and why
it's a good thing that we notate at this
point of course there is also as brick
pointed out here that the three-fold
repetition in those cases it's also
useful
and yeah in general i mean it's a
tradition that i like
um i hope it doesn't go
anywhere but
yeah i agree with you that there are
many cases now
where it's become a little bit redundant
so
the king the white king has found
shelter now on a4
then plays king e6
and there it is knight h8 knight e5 also
is winning
and there is the handshake
indeed and a deserved victory for vidi
but look at sam shanklin he's really
upset right now
probably frustrated with the way he
played and vidit on the other hand he
should be all smiles he just won a fine
technical game in the first round in
tata steel chess 2022.
absolutely kudos
to
vidit i'm sure we will be hearing for
him in a quick interview but a tough day
for some who
looks visibly disappointed
robert we are going to take a final
quick break before we come back with the
standings after round one but also our
game of the day recap so stay tuned and
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back for a final time to this
first round of the tata steel
2022
robert i think actually well i see that
fitted is getting ready for an interview
so we might hear from vidit first and
then we'll just have a quick look at the
results understandings after day one but
let's go straight with
uh it congratulations that was a lot of
hard work
yeah it's it should have been easier um
i felt like close to move 35 or
something i had a big advantage
and probably my technique
at that point was not the best so i
really had to
get down and start thinking after a
while
[Music]
and i feel like i played decently
towards the end maybe he had some
chances i don't know
but
i felt like i did the best i could after
a certain point yeah well
maybe chances
but only little chances for draw i mean
and and it was for the whole game
that you were better better better all
the time and pressing
yeah i mean out of the opening i don't
think i was really better he almost
equalized but at some point he started
to play um
for activity with c5 and stuff like that
which allowed his pawns to be very weak
and i managed to gain an advantage after
that um
but
i feel at that point it should have been
very close to winning but i allowed him
some counter play that's why it was a
long game
okay but in the end you pre-failed so
yes congratulations yeah i'm happy with
that thank you
so vivid despite the fact he felt he
allowed some counter chances of course
thrilled with his victory here to start
this tata steel chest tournament 2022.
so he joins a juradin van forest
and young krishov duda in the lead here
after they won
did those three players have won their
games so do that vid and van for race
then a big group of course on uh of
players on half out who drew their games
today
and at the bottom the tree those who
were on the losing andrew a porridge
shankland and grendelus and then robert
one more time what do we have to look
forward to tomorrow
we have some great match-ups of course
uh the highlight magnus versus aneesh uh
the russian derby between karjak and
dubo especially with their recent
let's just say controversy
sparked by what sergey thought was
disrespect towards russia by duba
working with carlson but all that aside
one game i am particularly interested in
is rapport with the white pieces against
von forrest because when you lose a game
you often want to just win the next game
you like you need to right the ship you
need to score and so rapport is the
white pieces he's the higher rated
player against jordan von forest but
jordan is exceptionally well prepared
though rapport is maybe the hardest
person in the world to prepare for
because he plays something new pretty
much every game so i'm really excited to
see what the opening of that game is
like how that one goes but i think that
either player can win that game
absolutely some very exciting clashes
and tomorrow we will be we'll be back
for round two uh the round will start at
2 p.m central european time that's 5 a.m
pacific time
and we will be live i believe around 10
to 15 minutes before the start of the
round with some
three round uh action
so robert today has been a lot of fun uh
thank you so much for being here by my
side a big thank you to the chat
and the first round of many many more to
come
well it was a pleasure thank you fiona
for being alongside me for what was a
great first day i'm so stoked for the
rest of this tournament absolutely thank
you so much for watching have a lovely
night or day depending on where you are
and we will see you tomorrow for round
two
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you